e
excuse me briefly everyone uh someone
filled out a card but didn't put their
name on it um if this looks like your
handwriting or you want to come by and
fully
e
morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs as you know
we have a couple of very important bills
today to be heard by the committee but
before we get to those I'd like you to
please join me in the Pledge of
Allegiance
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible through liberty
all thank you
everyone before I begin the hearing on
House Bill 377 fan I'd like to go over
how we're going to proceed today uh we
have a lot of people interested in in
testifying on this bill as you might
well imagine it's an important issue
regardless of what side you're on uh in
order to get through everyone and a
reasonable fashion uh we do have to
limit testimony uh the practice of this
committee has been that the prime
sponsor has given extra time because
they were the one who developed the bill
they're going to explain that process
they're going to explain why they did it
and and the whole focus and background
of that once we get past the prime
sponsor we will have to insist that
testimony be limited to 3 minutes it's
the only way we're going to get through
all of the folks who want to testify and
we want to give everybody an equal
chance if you're still speaking at three
minutes I'm going to ask you to start
wrapping up I will give you 15 seconds
to start wrapping up at the end of those
15 seconds regardless of where you are
in your testimony I am going to thank
you for that testimony and ask the
committee if they have any questions and
again I I appreciate appreciate the
importance of this issue I appreciate
everyone's feelings on this issue but
the only way we're going to get through
this if we adhere to that and and again
I want to be Equitable to everyone and
so with that I will recognize
representative Lisa Maser Prime sponsor
of House Bill 377 FN and ask her to
please uh present the
Bill thank you Mr
chair and hello to members of my
committee as well good morning for the
record my name is Lisa Maser I represent
Hillsboro District 44 the towns of gtown
and wear thank you for the opportunity
to speak on this critical issue and I
know it's an emotional one I stand
before you to address the growing
use of puberty blockers and hormone
treatments in minors practices that
carry significant medical risks and
long-term
consequences I'd like to begin with an
undeniable truth children cannot fully
fully comprehend the lifelong
implications of altering their bodies
with powerful
medications yet we are witnessing a
concerning Trend where children some as
young as 3 years old are being seen as
patients in gender clinics children as
young as eight or nine are being
prescribed puberty blockers and cross-
sex hormones often a after just a few
hours of
consultation while I understand that
gender dysphoria is real and painful
rushing miners into irreversible medical
interventions is not the answer these
treatments build as re reversible and
harmless come with serious risks and
these are not just abstract
possibilities they are already becoming
tragic realities for young people across
the country and across the world puberty
blockers drugs like Lupron were
originally developed to treat prostate
cancer and
endometriosis when given to children
they halt the critical hormonal surges
of puberty preent preventing bone growth
brain development and fertility from
progressing naturally the journal of
clinical endocrinology and Metabolism
has reported that children who use
puberty blockers suffer bone density
loss increasing their risk of
osteoporosis the FDA recently added a
warning that these drugs may cause
lasting damage to the brain spine and
and kidneys studies show that up to 98%
of children placed on puberty blockers
go on to take crossx hormones a pathway
that makes them lifelong medical
patients scientists at the
world-renowned Mayo Clinic carried out a
study and found that puberty blockers
lead to fertility problems withering
testicles and even cancer among children
who take them in recent years seven
countries across Europe and that number
is growing by the day and many states
across the USA and that number is also
growing by the day have taken
significant steps to totally restrict or
halt the use of puberty blockers and
cross- seex hormones for minors we are
talking about
children their decisions were driven by
comprehensive reviews of the available
evidence which revealed profound
concerns about the long-term impact of
these medical interventions on young
people and what's most alarming many
children begin this process before
they're even old enough to drive Vote or
make decisions about their own Medical
Care you will hear today that if these
children go don't go through these
procedures they are more likely to
commit
suicide page 195 of the Cass report
showed that child sex procedures don't
actually prevent suicide ACLU attorney
Chase strango admitted in response
before the Sue Supreme Court
that there's quote no evidence that
these procedures actually reduce
suicides now I'm going to speak from the
heart and I might get emotional so I'm
sorry because I've spoken personally
with these families who have been
devastated by these
treatments parents who believed they
were making the right decision to
support their children only to find that
those children later suffered greatly
from the irreversible change es to their
bodies and I have done the research on
this guys I have seen the photos and I
can't unsee them so that's why I'm here
today one mother who supported her
daughter through medical transition now
watches her grown child struggle with
severe depression infertility and
chronic health issues her words quote we
thought we were helping her but instead
we've taken her future away finland's
leading expert on pediatric gender
medicine and chief psychiatrist at its
largest gender Clinic says quote four
out of five gender questioning children
eventually accept their bodies if no
medical interventions are carried out
they need time and Compassionate Care
not radical medical
interventions you will hear today from
young adults who are rushed into
life-altering decisions without fully
understanding the consequences Khloe
Cole a d transitioner fears that these
treatments will cut children children's
lives short and that the hysterectomies
necessitated by testosterone will lead
to early dementia whether or not these
young women detransition they will
suffer and their doctors will have no
idea how to help them we don't let
miners get tattoos go to tanning salons
buy cigarettes or consume alcohol
because we know they lack the maturity
to make those decisions and that they
may cause later on why then would we let
them make IR reversible medical choices
that will affect their health and
happiness for the rest of their lives we
are in a very difficult societal
situation because medical professionals
have pursued a dangerous protocol
without first establishing a scientific
basis to support it they have misled
both young people and their responsible
adults to believe that quickly accessing
this care is the only option they have I
urge this committee to consider the
scientific evidence and the growing
bipartisan this isn't no longer a party
issue an international consensus that
children should just wait until they're
18 that's what we're saying today wait
until you're 18 on this issue miners
deserve protection from experimental
medical interventions that could cause
lasting harm counseling yes
absolutely we must prioritize their la
long-term well-being over short-term
solutions that may seem compassionate
but do carry significant
risks I'm asking you today please stand
with us in protecting vulnerable
children let's give them time let's give
them space let's give them hope for a
future that isn't divined defined by
irreversible medical mistakes thank you
thank you
questions representative Woods uh thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question uh you quoted some numbers
about the the number of patients uh that
have been harmed by this uh you hav't a
similar handle on a number of patients
that would be harmed if they didn't have
this medical treatment well you'll hear
even in my testimony this afternoon that
just last week um the I mean you know
when we talk about harm the worst harm
is to your self suicide and uh so la
just last week the Journal of sexual
medicine put out a study um that in over
a
100,000 uh people that
underwent um medical
interventions um at the end of this
study there was there was no change it
was actually I'm sorry there was more
people that after going through these
procedures um were commit committing
suicide and that just came out last week
so e and that was a huge study and more
studies like this are coming out every
day that these interventions whether
hormonal or
surgical are not saving
lives follow up oh yeah that it's not my
question my question centered around you
you mentioned again in the answer you
just gave about the harms yep my
question is do you have any handle on
the number of people uh that need this
care and would be denied this care I do
not have that no nobody has that
representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question um
you told us anecdotally about people who
regret having had
treatment have you any actual
statistical information about the regret
rate for this procedure and have you
compared that regret weight with the
procedure for other life-changing
childhood treatments I don't have the
answer to that there's probably people
coming behind me that may have that um
but I don't have those numbers no
because we're talking not even you know
on the national level but it's it's a
global uh situation as
well other questions yes thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking the
question um the bill as part of the uh
description uh has a clause that defines
quote normal
puberty um it's been a while but my
recollection is that there's basically
nothing normal about puberty um and so
I'm curious uh lack a good definition of
what that is how do you expect that to
be implemented and
enforced what is normal puberty here yes
um yeah and iar yes we have medical
providers that are sitting right behind
me that will answer that question I am
not a medical professional um but there
are different ages that people do go
through normal puberty and that is the
stages of that I know that they'll be
talking about so thank
you yes representative Lucas
thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
taking my question um I'm just wondering
have you done any research or listen to
evidence um regarding the regret rate
for these medications when they're used
for other conditions like precocious
puberty for
example yes yep it's coming thank you
yep other
questions I'm seeing none thank you oh
I'm sorry representative haret uh thank
you Mr chair thank you representative
Maser um appreciating your concern about
this medication of these medications I
wondered if you had any moral
disapproval for just the category of
transgender people the moral
disapproval I don't I love everybody so
I
don't as an adult this this is we're
talking about that don't that doesn't
relate to this bill I'm sorry this is
this is harmful procedures on minors and
I feel like that's just kind of moving
into a debate that that's not what this
bill is about but thank you for the
question other
you also signed up to speak is Sam
minutes good morning chairman members of
the committee my name is Sam Hawkins I'm
here today representing Nami New
Hampshire in opposition to House Bill
377 as an organization dedicated to
improving the lives of all people
impacted by mental illness and suicide
we believe that no one should be subject
to policies or practices that can cause
or worsen mental health symptoms and as
such we oppose any legislation that
seeks to prohibit or limit access to
clinically appropriate care for
transgender
individuals is well understood I Believe
by the committee that too often trans
people face stigma discrimination and
challenges accessing necessary care
which all contributes to a like higher
likelihood of poor mental health
outcomes I have specific statistics to
that in my written testimony which I
will distribute but I do want to be
clear and really Hammer home the point
that there is nothing inherent in one's
life as a transor non-binary person that
contributes to mental health rather it
is due to these experiences with
discrimination and an inability to
receive necessary care and
supports everyone's Journey will look
different but access to care can be a
crucial part of that to promoting the
physical and mental health of trans
people of all ages with studies we have
seen showing that access to care can
improve mental health out outcomes
including hormone therapy and when
initiated in adolescence I just further
want to say that all major medical
associations have released statements
supporting gender affirming care our
policies must focus on improving mental
health outcomes for all rather than
impeding the medical decision-making of
families and restricting access to
necessary care trans people like all
people deserve access to the care they
want and need to be well and I encourage
you to please listen to the voices and
stories of trans youth that may come
before you today as you consider this
bill and I thank you for your time thank
you um before I uh go to any possible
questions uh folks could do not block
the doorway it's it's a it's a fire
questions seeing no questions thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Erica lead I represent Rockingham 13
which is the town of Derry and it's good
to see some familiar faces here uh this
bill is very important because doctors
don't always get it right we can look
back to when the American Medical
Association was all right with the Tusk
experiments where black men were allowed
to continue living and infecting people
with syphilis in order to see the
natural course of the disease that was a
tragedy and a disaster that was endorsed
by the medical um establishment so
sometimes doctors don't get things right
we also remember thalidomide um back
before it was a life-saving cure for
blood cancers it was given to moms with
nausea because that was the accepted
medical practice at the time however it
l led to severe deformities of babies
and it had unintended unexpected side
effects when those side effects became
known people looked at the data looked
at the evidence and realized that they
were causing unintentional harm and
changed their
practice the reason we're here today is
because there is growing medical data
and evidence that shows that this is in
fact harmful for children and
unfortunately um there's been an
entrenched view within the medical
establishment that this is the correct
way forward despite mounting evidence in
any other area of medicine they would
reconsider this but quite frankly look
around it's it's scary for a lot of
people to talk about this because a they
feel that people will be told that they
hate trans people when that's not true
and they are also afraid of the
repercussions that will happen to them
socially if they speak about this but
the fact is if you give a young boy
puberty blockers while he is still early
early on in puberty you will sterilize
him for life he will not be able to
develop so that he can have functioning
testes so that he can then bear
children his penis can wither away and
Shrink not just staying the size of an
eight or nine-year-old boy but actually
getting smaller and this is a huge huge
problem for those men who later in life
and throughout their life know that they
want to live as a woman because
traditionally men who want to live as
women who have a procedure um down below
would use that tissue if you're looking
at these young boys you are denying them
the ability to have that reproductive
tissue repurpose to be more functional
you are sentencing them to a life where
they need to use colon tissue to create
a vagina if they proceed in their
medicalization not only are you
sterilizing them before they have before
they have while they're still in the
early stages of their mental development
you are closing the door for medical
interventions that have helped
transgender people over a lifetime it's
not compassionate to give these it's not
compassionate to give these to kids and
I ask that we stand up and we say that
it's time to end this experiment and
protect kids thank you thank you any
please be quiet please be quiet in the
back and thank you for taking my
questions do you have um references that
you can provide for this information um
thank you if others don't provide the
information I can send some of that
along I have a feeling that there'll be
others including medical professionals
to speak about this but if afterwards
you don't have your questions answered
please feel free to reach out to me see
me on campus ask me and I will make sure
you get that data and that information
okay thank
you other questions representative Weber
could you give us some kind of data
about the amount of time that uh these
treatments have been used and in many
cases successfully versus how long it
took to discover the issues with phide
and correct them well thank you this is
a developmental issue the EB and flow of
hormones over a child's development is
not just a onetime switch or a onetime
valve um as you go through this process
there are different times when the
hormones impact your body differently
this goes to development of your brain
it goes to development of your body it
goes to development of your bones um I
am actually expecting a massive rash of
of huge problems with bone density and
we're not just going to see older women
having hip fractures we're going to see
children treated with puberty blockers
with hip fractures and as somebody who
broke my femur I have to tell you that's
not fun and I don't wish it on anybody
um because this is a longer process it's
not going to be the same thing as giving
a mother olomide and then some number of
months later seeing a child um that is
born that is that obviously has issues
um we can look at the Timeline we can
look at the process however would you
consider it successful to sterilize a
child and if so I'm just curious why why
there's push back on adults that want to
sterilize themselves if we're okay with
sterilizing
children
follow the import of my question was not
the amount of time developmentally for
the individual child the import of my
question was how long have these
treatments been in use versus how long
theide was in use before the issues were
discovered well thank you there is a
very very different method of
administration when you're giving
something as a one-time or a limited
basis versus an ongoing treatment when
you have an ongoing treatment you need
longer followup in order to look at the
data um there is Success using these in
precocious puberty and I do want to note
that when we talk about normal puberty
in this bill precocious puberty is not
defined as normal puberty the intention
and what I believe is very clear
language is that precocious puberty is
not impacted by this bill because it is
not normal puberty those children need
to be taken off of it because there are
serious Adverse Events if they stay on
puberty blockers to long you have issues
with height you have other developmental
issues if you have these children who
begin puberty at four five six years old
and they stay on puberty blockers too
long we should learn from that
experience instead of somehow pretending
that this group of people doesn't
deserve the same quality of evidence in
order to protect their health and their
bodies because they do transgender
people people with gender confusion are
wonderful people that need to be
supported and you need to make sure
that people aren't blinding themselves
with kindness to the scientific data we
need to make sure we're not allowing
harms to be
up could you explain your use of the
confusion you can Define it however you
want somebody who somebody who is born
as a girl or born as a boy and they
don't feel comfortable in that gender um
if they don't feel comfortable as a girl
don't feel comfortable as a boy I don't
want to Define somebody's personal
experience and I don't want to
medicalize it either until they are old
enough to know the
consequences everybody has their own
interpretation of their life and I use
that term to talk about those who aren't
born pop out see pink and hair curlers
and act like a stereotypical girl I know
that's not me that's not most girls but
I also I also know everybody has a
process and not everybody always sees
thems one way or the
other representative Woods oh thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um you you pointed out some of
the difficulties in terms of providing
this
care sorry uh you pointed out the
difficulties that some may have uh later
in life if they start at this age uh
medicine as I'm sure you're well aware
is not all one way uh can you you also
identify uh the harm that would be done
by not instituting it at an earlier age
and the difficulties would that would be
uh encountered if it's delayed well
thank you if there were not documented
evidence of harm from this medical
intervention that would be a more
meaningful question however there is
clear evidence of harm to a physical
harm to children um generally when we
look at layers of harm we're usually
trying to look at somebody's Integrity
in their function because in order to
function well throughout life you want
to maintain as much physical health as
possible um I think that it's a it's a
strange place to be where instead of
looking at the data of actual harms
there are theoretical ideas of what
would happen on the other side I could
see a controlled trial it would be one
thing if we had a controlled trial where
people could enroll in this and children
could enroll in it I don't think it
would be ethical but at least we could
have those data but nobody would do that
because those who believe that this is
causing harm would see it unethical as
randomizing children to puberty blockers
and those who believe that it's harm to
deny that would believe that it is
causing harm in order to withhold those
so we'll never see a study of that there
have been some looks at some of the
natural studies and and um samplings but
we know that level of of evidence is
poor follow up um but that's not my
question you said we don't want to cause
harm and I agreed we don't want to do
that but if the study is not done to see
how much benefit is derived and a
similar study provided then we have only
have data on one side and what we need
is is there 10 people being harmed for
one being helped or is it just the
reverse there are people that are being
harmed uh but we have 10 people that are
being helped and so that was my question
which that you just said there is harm
being done let's not do it but my
question is do you know how many are
being helped um well thank you for the
question as a surgeon I understand why
you're looking at this this way because
when you look at clinical trials and you
look at data and Registries for surgery
that is something that you look at
because you look at the risk of
treatment and risk of non-treatment and
the way that surgeries don't have to be
approved by the FDA so you're looking
and trying to get the data and the best
that you can do um even the most of the
implantables don't need the same rigor
approval that drugs need when you're
looking at drugs the first thing you
look at is is harm from that drug um
that is the first process in approving a
drug is this safe you can't even look at
whether it's effective if it's not safe
children other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you
Brown again you have three
minutes good morning my name is Cali
Brown and I'm here today to represent
all transgender Youth and oppos Bill
sorry I am a transgender girl and I am
20 I transitioned when I was 10 years
old I was placed on puberty blockers at
the age of 12 to prevent male puberty
and I started taking estrogen at the age
of 14 me receiving hormone blockers in
therapy was not even a question I needed
this to live my life authentically I
needed these things in order to feel
complete and to feel like myself as far
as I've been told the Purity blockers
are known to be 100% reversible
why are we going to punish the
transgender youth below me to suffer and
live their life in the wrong body
unhappy according to the Trevor Project
in 2022 39% of transgender youth in New
Hampshire have seriously considered
suicide 10% have actually attempted
suicide by following through with this
bill you are going to make these numbers
raise drastically lack of hormone
therapy and Purity blockers will cause
feelings of displacement and uncomfort
which could then lead to the thoughts of
suicide the gender affirming care is not
hurting us in any way shape or form it's
just simply growing us into the person
we truly are inside to me that's all
that matters if we wait till we're 18
the damage is already done in my
situation my voice would be deep and I'd
have a more masculine body shape thank
you for giving me the opportunity to
speak on behalf of transgender youth
thank you any
questions seeing none thank
sure okay uh also signed up to speak is
O'Brien again representative you have uh
you asked for five minutes but three
minutes please got
it um thank you for this opportunity to
speak
uh I think there's a lot of lack of
knowledge on this issue I uh through
Word of Mouth it seems that I uh am a
sympathetic figure to people who have
who have detransitioned and I've gotten
some calls I recently spoke to a
woman um originally from the western
part of the state and she now lives in a
in a city because she can't drive and
she detransitioned and and she thinks
that it was pushed on her the
transitioning to male because it would
be a quick fix for her other mental
health issues and she's angry and wants
to uh wants more medical help with
detransitioning and finds that to be
difficult to find that her the doctors
that helped her transition now will not
that I think that um that this is a sort
of body
dysmorphia that would not be dissimilar
to someone who went to their doctor and
said I need diet pills but that person
was anorexic I think it would be immoral
for the doctor to give them diet pills
and what if that if someone came to
their doctor and said I'm not the
correct race that I should be and I need
some kind of medical intervention to be
A different race no we would stop and
and help them to accept themselves as
they
are telling children that they were born
in the wrong body is not help in the in
the wrong body is not helpful I don't
think it it gives the right message we
ask them to accept themselves in other
circumstances but this why is this an
exception and it should not
be I speak about all of this with some
other Insight my late sister-in-law was
my very best friend she helped me rais
my children she was much older than me
and she recently passed away from
gastrointestin uh intestinal cancer
answer not a smoker ran in the
family She's a Lesbian she called
herself a radical separatist lesbian and
we both were tomboys I was in a
male-dominated field and usually the
only woman in a machine shop where I
worked or a musical instrument
making Martha used to tell me all the
time that she was glad that she did not
live nowadays because that she would
have been pushed to become male and she
said she would have fallen for it and
that one of the last things that I was
able to buy for her when she was very
ill was a t-shirt she found out about
this t-shirt you could get from an
organization called gaze against
groomers I and and she was so happy
about this t-shirt that said leave the
kids alone she wanted me to buy it for
her and I
did she got so sick she couldn't raise
her arms anymore and she couldn't wear
it you have 15 seconds okay while I'm
here to to spread to send that message
as well that that is uh she went through
puberty it was very awkward it is very
awkward it's medical uh definitions of
what is a normal puberty are included in
this bill puberty is not normal or or
it's awkward for everyone and I'll take
questions thank you any questions
representative
Weber you stated that we should help
children accept themselves as they are
yes how does this help the child who
starts unaccountably for a parent at age
three telling that parent that they are
not in their right
body I would go I would go back to the
examples I gave if you had a child who
told you that they were fat yet you knew
that you know you had medical help with
determining that your child was not
overweight and your child kept telling
you they were fat would you give them
diet pills if they were underweight
would
you change their race somehow using face
creams or pills or or things like that
you wouldn't do that no parent would do
that we would say you are just fine the
way you were born you are just fine the
race that you were born you are just
fine the body weight that you are we
wouldn't we wouldn't do things like that
that would be cruel and to to make a
decision for a child and when they are
way too young to make that decision they
don't have the intellectual capability
to make that decision we don't tell them
we don't make decisions for them that
would affect their fertility and their
sexual function we don't make decisions
that at the age of 3 four 5 6 7 8 9 10
that they'll never have an orgasm that
they'll never have children we don't
also signed up to speak is Courtney Reid
Hampshire again you have three
minutes hi good morning members of the
committee thank you so much for taking
the time to hear my testimony for the
record my name is Courtney Reid I serve
as policy Advocate with the ACLU of New
Hampshire and I'm here to oppose
House Bill
377 uh I will try to keep my remarks
brief as we have a lot of speakers to
get through today so to get to the
bottom line HB
377 would directly harm transgender
youth by barring access to critical
Medical Care in a discriminatory fashion
the consequences of which would be
devastating there are youth in this
state right now that are currently
benefiting from this care and this
legislation would disrupt thoughtful
decisions that families and Physicians
have made together to support these
adolescents HB 377 would deprive
transgender Youth and their families of
the ability to make critical medical
decisions or even to receive a referral
to seek this care outside of the
state all of which is antithetical to
our countries and our states values of
bodily autonomy and the right to make
private medical decisions and so this
bill seeks to ban access to Medical Care
however this Medical Care is
wellestablished it follows standards
that are set forth by maor Major Medical
organizations including W paath the
world professional association for
transgender Health the American Academy
of Pediatrics and the endocrine Society
gender affirming care has been supported
by Decades of research and is endorsed
by every Major Medical Association so
the reality is that denying this care
altogether is far more harmful than the
possibility of regret which remains
exceedingly rare the government should
not be dictating personal medical
decisions yet this bill does just that
by imposing a categorical ban on access
to this care exclusively for transgender
youth while permitting those same
treatments for their cisgender peers and
so we've seen similar laws blocked by
the courts when they're faced uh when
they're challenged and with ongoing
Federal discussions in court cases such
as USV scetti at the Supreme Court this
beill bill feels unnecessary at this
time and so if safety and regret are
really at the Forefront of concern for
this
body it would make more sense for the
sponsors of this bill to advocate for
research clearer guidelines rather than
enacting harmful restrictions that
disregard where the research is at and
dictating how individuals should be
living their lives with that in mind I
urge you to oppose hb3 77 and protect
the rights and well-being of transgender
Youth and their families with that I'm
happy to take any questions thank you
any questions yes representative
delus thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um the New
Hampshire Medical experts have assured
us that gender affirming uh care is safe
and
evidence-based but many European health
agencies have concluded that there are
experim that the these are experimental
treatments for example after a system uh
systematic review the council for
choices for health in Finland determined
that in light of available evidence
gender reassignment for minors is an
experimental
practice um and England's cast review
concluded that there is not a reliable
evidence base upon which to make
clinical decisions or for children and
their families to make informed choices
why have you reached such different
conclusions how did you come to those
conclusions thank you for your question
representative of of course the debate
around the guidelines and standards of
care uh in in Europe and in the United
States is something that's constantly
evolving and I think the ultimate uh
solution to that is not to completely
prohibit care which has again been
supported by every Major Medical associ
ation but to instead follow and
establish the this experimental research
uh and to have further studies to better
understand this care I would like to see
and I think other Advocates would like
to see evidence that suggest it is
better to prohibit this care for
individuals experiencing gender
dysphoria rather than to uh establish
more research to make sure that the
standards of care are grounded in clear
and compelling
Weber thank you and thank you for taking
my question we've heard about treatment
and gender affirming care for children
who are very very young with the
implication that very very young
children are receiving the kinds of
drugs that we are talking about here
isn't it true that the treatment for a
younger child
and perhaps well into puberty may be as
simple as allowing that child to wear
the clothing that they choose use the
name that they choose and possibly even
the pronouns that they choose without
any kind
of
whatsoever thank you for your question
representative certainly uh what you're
describing social affirmation is an
important component of care uh I can't
speak to the specific ages and
guidelines within W path but I do want
to express that all of those standards
are evidence-backed thank you
representative woods and then
representative Castle ring thank excuse
me thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my
question um in
um under prohibitions for health care in
the um U proposed uh uh
line 177 page one uh it says um no
person shall engage in counseling make a
referral so on and so forth um how From
aclu's perspective does counseling then
uh preclude someone who has
questions about um their dysphoria um
does this preclude them from does it
does that preclude the them from even
discussing representative Woods can you
move your mic still a little closer
please does that preclude does this
preclude them from even discussing uh
with um one of their patients um the
question of their
dysphoria thank you for your question
representative uh I certainly see
concerns about uh this bill being overly
broad as the definitions uh include
person to be any individual not just a
healthare provider or a clinician uh I
think the line that you site in the bill
also raises significant First Amendment
concerns as it prohibits referrals uh
for seeking State out of care where it
legal other questions representative
Castle
ring thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so is it the
stance of the ACLU that uh the use of
puberty blockers and children are safe
and effective
thank you for your question
representative the ACLU uh ultimately
has a position that it is not the place
of the legislature to interfere with the
physician patient relationship and that
doing so in the way that this bill does
is discriminatory based on sex follow up
thank you so the ACLU takes no stance on
the efficacy or safe and effectiveness
of puberty blockers and children thank
you for your question representative uh
I want to get back to you and site the
exact arguments that come from USV
scetti which the ACLU argued but the
ACLU ultimately supports uh the
allowance of these critical medications
when medically necessary or deemed
medically necessary by physicians to
treat gender dysphoria follow could you
define medically necessary for
me thank you for your question
representative I think that uh probably
a healthcare provider would give a
better answer than me coming from the
policy advocacy space but uh when
medically necessary this means deemed as
needed to treat gender dysphoria or to
have significant health benefits for the
mental health and well-being of a
transgender
adolescent representative
Weber does the ACLU have a policy on the
rights of parents to make
medically appropriate decisions for
their
children thank you representative Weber
uh certainly this bill is concerning and
how it would interfere with a patient
physician relationship understanding
that parents are a critical uh component
of making these important decisions and
I'm sure you will hear uh from other
speakers today about the role of parents
in uh dictating these Healthcare
decisions other
questions seeing none thank you thank
also signed up to speak is
representative Sarah deido from Bingham
date thank you chair Vice chair and
honorable members of the committee my
name is Sarah DeVito I represent
Rockingham District 8 thank you for
allowing me to speak today I'm
testifying today to express my strong
support of H bill
377 um this is necessary in ensuring
that young adults or young individuals
are protected from making life altering
medical decisions before they reach full
maturity medical interventions such as
puberty blockers and cross- seex
hormones have significant and often
irreversible effects on a child's
development including impacts on
fertility bone density and long-term
mental health while proponents argue
that these treatments alleviate distress
growing evidence suggests that many
minors later regret undergoing such
interventions given the fact that
adolescent brain development continues
until the mid 20s it is essential that
we a on the side of caution when it
comes to medical decisions that can have
life lifelong
consequences this bill does not prevent
anyone from accessing these treatments
once they reach adulthood and can make
fully informed decisions rather it
ensures that minors are not subjected to
medical procedures that they may later
regret before they are old enough to
fully comprehend the long-term effects
it also protects medical professionals
from pressure to administer treatments
that may not be in the best long-term
interest of their young
patients additionally this bill aligns
with existing principles and medical
ethics that prioritize Do no harm many
European countries including Sweden
Finland and the United Kingdom have
moved a significantly restrict medical
transitions for minors due to concerns
about long-term harm and the lack of
conclusive evidence supporting their
safety and Effectiveness New Hampshire
should follow their lead by implementing
re reasonable safeguards to protect our
vulnerable children for these re for
these reasons I strongly urge the
committee to support 377 and move it
forward in the legislative process thank
you for your time and for your
commitment to protecting the well-being
of our New Hampshire's
youth thank you any questions
representative
Weber do you have any hard numbers about
the regret rate from uh youth who have
received these treatments as opposed to
youth who have received treatment for
other life-altering
conditions not in front of me and thank
you for the question representative
Weber not in front of me um I do have
those numbers and I can email them over
to you if you would
like I will say that the numbers
obviously are not hard because a lot lot
of the children
um we don't have conclusive numbers a
it other questions
followup is it possible that they're not
expressing regret because they don't
regret having had the
treatment um I couldn't speak for them I
know that I have spoken with several
families that their children do regret
it um and they're embarrassed um and
they would never come forward
publicly representative TZ quick
question thank you uh Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question um how many
families have you spoken to who are
thrilled with their decision or happy
with the outcomes of their medical
procedure unfortunately I've not spoken
to one family that is Happy um with
providing that I will say that obviously
I've only spoken to um families within
my district so that could be different
but person have not spoken to
any thank you for the question other
questions represent yes representative
uh thank you Mr chairman um and thank
you for taking my question
um several uh folks have now testified
that we know that this is providing harm
while also acknowledging that there
hasn't been a proper blind study uh or
properly structured study to confirm
that so how are you generating the idea
that we know that this is bad without
the data to support it
I'm personally speaking to families that
their children have gone through it
these are families living this um
Nightmare and they thought they were
providing the best medical care for
their child at the time and now years
later they're realizing that it was an
awful mistake and it can't be
reversed thank you for the
question other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you
also signed up to speak is Rosie emrich
from
hookit uh Dear honorable members of the
committee I am here today and conquered
for the third
week this is the third week I've had to
show up here and sit in front of people
just like you and listen to them say
horrible things there are people behind
me snickering and laughing and
talking this is painful I am tired I am
anymore I spent a lot of time this
weekend thinking about my
testimony and I'm not entirely confident
that what I say is going to land on some
but my child's journey is theirs and
theirs alone and con contrary to the
testimony that I read online and some of
the things that I've heard today I did
not force my child into
this why would I why would I subject my
child to
this they didn't choose this I didn't
choose this nobody else compelled or
influence them into this what I did was
listen and pay
attention I listened to what they
started telling me from the time they
first started speaking sentences and I
continue to listen every day and if they
said Mom I was wrong I want to go back I
would be the first one to affirm that
too I love my children with everything
in
me and it is me and my child in
collaboration with their trained medical
providers with years of professional
experience who should be making these
medical
decisions so I'm here today even though
it feels like it's not accomplishing
anything and I don't think some of you
will hear it I'm here today because I'm
doing everything in my power to build my
child a world where they know I will
always fight for them even if I'm
bailing out the entire ocean from a
sinking ship with a teaspoon I will
always listen and love them when they
tell me who they are and I will fight
for
them despite all of this hardship right
now my trans child has given our family
a one wonderful gift we are all more
comfortable in our skins more confident
in the ways in which we don't meet the
impossible standards of feminity or
mascul masculinity we're more
understanding and compassionate we're
more willing to seek to understand we
are fiercer and more likely to stand
with those being marginalized and mostly
we have more love because we have cre
created an amazing community and family
thank
you thank you did you want to take any
questions or if people have questions I
can take them any
questions representative
Weber I just wondered if you would be
willing to tell us how old your child is
yeah sure my child is 8 years old thank
you yeah thank you other
questions I'm seeing none thank you
also signed up to speak are Jenny and
Luke
[Music]
Bo is it boar boar
yes can you spell that for me please
ERT uh my name is Jennifer and this is
Luke um I'm going to go first and we are
here to oppose this
bill so my name is Jennifer I'm from
nashille New Hampshire I'm a mother of
three children my youngest is a trans
male I've always been supportive of my
children no matter what they have needed
from me I have created an environment in
my home where my children can be open
and honest with who they are when my son
was nine he told me that he was actually
a
boy he had been born female he socially
transitioned to a
male he always hated school but he began
to engage and find friends with his
haircut and wardrobe changed he finally
seemed comfortable in his own skin
gender affirming Care at that time was
counseling it was support it was using
his correct pronouns and it was allow
him to be who he was as a mother I did
have to grieve the loss of my daughter
but I also celebrated that I gained a
son over the next four years I watched
my son's journey of Discovery he is very
confident and aware of who he is he
actually asked me to take him here today
he has a unique situation because he has
Turner syndrome and his body does not
produce sex hormones we did not have to
pursue puberty blockers because he
didn't need them but we are in a unique
situation where we don't have the time
to wait until he's 18 to start sex
hormones he's not going through puberty
without them he's had months years of
counseling he's well-rounded he's a
happy kid this bill seeks to destroy my
family values my role as a mother to
support my child and it inappropriate
inappropriately inserts the government
into my child's
Healthcare his body his medications his
sense of self are not things to be
regulated or banned I know with 100%
certainty that he is a boy and that
having secondary male characteristics
are the right choice for him I didn't
choose it it's not been an easy path
like the other mom said we listen to our
kids he knows he tells me just as my
other kids have chose to go down path
that they've wanted to go down and I've
supported them I know that he's done his
research I know we don't enter into
situations lightly we have an
endrocrinologist we have a trained
medical team from Mass General people
come from all over the country to go to
Mass General I trust the team that we
have I never thought I'd have to sit
here in front of the government in New
Hampshire to remind you that my child's
health care is my child's health care
and nobody in the government has any
right to legislate that I've been
sitting back here listening to hateful
people who are snickering at people's
testimony who are rude and respectful my
son is an amazing person who's here
today to stand up for our family and
what we believe in and you 15 thank you
and there's people that don't even have
the decency to even open their ears to
listen so I please hope that you can
son hello my name is Luke Bo and I am a
trans boy from nashaa New Hampshire and
I oppose this bill I'm 13 years old
right now but I might not look at a Thum
because I have a medical condition
called Turner syndrome Turner syndrome
is a condition where some of the DNA of
my ex chromosome is missing this means
my body physically cannot go through
puberty on its own because of this I
need to take one of the hormones so I
can go through puberty I would prefer to
take testosterone of course because it
fits what I want to look like sound like
feel like and who I am a boy I've been
out since 2021 but have felt this way
for way longer growing up I've never
liked girly things I've always dressed
masculine and done what's considered
masculine things I always related to
masculine characters and would dress up
like them I dressed up as a handyman all
the time and I always wore so-called boy
clothes my sister would even say I was
an old man trapped in a little girl's
body obviously
these things don't make me trans but
looking back I was just a little boy who
didn't know how to say he was a boy I
however could technically take estrogen
but it would be very uncomfortable for
me too but if I don't take any hormones
it will lead to serious problems this
band cannot be put in place because if
it does I will be stuck in a
prepubescent body for the rest of my
life or if an exception is made so I can
take estrogen I will be in a body that's
not m
and someone who I've never been and
never will be thank you for your time
questions thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question I was just
curious um if you would ever want the
decision to change your mind because
obviously I have 11-year-old daughter
she changes her mind all the time so I'm
only curious about that because I've
heard different testimony back and forth
about that there it is possible to
detransition it is not possible so I'm
just curious for you would you like to
have that choice in your future to be
able to go back and forth with that um I
mean it'd be nice if I did want to
change my mind but I know that this is
something that I'm set in stone I felt
this way for like five years my mind is
not changing thank you other
Weber is it of concern to you as a
mom
um that if we pass this bill putting
restrictions on kids who do not have
pre-existing medical
conditions that just as we have seen
with other medical procedures that have
been
banned it may make it more difficult for
you as a mom to seek the appropriate
care that you and your son know that he
needs absolutely that's of utmost
concern um actually we we have been
meeting with our
endrocrinologist for months now this is
not an easy decision we've been planning
his testosterone but the political
climate is something that we've had to
talk about in our doctor's appointments
and that's horrifying to me the the
these are things we've been talking
about for years planning for when
testosterone was appropriate and at with
his condition 14 years old is when it's
appropriate that is the what the Turner
Turner syndrome guidelines are and the
political climate and people trying to
legislate this is getting in the way of
his best care and treatment and I do
have to say even if he didn't have
Turner syndrome I would want this
decision to be made privately with his
therapist his doctor and our
family
well this is an intrusive question so
please don't answer it if you don't want
to how how long have you been discussing
with doctors counselors and others this
course of treatment sure um when did you
start thank you for your question so I
actually found out that um Luke had
Turner syndrome when I was pregnant um
so I've always known that he would have
infertility that he would have these
concerns that he might not have ovarian
function so gender has always been
something that was kind of in the
background of my mind and so when he um
came out to me at 9 years old we started
talking to his doctor right then and
there so he'll be 14 this summer so
we've been talking about it with his
doctor since he was nine we've been on
no um we we take a growth hormone but
that that's for his Turners but we have
taken no gender affirming care right now
it's all been support and I have to say
the Nashville schools have been
completely supportive I've always called
him his pronouns his name everything
in representative Kastle R thank you Mr
chair just I have a follow-up question
um so your the condition that your son
has um it seems to me like there's a
difference in hormone changes and
different things that happen anyways is
there is there anything that you would
tell us on that because I'm not educated
on that condition so just curious more
on that so with turner syndrome he on
his ex chromosome he's missing some
information and there's a wide variety
of the way that that can present for
kids he is very fortunate there are
heart conditions kidney um conditions
multiple conditions he doesn't have he
has a very mild form of it for us we
think it was a blessing because he
hasn't he didn't have to go on puberty
blockers because his body naturally
provided those puberty blocking so it
actually gave us the time and space to
be able to work out um what he needed
for his his
hormones other
questions seeing none thank you thank
much also signed up to speak is Eric
Cole
Johnson good morning good morning hello
representatives and thank you for the
chance to speak with you today and you
have three
minutes I've taught in New Hampshire for
30 years I've met many teens and I'm
here to represent them and their freedom
to get the health care that they need um
adolescence is a time of growth and
development some students it's a you
know relatively smooth Journey um but
others struggle with maybe a learning
disability going through a family crisis
or even you know loss of a parent um
whatever circumstances a student has
though we as educators are committed to
helping these young people find a path
to success sometimes it comes through
support from their peers teachers um
parents other times consultation with
experts like child psychiatrists or
counselors or doctors um let's take one
student Johnny he's in the class he's
he's um struggles to stay focused blurts
out remarks loses homework um can't
complete tests um finally he's referred
to testing oh he's got
ADHD um so this decision whether Maybe
maybe we could help him through
medication or not um that should be made
by him his parents his doctor not by
lawmakers um it's not the role of the
state to interfere in these private
decisions and of course it's very
different ADHD but still like for every
every medical condition when you take
medications there there are possible
side effects right like with ADHD you
can be your height can be you know
stunted a little bit you have increased
risk of having a heart attack
cardiovascular health um so um as
lawmakers you all have generously given
of your time to make sure New Hampshire
and its citizens are the best they can
be um I really believe you all care for
us in New Hampshire and want to help um
New Hampshire's citizens flourish um
it's important that we look to experts
in situations that may be unfamiliar to
us um such as the current state of
transgender youth here um who hope to be
able to consult with doctors and get the
medical care they need maybe we feel
fine in our bodies and we known oh I'm
we've always had this sense I'm a I'm a
man I'm a woman whatever your case may
be and we have trouble imagining what a
transgender person feels like um but the
fact is that they do exist have always
existed and will always exist whether
others understand them or not um there
are questions there are answers to
questions out there many experts in
relevant Fields um having the government
mandate private citizens Health Care
choices um is not not the answer the
answer is to believe the rights of
indivual individual families and their
health care providers to decide every
educator knows that a student setbacks
can lead to growth but knowingly denying
a Young Person's very personal identity
is not how we both best help them it's
by listening to them getting informed
ourselves Consulting with experts and
realizing that there are many ways of
living many ways of being that are just
as legitimate as ours whether the
child's sense of self is familiar to us
or not we do them the most marvelous
Justice of all by allowing them to
flourish seconds in closing I urge you
to trust in the rights of families and
healthc Care Professionals to make
decisions for the young people in our
state we have the opportunity to help
all our children whether cisgender
transgender live authentic lives and
reach their full potential let's work
together to ensure that New Hampshire is
a place where every young person can
Thrive supported by the family and
experts who know them best thank you so
much for listening perfect timing thank
you you taking questions any
questions yes representative lontine
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh what age groups
are uh classes of kids did you generally
teach in your 30 years of experience
thank you thank you for your question
representative um I've taught students
19 other
questions seeing none thank you thank
scare good morning you have three
minutes thanks um I'm Beth scar
grandmother from Nashua and I'm here to
testify my strong support for HB
377 to protect kids from damaging
puberty blockers and crossx
hormones there's a young gender
non-conforming New Hampshire Man Who as
a boy liked Barbies and other feminine
things at the age of 10 10 he socially
transitioned began puberty blockers at
12 started cross- seex hormones at 13
and underwent genital surgery at
17 on social media he talks about about
wanting to marry and settle down in a
house with a picket fence and raise
children he claims to be happy but he
frequently speaks of his non-existent
love life he's lonely his body has been
fashioned into a simulation of a woman's
body but it will never function like a
woman's body and his dating pool is near
zero the promisees made to him and his
parents that he could live happily ever
after as a woman were lies at 24 he was
he's coming to grips with this reality
he's learning that no one can change sex
he could have grown up like so many
gender non-conforming men who are living
with their functional male bodies intact
and in good health that is what I want
for these kids stop giving them medicine
medications that harm their bodies and
their minds leaving them sexually
dysfunctional and infertile and with
other serious health problems let them
grow up whole let little boys who like
Barbies be their gender non-conforming
selves Don't force them into a gender
stereotype box gender confused kids and
their parents deserve better girls who
are tomboys and effeminate boys deserve
better puberty is a human
right thank you any questions
representative
Weber do you have any research on the um
uh rates of regret following surgery as
opposed to the rates of people who are
satisfied with the surgery or regret
rates for other types of life-changing
surgeries um as opposed to anecdotal
evidence what what I've my understanding
is that no one's collecting the data on
regret um there I mean there are very
little data being collected on regret
what I what there is I could send to you
um and what happened in um the UK is
that um they tried to go the the kid
after they shut down the Tavo they tried
to go to the Adult Services and find out
you know how many of these people have
detransitioned or expressed regret and
they wouldn't share the data with them
so these are really difficult numbers to
doson good morning my name is Kelly van
doson and I live in eping I'm an
independently licensed clinical social
worker providing Therapy Services in the
state of New Hampshire as well as a
concerned constituent I am here today to
implore you to find HB 377 in expedient
to
legislate I've had the privilege of
knowing transgender children both
personally and in my clinical work they
are kids with all of the strengths and
challenges of any child but with a need
for additional medical support to live
long and happy lives the children I know
would love accessing care to be
protected because it really is about the
least interesting thing about them when
they have access to the care that they
need they would much prefer to be
focused on things like school friends
and activities just like their peers are
able
to denying the children I have known and
others like them access to care that is
largely and in some cases entirely
reversible has minimal Associated risks
and with a 97% satisfaction rate is
cruel and unethical and that
satisfaction rate comes from a 2024
article published in Jamma
Pediatrics this legislation would have
absolutely no impact on the vast
majority of granite Staters it would not
improve their lives help them support
their families or make them safer they
would have no idea that others in their
state are no longer afforded privacy
autonomy and competent Medical Care in
their doctor's office however for the
small minority that it would impact the
effect would be devastating the state
has no business getting between parents
children and their medical providers in
making complex and nuanced decisions
these deeply personal decisions should
be made in a doctor's office not a
legislative chamber as state that
prioritizes parents rights and personal
freedom I ask you as its representatives
to legislate in keeping with those
values and oppose this Bill thank you
for your time thank you representative
Weber so am I to um understand that you
believe it would simply be flat out
discriminatory to deny these children
the care that they need I do thank you
for the question and I do particularly
as there is an exception for their
cisgender counterparts to receive this
same Care thank you and followup it's
not actually a follow-up it's a whole
new question okay sure um thank you for
the Indulgence uh as a professional do
you have concerns that if we put limits
and guardrails around this particular
type of care we may wind up discouraging
pediatric endocrinologists from coming
to New Hampshire to make their practices
here when they can go to neighboring
states where they will be able to
practice the full range of the services
that they think that uh are needed
and the follow-up to that is will that
have effects for children with many
other kinds of childhood conditions
diabetes comes to mind that require a
pediatric endocrinologist for their care
sure thank you for the question um
that's actually a an incredibly
pertinent question to me because I also
happen to be the parent of a child with
type 1 diabetes um and it does concern
me our Pediatric Endocrinology team is
wonderful and I know that providing
gender affirming Services is an
important part of their practice and I
do fear that there would be a chilling
effect on medical professionals and I
you know speaking as a mental health
professional I also fear that some of
the language of the bill could provide a
chilling effect and leave some Mental
Health Providers feeling that there is a
uh conflict between the nasw code of
ethics by which we are all to practice
and and the law that we have to follow
as licensed Professionals in the state
in the sense of you know providing
counseling around seeking gender
affirming
care representative Woods uh thank you
Mr chair and thanks for taking my
question being a counselor uh do you
read this I you may have heard my
question earlier uh do you see this as a
chilling effect to talk to your patients
at all about any any kind of sexual
dysmorphia uh for or against a change I
mean the way this is written it just
says counseling yes I do I do that does
concern me and I have experience not
only providing direct Clinical Services
but also uh supervising clinicians who
are new to the field and who often have
these questions and to be frank even as
someone with 15 years of experience I
would need to seek supervision um from
other professionals to really understand
what the implications of this bill would
be for my
practice representative Kastle ring
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
so does the state have the ability to
systematically review things and you
know let's say stop them if there's
evidence of damage or something that
could happen to a child or anything like
that in your clinical
practice I'm sorry just to clarify do
you mean the State Board of mental
health practice in general the state
because you mentioned here that the
government is involved in this
conversation so the question that I have
for you is have you seen that in your
practice anything else that has happened
that the state has come in and said this
couldn't happen because it's unsafe
uh not that I can think of okay so if I
were to tell you there would sorry
follow sorry so if I to tell you there
were cases of that would you agree that
that's good or not that the state would
have oversight into intervening when
there are unsafe practices in medicine
yes yes I would think that in general
having oversight would be a good thing
for uh the state to have but that that
should be happening at the level of the
mental health board in the case of mine
or of other uh state boards of Medical
Practice and not necessarily through
sweeping and Broad legislation follow so
in your clinical practice would you say
that these uh puberty blockers are safe
and effective as the question I asked
before uh that would be out of my scope
of practice as a mental health
professional in my own reading of the
literature as an individual I taking the
preponderance of evidence I feel
personally that they are but it would be
out of my scope of practice to say as
mental health professional thank you
you're welcome representative
delus thank you Mr chairman
just a quick question what is what's the
age range in your pediatric uh practice
so my current practice is not I don't
see pediatric patients in my current
practice but over the course of my
career I have seen uh children and their
families ranging anywhere from 3 to 21
and then all through the rest of the
lifespan oh okay great um can I ask a
second question not even a followup just
a Qui just a question so being involved
in this in these cases
do you see regret are there people who
come to you who want to
detransition and what have you done with
that uh I have never worked with someone
who wanted to detransition if I did have
theoretically someone who came into my
practice with that I would provide the
same type of support and evidence-based
care that I would to any patient who
came into my office which would mean
exploring the reasons for it looking at
their preferred ways of being and
providing support to them whatever that
looked like regardless of my personal
beliefs
yeah other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you
Harris I'm
sorry
thank you so much for listening to my
testimony honorable members of the
committee my name is Katherine saris and
I'm a Performing Artist and arts
educator and I drove here from
Connecticut today because this is such
an important um issue for me I believe
that we are all made every single one of
us in the image of God and are endowed
by our creator with the rights the
inalienable rights of life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness I am a surviv
Survivor of sexual assault childhood
sexual assault I experienced traumatic
violative Behavior between the ages of 5
to 10 this caused my childhood self to
believe that being a woman was a
position of weakness and to reject my
own body I experienced suicidal a
ideation from the age of seven if I had
been offered puberty blocking drugs at
my pre-teen years I probably would have
taken them it was only years later as an
adult that I understood the origins of
my feelings of self-hatred
thankfully gender altering drugs were
not available to me as a minor and
instead the resources at my disposal
were a loving family youth leaders at my
church and
counseling I am so grateful that my
story is not the story of so many
persons like Laura smtz from Oklahoma or
Simon Prince's girlfriend or many
stories that I have read and heard over
the past decades I so appreciate the
testimony of Jamie Reid from the courage
Coalition that you will hear soon and
the D transitioners and the sisters that
are present today my story has a happy
ending of inner healing forgiveness and
freedom I represent the children whose
lives will be saved from from
significant mutilation and possible
death if you do not pass this bill there
are many many persons who have
previously adopted a sexual or gender
identity that later they found in life
was unfulfilling I have an entire book
here of their stories and there are many
many more that you can find at changed
movement.com
they found that healing from childhood
trauma actually enabled them to
eventually be able to be restored to
their true identity and to embrace
Freedom please I strongly urge you to
pass this bill HB
377 protect our children from a lifetime
of regret and don't live with your own
regret that you failed to vote to
protect them when you had the
opportunity and I would be happy to take
any questions thank you yes
representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question is it your belief
that had uh puberty blockers been
available your parents would have you
and your parents and your doctors would
have made the choice to take them and
beyond that do you expect do you believe
that you would have then at some point
later chosen to pursue gender uh
transition rather than stopping to take
the puberty blockers and P and having a
normal puberty experience from then on
thank you representative Miller and
thank you for the the question um I know
that if I had been raised in the current
climate of all of this ideology that we
are experiencing I watch my students
every single day I think that it would
have been probably a TR a choice that I
would have made I probably would have
chosen to go ahead and experience gender
quote affirming care which actually I
believe is extremely destructive for
yeah again s could do you not block the
door please yes
representative thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question excuse me if
it's very intrusive but um when you were
um a child and you were abused did you
ever think that you were a
boy no I never um thank you
representative Palmer thank you for the
question no I never thought that I was a
boy I knew that I was born as a girl and
I knew that if I wanted to grow up
without the organs that I had that I
didn't have an option for that at that
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is
minutes sorry took a second to unlock my
iPad we're not counting it against you
thank you thank you Mr chair and my dear
colleagues for the record I'm
representative alisandra Murray from
Manchester
W9 and I'm here testifying in opposition
to this bill I'll try to speak fast
since I have 3 minutes during my first
term last year I testified on a very
similar bill at which point I came out
to all of my colleagues as a trans
non-binary person these issues impact me
personally and also impact many people I
love since anti-lgbtq attacks have
started in New Hampshire this past
session I have multiple friends who are
either trans themselves or have children
who are gender non-conforming who are
now moving out of New Hampshire because
it is no longer safe for them here and
because the life-saving health care they
need is at risk legislation such as this
is not protecting Granite seaters it is
ruining people's lives and putting them
in danger there is an incorrect
assumption that the use of Medical
Treatments like puberty blockers and
hormone therapy is prolific and easy to
access this is patently false Over The
Last 5 Years fewer than a thousand trans
people per year have started treatment
with puberty blockers this is a tiny
fraction of the 121,000 youth who were
diagnosed with gender dysphoria within
that same time period similarly just
14,000 total of those youth were treated
with hormone therapy underscoring just
how rare the situation is puberty
blockers are safely used in children who
start puberty too early a condition
known as precocious puberty and their
use in transp patients is not considered
experimental by experts these treatments
have been taking place for decades a
2023 study published in the New England
Journal of Medicine found after
following participants for 2 years after
they started treatment that gender
affirming Healthcare significantly
improved trans and non binary teenagers
mental health and body dysphoria on the
other hand I've heard me Members
reference the Cass report I will gladly
send the committee a breakdown of the
many inaccuracies in that report but the
issue I'll mention today is that the
report endorses Psychotherapy as the
recommended treatment for youth
experiencing gender dysphoria used since
the late 1800s it did not improve
patient outcomes with individuals
reporting significant distress
throughout treatment there is an
abundance of evidence showing that
medically affirming interventions confer
key benefits and no contemporary
evidence whatsoever shows those same
benefits for those treated with
Psychotherapy alone all this data shows
that gender fir care is not only an
effective treatment for gender dysphoria
but it is also a necessary one people
keep talking about the permanent effects
of these treatments but do you know what
is actually permanent is puberty I knew
before 10 years old that I was not a
girl and not only did I feel it in
myself but my entire childhood adults
around me told me I was not meeting
their expectations of my gender
presentation now these same adults want
to talk about saving the tomboys but
they don't want to save them they want
them to conform they wanted me to
conform the truth is even if this bill
passes you will not eliminate gender
dysphoria for a single individual you
will solve problems for no person you
will only increase the risk of suicide
for lgbtq teens and make it even harder
for them to become the individuals they
know themselves to be as you vote on
this billing committee and on the floor
I urge you to consider how this
legislation aligns with your position on
parental
rights may I finish my sentence finished
sentence yes if our colleagues should be
allowed to treat their children with ior
mechin outside of the medical context
why should the parents of gender
non-conforming youth not be allowed to
make the medically supported decisions
that they think will best support their
child I ask you to vote against this
bill and urge you to please listen to
the voices of my community members here
today we are 1% of the population but
our voices our experiences and our lives
matter thank you any questions
representative kessle
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so I had a question for you
you said that it wasn't experimental uh
to your knowledge is there any puberty
blocker that is approved by the FDA
under that um I believe that um if not
by the FDA the majority of these
treatments are considered on the same
level as um prescriptions such as
Wellbutrin um there are plenty of uh
treatments that are considered off label
not technically FDA approved that are
widely used across um the industry for
multiple conditions follow so question
for you too I I know the Mayo Clinic
studies I know a couple different
studies that were sent to me over email
um they did show that there was harm uh
to kids with their bone density and
different things would you agree with
those studies or not I mean I would have
to look at these individual studies I
would say every medication for the most
part has some sort of side effects and
it's up to the individual their parents
their doctor to determine if those side
effects are worth the treatment that is
being um treated the medical treatment
itself thank you representative Tes
thank you and thank you for taking my
question um representative Murray I
appreciated you laying out a lot of hard
data that we had not yet heard this
morning um could you possibly if you
know elaborate on how much um uh like
medical evaluation I'm sorry mental
health evaluation and treatment happens
you know as a a a patient is going
through this process
because um the previous speaker uh it it
was almost like people thought the drugs
are just handed out and so as wondering
if you could illustrate for us um or
maybe another mental health professional
you know sort of how um more detailed uh
the therapy that uh patients would get
if they're in in this course of therapy
yeah um I mean obviously I can't speak
to every case I can speak to my own as
an adult I've been talking with my
doctor about my gender dysphoria for 10
years and throughout that time we've POS
um we've um explored multiple treatments
and at no point where those treatments
offered to me on the first visit right
away at all without trying other um less
invasive or um easier treatments first
Psychotherapy any other
questions seeing done thank you thank
you
Brennan good morning my name is Nancy
Brennan I live in
weer and I have been reading studying
following and testifying on issues like
this for the past eight years ever since
I worked with the venerable R renie
Cushing to pass the first transgender
non-discrimination
bill I think it's important I did bring
testimony I have sent you testimony and
the testimony I sent you has a lot of
reference material and I have brought
even more but I know you're not giving
me an hour there is good information out
there that tells what transgender care
is and what it does I would recommend a
book called free to be which is by a
clinician and a researcher with loads
and loads of um schooling and experience
working with transgender kids we have
heard stories today both from people who
want this care and I think so far only
secondhand but we're going to hear some
others from people who themselves wound
up
detransitioning this book gives the
history the science and then
representative stories of real children
who went to gender clinics and who spent
weeks months years being counseled
before they were ever given puberty
blockers some never given puberty
blockers some left happy with who they
are nobody that I read about was pushed
into it I'm not saying it can never
happen but I am saying that there's a
lot of false information out there the
cast view which was mentioned is seen as
some kind of a you know be all and end
all of why we shouldn't do this but the
cast review has been reviewed by real
doctors real
endrocrinologist and they found a lot of
problems with it I can send it to you if
you're interested but there were I don't
know 15 or 20 doctors gender care people
um who had a total of 86 years of
experience and published 278 peer
reviewed studies and they came out with
all the things wrong with the cast
review
um there was a question and it may or
may not have gotten answered there was a
question about regret regret overall for
Trans care and this is probably
specifically more for 15 seconds please
more for adults but the regret is only
1% as opposed to knee surgery which is 6
to %. at any rate I have lots of
information and I hope you will listen
to the stories of the people that need
this Care thank you very much any
questions seeing none thank oh okay I'll
you also signed up to speak is Peter
Doyle
esteemed legislators of the house Health
and Human Services and elderly Affairs
committee I'd like to begin by thanking
you all for your hard work on the people
for the people of New Hampshire and for
your concern for the health and
well-being of gender distressed children
I'm here to testify in favor of HB 377
before I do I'd like to explain uh I'd
like to tell you a little bit about my
own experience my name is Peter Doyle
I'm a lifelong Democrat and liberal and
let me be clear I'm not anti-trans
adults may do what they feel is best for
them children however require a higher
degree of safeguarding I know this to be
true because I was once a so-called
trans child as a child I experienced
what's now called gender dysphoria from
a young age up until puly I regularly
told adults that I was a girl this was
the 1980s so it was not taken seriously
and rightfully so gender dysphoria did
not really exist then we had not begun
to pathologize gender non-conformity in
youth more importantly I was not a girl
I was a boy the idea that I had that I
could become a girl was seen as absurd
because it is it's tooth Fair wish only
a child could believe the adults in my
life knew this and they acted
accordingly painful as it was at the
time for me I am better for it had I
grown up today what is normal devel what
is a normal developmental phase would
have been seen would have been affirmed
as real I would have been shipped off to
a gender Clinic where so-called
clinicians would have abandoned their
hypocritic oath and ignored the evidence
to make my tooth fairy wish come true in
the form of puberty blockers and cross-
seex hormones that would have been a
grave mistake I did not need blockers or
hormones to be my so-called authentic
self I just needed to grow up my
experience is very common among samesex
attracted adults I grew up to be a
healthy happy gay man who has lived a
full life thus far and I know many
others with similar experience to my own
given that childhood gender
non-conformity is a common experience
from most same-sex attracted adults how
can you tell the difference between
someone like myself who would have been
harmed by medicalization versus someone
who wouldn't the short answer is you
cannot children do not know who they are
they are children it is the duty of
adults to orient them to reality that a
normal part of growing up gender
distress is no exception protect
vulnerable kids like I was let kids be
kids let them grow up just as I did
gender transition is an adult decision
that children are incapable of making
this is why I order you to or this is
why I urge you to support HB 377 thank
also signed up to speak is Kathy
Stratton from the New Hampshire Medical
Society
that's on correct it's on
you honorable chairman and members of
the health and human services and
elderly Affairs committee my name is
Kathy Stratton I am the CEO of the New
Hampshire Medical Society I'm here today
representing the medical society in
the society's members have serious
concerns about how this proposed
legislation would interfere with the
doctor patient
relationship as a society of Physicians
New Hampshire Medical Society is
opposing this bill based on some core
principles and values the legislature
should not be in the business of
regulating and Licensing decisions that
need to be made between the physician
and the patient the New Hampshire
Medical Society has a longstanding
history
advocating for patient rights and the
ability for patients to receive
appropriate medical-based
care in based on their own unique mental
and physical health needs I want to
Spotlight two physician testimonies that
will be submitted um online um one is
from Dr Maria boan who is a
um a family practice physician um
unfortunately these two Physicians that
that I'll reference today um are un are
taking care of patients in New Hampshire
and they're unable to be here um and in
the testimony of Dr Maria boan this she
she states that um this is part of a
well-established process that each
child's physical mental and emotional
health needs are prioritized um
scientific and medical commitments
including organizations such as I'm
sorry scientific and medical communities
including organizations such as the
American Academy of Pediatrics the
American Medical Association and the
American Psychiatric association
strongly affirm support gender affirming
care um I have with me today testimony
for uh from Dr France Islam Liberty who
um actively treats young patients for um
with puberty blockers and I will share
that with you today um I won't be taking
uh questions today but I appreciate the
opportunity to present to you and for um
for you to consider our testimony thank
you also signed up to speak is Jan
is did I pronounce that
correctly too many consonants in a row
it's Jan herzler Oh I'm sorry no worries
never it wrong uh chairman McDonald and
honorable members of the committee I'm
sitting before you as the parent of two
trans boys both of who started
testosterone before age 18 in strong
opposition to hb33 could move the
microphone a little closer please sorry
should I start over or um no that's fine
okay um when my middle child told me he
was trans I was confused and even felt a
little betrayed as a woman what was
wrong with being a girl had I not
modeled Womanhood effectively thankfully
those feelings faded quickly as I talked
with my son and did more reading about
what it's what it's like to be trans but
I'm still ashamed of My First
Reactions I'm telling you this so you
can understand that like all parents of
trans kids this was not something his
father or or I pushed upon him well my
husband and I were always open to the
idea of our kids being gay the idea that
they might be trans transgender was
never even a blip on our radar until our
son came out sorry I'm super nervous um
before coming out my son was anxious and
depressed so we sought counseling for
him after he came out my therap his
therapist was able to talk with him
about what he was feeling regarding his
gender he was in therapy for at least
two years before he Ser he seriously
broached the idea of starting
testosterone which like everything in
his life he had meticulously researched
before asking if he could he's he's a
refuge kid his therapists his Physicians
and we as his parents all talk with him
extensively about what it would mean for
him let me be clear hormones are not
given until there is no doubt that it is
in an adolescent's best interest and
that can and usually does take years to
take this decision away from those who
know the Adolescent best and worst to
make it a felony to do so undermines not
only the parent child Bond but also
what's recognized as best practice
medically none of these decisions are
made like like lightly and the
interference of the state does nothing
to help the truly compassionate thing
would be to trust parents their child
and medical professionals to help make
decisions that are in the child's best
interest I hope that you'll take our
experience into consideration when
voting on this bill and deem it
inexpedient to
legislate thank you any question any
taking questions any question
representative Weber I was just
wondering the a sorry I was just
wondering the ages of your sons um my
middle child is 21 and my youngest is 17
thank you very much thank you
representative
delus thank you Mr chair this is
actually more of a followup to uh the
representative's question when did they
when did they start their
therapy um my middle was I believe 13 um
and the youngest was 14
okay thank you yeah and before that
there was no like the hormone therapy
was much much much later everything was
social before that and you know we we
had to wait until I don't think that
anyone will give hormone therapy before
at least a year of of um therapy and
usually it's two or
three other
colie hello everyone excuse me my name
is Stephanie colie um I am from Center
Conway New Hampshire and I'm here to
oppose HB
377 um as you're probably can tell by my
voice I am a transgender woman and so I
have irreversible changes haven't gone
through puberty me puberty specifically
um so for those that have spoken about
the fact that um children who undergo uh
cross hormonal therapy will have um
irreversible changes there will be
changes regardless I assure you so um
couple facts that I've heard many
questions about was the um how often
people regret it so I pulled up a couple
of things while I was listening um to
the earlier testimony and basically um
according to uh a 2022 study trans kids
are almost always right about their
transness and so recent studies show
that over um 97.5 to 98% of the kids who
declare their transness maintains that
over time in other words detransitioning
is quite rare yes you will hear from
people who considered it or even went
through transition and lat a change but
it is quite low um the other thing is
that there was a very large study I was
part of that in 2022 called the US trans
survey and they studied over 90,000
trans people 990,000 okay um and out of
that almost no one U regrets any sort of
gender affirming surgery and
97% report that life
satisfaction improved after gender
affirming surgery and again kids are not
getting gender affirming surgery this is
not Jiffy Loop people one kid doesn't
come in as a boy and goes out as a girl
or vice versa it's not the way it
happens it takes years even for an
adults in my own case I was in
counseling for oh God I can't even count
decades um and ultimately um came out
later in life um and I went into uh
counseling for two years and then I went
to lowd dose homeone therapy for about
four to five and then finally went into
higher levels of homo therapy and
transition eight years after the whole
process so this is nothing that's done
quickly and lightly and I do do not
think given the Hance evidence of that
gender affirming care is helps people I
don't think it's the position of the
government to be you know interceding on
against parents the children the
patients and the doctors if there's
evidence that comes out showing problems
certainly that's a a different story but
they've been using these um puberty
blockers for four decades you have 15
seconds okay and I'm that's pretty so I
just you to oppose if anybody has any
questions I'm willing to answer thank
you any questions representative
delus thank you Mr chairman I'm I'm
interested to know when what age did you
start the hormone therapy I was
53 I'm I'm almost 70 now I'm 69 almost
70 so as an as an adult correct you've
made this decision yes and I regret not
having that option I knew at age 4 which
was 1959 if you want to do the
math um that I was female but back then
that was not an option and I feel like
we're trying to get pulled back into
those bad old days okay thank
you representative
Castle thank you for the question thank
you Mr chair um I just have a question
specific to your experience you said you
were four so my question would be if you
were to take those hormon then would you
have a concern of other I mean would you
be concerned now that you would have had
other issues and developmental and
things like that that would have
affected you negatively now in your
later years um well first of all at age
four you would never start
hormonotherapy not then certainly but
not now CH when children at a young age
present um with gender dysphoria they go
through counseling for quite a while and
then they socially transition with the
parent involvement um the psych
psychiatrist psychologist therapist
whatever um the doctor um they go
through social transition meaning they
just dress appropriately for whatever
they feel comfortable um change their
hairstyle Etc it's not until they I
believe the it's Tanner stage two
puberty I think that question was asked
earlier when they begin um having um uh
puberty blockers and it's a Tanner stage
two um at that point of puberty they
then consider the um puberty blockage
because that allows the child and the
family and the doctors and the
therapists time to see if this trans and
this maintains itself that this child
truly does want it or it's just a phase
or they're exploring so so you never
you're not going to start any the any
sort of drugs surgery or anything at age
four follow follow up so then I guess
I'll re rephrase the question if there
were scientifical proof that it would
cause detrimental harm to a child would
you be opposed to us passing a bill that
would make it to 18 if there was
scientific um evidence of harm the
medical societies which all support this
would be against it they're the ones
that study this they do the follow-up
studies and when they come out with
information that indicates a particular
therapy is dangerous to to um you know
in the preponderance of evidence they're
going they're going to stop that as well
I was I was a healthare professional for
41 years as a nurse for 35 and I saw a
lot of changes in those decades and
during that time I saw things that were
set in stone that then later changed but
again these medicines have been studied
for decades they've been using that for
precocious puberty for I think 40 years
so that's a long time they've been
looking at this stuff and they'll
continue to look at it and so and again
people have said well there's potential
health problems like bone density issues
ETC sterility
I will remind you that suicide is one of
the lead leading causes of
stability okay so and suicide is quite
high in our rate and trust me I know
this from personal
experience okay
so thank you one more follow I'll make
it quick so you mentioned you worked in
the medical field did you see a large
amount of money being made from this
type of uh industry no I did not but I
would and and honestly I didn't work
directly in that I was Prim a cardiac
intensive care of nurse okay thank you
for you yep other
questions seeing none thank you you're
you also signed up to speak is Seth
good morning
morning is there anything I need to do
with the okay microphone okay yeah it's
on yeah my name is Seth herzler I am a
21-year-old transgender man and I
vehemently oppose this bill I was 13
when I first realized I was trans and I
had gone through an estrogen field field
uh puberty long before then I was eight
when I had my first period and at that
point I had also started to grow to grow
breasts um I had all the Hallmarks of a
female body I had never felt comfortable
during or after puberty I was told by
family members at the time that I would
get over it uh but I never did doctors
never took me seriously their priority
was always making sure that I could bear
children any he push to maintain my own
bodily autonomy was met with lectures
about how it may negatively impact my
ability to be a mother I never wanted to
be a mother all of that push back and
incessant reminders of my worth as a
reproductive vessel was Amplified
10-fold 2 years after coming out when I
set sought a medical transition before I
could even be considered for
testosterone I had to get a letter from
a therapist stating that I had been
consistent in a diagnosis of gender
dysphoria for at least a year I filled
out form after form telling me the risks
and when I was 14 I finally got to go on
testosterone and just as medical
literature from Decades of research has
confirmed time and again it D
dramatically improved my mental and
physical well-being as any necessary
medical treatment should I am not
exaggerating when I say that gender
affirming care is the reason I am alive
today okay thank you any
you also signed up to speak is Donna
Peterson
here could you tell us whether the
person supported or opposed uh she
support uh Donna Peterson supports the
Bill thank
you okay I'll put that to us one side in
case Donna Peterson should come back in
also signed up to speak is Elias I
did I pronounce that correctly did I
pronounce your name correctly uh it's
lucier okay sorry it's all right anyways
hello thank you for your time as youve
just heard my name is Elias lucier and
I'm an 18-year-old trans man I oppose
this bill I will be speaking about my
personal experiences with HRT hormone
replacement therapy and some pieces of
important
history I started HRT when I was 15 I
remember the excitement I felt with each
change I experienced and how truly
confident I felt in my body for the
first time in my
life unfortunately that came to an end
all too soon as at 16 I was diagnosed
with stage 4 Hodgkins lymphoma for
safety reasons I could not be on HRT and
chemo at the same time so now along with
with being stuck in a body that was
slowly killing itself and being killed
by chemo I was stuck in a body that no
longer aligned with how I saw myself as
once you stop HRT most of the changes
reverse I was old enough to choose to
start chemo and my cancer related scans
that gave me large doses of radiation if
I was deemed old enough to choose those
drugs that could have killed me then I
was old enough to decide what else I
wanted to do with my
body now I'm in complete remission and
I've been back on HRT for about a year
it has practically saved my mental
health and it saves the mental health of
many other trans youth many of which I
know with the introduction of all these
anti-trans laws presented in just the
last two months along with one being
presented to along with the one being
presented today these laws and bills are
trying to scare trans kids into clients
so that they can erase trans people do
you know who else had tried to erase
trans people in the past the Nazis did
just three months into Hitler's Reign
the Nazis attacked the first queer and
trans clinic and burned all papers and
books retaining to trans people and
their health care we've already seen
similar Erasure in our own country with
the word transgender simply being erased
from all government sites among many
other laws and executive orders
attacking our
community it's been two months and the
law is already trying to erase us how
long until books start getting burned
again I assume not long since books
discussing trans people are already
being banned from
schools a quote from um Henry Chine in
which the book containing it was burned
that day by the Nazis where they burn
books in the end they will burn humans
too this bill is the Stepping Stones to
do the same thing as the not
erase trans people those who do not
learn from history are destined to
repeat it if you do not learn from
history and decide to pass this bill you
are doing the same thing as the Nazis
all those years ago all my sources are
included with my statement which was
submitted online I will not be taking
questions and thank you for your time
thank
you also signed up to speak is Courtney
Health okay would she be coming back or
her also signed up to speak is Lauren
Cole
Johnson and let me remind you uh three
minutes please
thank you committee members for hearing
quick as an educator of high schoolers
as a
parent and as a resident of New
Hampshire for more than two decades I am
distraught and saddened to continue to
encounter horrendous legislation
emerging from this body in response to
unfounded fear HB 377 FN is based on
inaccurate assumptions by folks who know
little about gender affirming
care I speak with
compassion and love for my family
members and for the lgbtqi
community to quote an inspiring young
person I heard testify in another
committee regarding hateful bills that
would harm her sibling I'm not going to
answer questions because there should
not be any questions about what I say
here
that young person said there should not
be any questions because healthc care is
a human
right this bill does nothing to help
children it does direct harm to children
the title of HB 377 is vulnerable
children compassion and protection act
we need a definition for compassion in
this
hearing
compassion a feeling of deep sympathy
and sor sorrow for another who is
stricken by Misfortune accompanied by a
strong desire to alleviate
suffering this proposed act does not
evoke deep sympathy for children nor
does it include a strong desire to
alleviate the suffering of said
children in fact this act promotes the
criminalization of trained medical
professionals whose years of training is
backed by years of scientific research
in criminalizing professionals this bill
also does direct harm to their
patients the word protection means care
guardianship who are you trying to
protect if it is the patience you are
trying to protect then rip this bill up
it does nothing to protect
children I strongly urge you to oppose
this bill and vote Yes for
you also signed up to speak I have the
here is that is that your first name
last name
um yeah yeah sorry um winter is my first
name winter golden I am 15 years old
last name g o l d n yes like the color
so thank you I
strongly advise opposing this uh this
bill because
like I was once very suicidal and that's
mainly because I had a bad therapist and
couldn't get the help I get I've had
transfer friends and still have them
that are really suicidal and uh well
because they don't feel love they're not
getting the help and care they need and
that's very important because like
coming from a trans person if I didn't
get the help eventually such as hormones
and blockers I'm going be real I don't
even know if I'd be alive right now
it's very important
to support young kids instead of take
away
and uh yeah
and I kind of lost my train of thought
um questions are welcome okay hey I
representative Weber huh thank you Weber
thank you and thank you very much for
taking my question my question is could
you tell us a little more about your
life before you started taking uh
hormones and after and what changes you
saw okay so I if you're willing to
discuss that I don't want to be
intrusive no it's okay I'm totally fine
with it
so I would like crossdress in this
little or fan costume when I was about
like I don't know 3 years old I remember
it vaguely and
I would wear this fairy costume
constantly when I was like four after
going trick-or treating and honestly
um once like I had major depression
beforeand cuz I don't think Mom and Dad
knew what trans was I didn't know what
trans were was I didn't know have the
language to describe it and so when I
did uh yeah everything changed I when I
start to raise me as a girl I felt whole
again and before all that
um I would that was basically it I was
happy and it was great until one day I
hit a tiny bit of male puberty I got the
blockers and it really helped me out
emotionally and later on in a nutshell
long story short got the hormones and uh
I find it very important and very
meaningful and
strongly um
recommend you oppose this Bill thank you
very much of course okay thank you and I
representative Castle ring thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
so you mentioned that you had changed
therapists I'm just curious if the new
therapist that you have recommended the
therapy that you're currently doing or
the course of action that you're
doing my old therapist was a jerk who uh
honestly was unsupportive and uh wasn't
very nice and wasn't really a good
person so I switched to a therapist I
used to have when I was nine who was
actually trans
himself
and
uh it just kind of happened
cuz my um old therapist was uneducated
and I couldn't get the care I needed
so no they didn't set me up with a new
therapist
I got this one
myself representative
delus thank you Mr chairman how old were
you when you started when you started
the uh actual uh therapy the
blocker 10 years old you were 10 yeah
okay any other
Warner you've asked for five minutes
again please please remember we're
limiting testimony to three I
understand thank you so much for taking
my testimony it is of course an honor to
be in front of your committee um thank
you Mr chairman and members of this
committee I'm Dr Deborah Warner from
Littleton and I came down the highway to
testify in favor of this bill I'm a
psychologist I've been in practice many
years um and in this the settings of uh
private practice and in um Clinic
devoted to recovery from violence I
worked for the state and the children's
psychiatric hospital as well as the
Department of Correction
both adult and
juvenile I currently have a practice
that's in private and I see patients
actually many times by tele medicine now
I was trained in child family and adult
psychology I trained in Bowling Green
Ohio and then I did my residency in
Rochester New York and my internship at
the University of Rochester Medical
School I am well trained in child
psychology and and one of the things I
wanted to bring up is that when we have
what childhood is about is De developing
and growing they're not just Smalls siiz
humans there's a lot of work going on
inside of their um mental capacity and
their emotional development they do the
obvious things like grow and have sports
and and they learn things in school
facts and and skills but they also
inside of their mind they are also
working out many emotional things that
they need to to master in order to
become adults we develop a sense of
identity we develop our understanding of
relationships um our sense of self and
um how we relate to the world we cover
philosophical things who am I what am I
here for and all of those things are
covered for a minor while they're on
their way to adulthood and um so you
could look at what what are they
important tools of a child let's look if
many times they would take on roles in
order to see well I'm going to be a
pirate I'm going to be a princess I'm
going to be a doctor I'm going to be a
firefighter you know and and they might
live out those things for a while um
what we do with our imagination is very
important and just as a carpenter skills
um their tools are a saw and hammers a
child's tools are there imagination and
play and in those processes they need to
have the ability in their formative
years that the things they do are not
permanent they can play with this thing
they can play it through they might
become a firefighter they might become
the other gender later with the facility
of of Medical Science 15 seconds left
and so uh we need to make sure that the
children remain in that protected state
that the things that they do are not um
permanent that they can reverse
them thank you thank you any
questions representative CLE ring thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um I have a question for you
with your experience um have you seen a
lot of kids with uh let's call it gender
distress in their youth um change their
mind when they oh yes okay oh yes say
that's a large portion of it or a small
portion uh most most most do thank you
representative
lamon thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um but have you
seen children that don't change their
mind from your testimony it it sounds as
if you don't believe that uh there are
trans children that yes indeed we we've
heard many examples already today that
there are people who have a very firmly
um consistent uh view of themselves in a
particular role in a particular gender
and it is unfortunate that in the uh
current landscape of ideas and social
Society is that the idea of changing
genders is right on the table with other
options and so it it becomes a little
too easy for children to to look in that
direction however they still May
maintain that and become adulthood they
could finish the procedure um yes
please
um but would you not agree that uh
puberty blockers which this bill would
prohibit um may give a child an
option to really work things through
give them time to decide and figure out
whether it's a passing phase or they are
truly um trans children and would it not
give them
the
option
uh to transition later without having to
go through puberty um and a and the
gender which they really do not
yesong as long as it's reversible it
would make some sense but quite
unfortunately the puberty blockers once
you pass the years of puberty you cannot
go back and have puberty thank goodness
for most of us puberty was a difficult
time and you know we all have some sort
of um
Amnesia various phases of repression of
the things that were difficult then but
that we somehow or rather managed to get
through it is it is unfortunate that
it's a med like that is not reversible
because then they can't just try
it follow
followup um I believe most of the
testimony we have and the evidence
online is that they are reversible
puberty
blockers if you go all the way to
adulthood and you haven't had puberty
you can't go back and get
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is Savannah
Griffin
you asked for four minutes again please
keep it to three we'll
do uh hello uh my name is Savannah
Griffin I'm from Bradford New Hampshire
um and I'm a transwoman i there's been a
lot of talk
about regret and permanent irreversible
decisions and let me start by saying
that my biggest regret is not
transitioning
sooner
um and as for irreversible
changes suicide is an extremely
irreversible
change um when I was
17 before I had come out I would was
suffering severe depression and driving
home from school one day I drove my
truck off the road hoping I would not be
alive at the end of
it luckily I
survived
and I started counseling and anti
depressions um the
anti-depressants weren't very effective
but I managed to survive and through
counseling I was able
to accept myself as who I
was and
start estrogen I
was 18 at the time and it's the best
decision I've ever made six and a half
months after starting the estren I was
able to quit the
anti-depressants I've been as happy as
I've ever
been and I go months without having
suicidal thoughts at all whereas before
coming out it was daily not just
Suicidal Thoughts but self harm drug
abuse it was not good I'm lucky to have
come out
Al
I this bill which I am opposed to I
forgot to State
um would
starting the hormone replacement therapy
that I desperately needed had I been
able to accept myself as who I was
before I tried to kill
myself and maybe that would have kept
from trying to kill myself
and
yeah we don't need any more suicide
attempts it's enough of an epidemic
already
please just realize that you're down to
okay thank you for taking your time and
I will gladly answer any questions thank
you any questions representative Weber
so just to be clear is it your testimony
that for you the Lost opportunity that
we've been talking about in other
directions for you the Lost opportunity
was not having the treatment that you
needed earlier in your life when you
needed it
precisely other
questions yes
representative thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question at what age
did you realize that you were um you
were not in the the proper body or what
age did you realize you were not the
gender that you were born as I started
suffering from disphoria at about the
age of
15 although I didn't end up coming out
until I was
18 representative Lucas did you have
your hand up no okay sorry anyone else
yes representative hartnet thank you Mr
chair uh thank you for your testimony
and thanks for uh taking the question um
uh I appreciate that you're here uh in
opposition to this bill one of the
things that would be helpful for us to
understand a little more is what the
process was like for you once you found
a physician to work with what the
process was like the discussions were
like how long it took before prescribing
happened uh what they explained to you
about the the risks of the medicines the
benefits those kinds of things we've
sort of been missing a little bit of
that today it' be helpful if you could
explain that I mean My Testimony might
be slightly not well I guess not
perfectly aligned because I didn't come
out till I was 18 so I underwent a
slightly different process um
but I started counseling shortly after
my suicide attempt
um and then through counseling I
discussed my dysphoria I dis we
discussed options
of well being trans or being some other
sort of gender
non-confirming and I eventually came to
the realization that I in fact very very
much needed to start estrogen and
spirolactone which is a testosterone
blocker and I was in college in the
North country of New York at the time uh
so I went to Planned Parenthood north
country
and explained my situation to them with
my uh about how I had been seeing the
therapist and they give me a very dense
packet of
information and they ran some blood
tests
and they started me they said I could
either start on estrogen or spiral acone
but I could only start one at a time to
see if there were any side
effects and so I started I chose to
start on estrogen
and after about 3 months of no negative
side effects I started on
spirolactone after they ran some more
tests to make sure that my levels were
normal
um
yeah follow up thank you uh did you feel
like you could have stopped this at any
wanted um yes I could but being honest
that thought never really crossed my
mind because I mean I was happier than
I'd ever been
before thank you representative Castle
ring thank you Mr chairman um question
for you on your I don't know how to
phrase this question I'm trying to
figure out how to do it but so
specifically when it comes to you you
mentioned that you had therapy after you
had tried to commit suicide did you have
um very little
but
um I think if I had had some counseling
I might have been able to come to the
conclusion that I was trans and maybe
even start hormone replacement therapy
before I had tried to kill
myself so is there anything else that
you would say going through your
experience that you could help us
understand that you would that could be
done differently to help the suicide
conversation I
mean there's still quite a social stigma
around
suicide um and I think it needs to be
talked about and if you are suffering
those thoughts please talk to somebody
and maybe
you can work it work out your issues
before you try to take your own
life other
bonana a
bon and you've asked for 5 to 10 minutes
again we have to limit testimony to
three today yep I understand understand
um I just want to say that I just put my
legal name down given that this is a
legal setting I would prefer you refer
to me as Oliver and my last name is
pronounced Bama I fully understand no
one pronounces it right the first time
um so I just want to preface this with
the fact that I am actually one of the
people who would be impacted by this
bill I am currently 17 and in uh seeking
hormone replacement therapy I've been in
the process of seeking this uh treatment
for about 3 years now and prior to that
I was in significant therapy for other
unrelated reasons um I would like to say
also uh kind of where I would like to
say here is that the I find this bill to
not only be abhorent and contributing to
the genocide of trans people which I
will get to but also to be incredibly
unnecessary um I actually am from Sutton
uh just kind of sim a similar area to
our previous speaker and I've actually
experienced extreme bullying to the
point of that I've been diagnosed with
complex post-traumatic stress
disorder excuse me in relation to my
gender expression and gender identity
due to the bullying I EXP experiened
from first through fifth grade now I
experienced this bullying not because I
considered myself trans or called myself
as such but instead because I asserted
that I was neither a boy nor a girl
because I am transmasculine nonbinary I
would like to say that the bullying that
I experienced actually greatly
discouraged me from coming out as
transgender and in fact delayed my
wanting to identify as such publicly for
many years and I would like to say that
I find that this bill is only going to
encourage that kind of bullying and that
kind of fear in trans youth um I would
also like like to say um how this um
fits into the definition of genocide um
the you um excuse
me um so the official gen definition of
genocide as defined by the United
Nations is as follows quote genocide
means any of the following acts
committed with the intent to destroy in
whole or in part a national ethnical
racial or religious group as such a
killing members of the group b causing
serious bodily or mental harm to members
of the group C deliberately inflicting
on the group grou conditions of Life
calculated to bring about its physical
destruction in whole or in part and D
imposing measures intended to prevent
births within the group and E forcibly
transferring Children of the group to
another group I use the genocide term
genocide here in no way meaning that
this has reached the extent of the
Holocaust or various ongoing genocides
in the palest in Palestine and in the
Congo and in no way intend to
delegitimize this fites but instead to
draw necessary attention to the cause um
and anytime I'm going to cite a piece of
legislation here I may not KN in the
bill number but it is from the uh like
official legislation I have done
significant Research into this um I
would now address each one of these
criteria one at a time some Nuance is
required because being transgender is
not something that is passed down like
through families or genetically like a
religion or um other ethnic uh thing is
it's similar honestly to the way uh
disabilities are um firstly killing
members of the group 350 trans people
were murdered because they were Trans in
2024 and increase from last year by
nearly 10% these Mo these murders were
motivated by the fact that they were
trans and this especially impacts black
Trans women
um and keep in mind that there are only
a couple million trans people in the US
uh trans people have about I believe
it's three times as likely to be
murdered as their s under counterparts
um second is serious bodily or mental
harm to the group numerous states have
either put restrictions on or outright
Bann trans Healthcare as you yep um
which is um it proved to reduce rates of
depression anxiety and self harm and Su
suicidal ideation comparably to about
20% of people dep anti depressants
working for people additionally there is
the shooting of queer and trans spaces
and the attempts to eradicate these
physical spaces and the defining of uh
gender affirming care as child abuse
despite the fact that there is no
evidence to as such in the attempt to
remove trans people from their families
I ask that you oppose this Bill thank
you thank you very much any
you also signed up to speak is Lind
jakow
hello members of the committee my name
is Lind Jak house and I am a co-founder
of 603 equality a Statewide organization
that advocates for lgbtq plus people
while I myself have never accessed
puberty blockers or hormone replacement
therapy as a non-binary person I've
spoken with countless Youth and adults
across our state who have and who have
been able to grow and Thrive into happy
healthy young adults due to being able
to access this medical care as with any
type of Health Care it is natural to
have questions but questions about
health care should be answered by
doctors and these decisions made by
families not politicians some opponents
of this care put forth the false idea
that teenagers cannot consent to Medical
Care this is a false idea that seems to
only ever be applied to accessing gender
transition related care if it was true
that teenagers couldn't consent to
Medical Care Childhood Cancer WS
wouldn't exist and children and teens
would have to wait until their 18th
birthday to repair a broken B own the
best way to protect the health and
well-being of transgender young people
is to ensure that they can continue to
have access to essential age appropriate
Medical Care from licensed clinicians
practicing according to the
well-established standards of care
Studies have found that regret for
transition related care is quite rare as
low as 1 or 2% Studies have shown 6 to
30% of patients are dissatisfied after
knee surgery yet no one is trying to
pass laws to ban knee surgery
transgender young people who meet
criteria for gender trans dysphoria and
who undergo social or medical transition
are actually the least likely to regret
their care and those vast majority of
transgender youth remain consistent and
persistent in their gender identity over
time many people who choose to stop a
medical transition have complex unique
reasons like discrimination feeling at
home in a more non-binary Identity or
not feeling like their transition
requires medical assistance I respect
everyone's unique Journey but no one
should seek to use the law to stop
others from having the freedom to to
medically transition just because it
wasn't right for them Additionally the
largest doctor's Union in the UK the
British Medical Association voted in
favor of a resolution to publicly
critique the cast review used to crack
down on gender affirming care for Trans
youth in the UK calling its
recommendations unsubstantiated the
organization also voted to oppose the
implementation of the reviews
recommendations and stating that gender
identity services in the UK are
inadequate a claim well supported by the
extreme wait times of 5 years or more
which have linked to suicides among some
transp patients they assert that the
cast review engaged in unexplained
steady deviations and ambiguous
eligibility criteria while excluding
evidence supporting transgender care
evidence-based standards of care exist
to ensure that no one regardless of
their age under goes any permanent
irreversible changes without informed
consent and careful consultation with
medical and mental health professionals
Banning this medically necessary care
puts transgender people at incre
increased risk of serious harm including
depression self harm and suicide of
thoughts or behavior you have 15 seconds
when transgender youth like all youth
receive the medical care they need they
are able to thrive and have healthy
happy childhoods that set them up for
success in life like gay people many
transgender people have a basic
awareness of who they are from a young
age that's why families need the freedom
to support to provide trans youth with
the support and care that research shows
helps them live happy healthy lives I'm
happy to take questions great thank you
any
fine also signed up to speak is Jonah
EXC
me thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Jonas suon Morse I
live in Canterbury New Hampshire I am
here to testify against this bill um I
want to start by affirming that trans
boys are boys trans girls are girls
trans non-binary people
exist um I am the parent of a trans kid
but I actually want to tell you a story
about my adolescence um my body was
changing I was getting hair in new
places and I felt a little lump in my
chest and at first I didn't think about
it very much at all and then I thought
about it a lot and then I went and
talked to my mom about it and that will
tell you how nervous I was and
eventually we went and talked to my
doctor who said yep you're going through
adolescence your body is changing you're
going through puberty you're making and
reacting to various hormones you are
developing breast tissue and I said wait
no hang on I get the beard one not the
breast
one um and my doctor told me bodies are
complicated and we talked a bit about
some of the complexities of puberty and
hormones and even with that
conversation it was really very
confusing to have my body developing in
a way that did not align at all with who
I was I did eventually go through a more
typical male puberty development I
joined the swim team that's basically
got me through high school I went off to
college got married we moved to New
Hampshire we're raising a family life is
pretty
good if this bill becomes law some kid
in New Hampshire is going to notice his
body changing and hair in new places and
he's going to feel a lump in his chest
and not think about it very much and
then think about it a lot and then go
talk to a doctor who's going to say yep
your body is changing you're going
through puberty you're making and
reacting um to various hormones your
breasts are going to get bigger your
hips are going to get rounder you're
going to start having periods and that
kid is going to say wait what no I want
the beard one not the breast one and his
doctor isn't going to say well that's
not possible his doctor is going to say
that's illegal
here I don't know how my story would
have gone if that had been my experience
it definitely would not have continued
with I joined the high school swim team
and that's what got me through high
school I hope my story would still have
ended with life is pretty good or at
least I don't know my story hasn't ended
yet
but but it would have been a much more
traumatic experience along the way don't
subject our kids to that let kids and
parents and medical professionals make
their own choices about their own bodies
please vote itl and I would be happy not
to share my family's personal
experiences but in general the
experience that I've had as the parent
of a trans kid and some of the research
we've done into options if you would
like okay thank you any
questions seeing on thank
you we're not going to take a FAL lunch
break but members of the committee can
go to lunch at their Leisure um we still
have quite a few people left to testify
on HB 377 and obviously at 1:00 or
probably not at 1:00 but this afternoon
we have another Bild to consider also so
there won't be a formal lunch break but
again anyone who wants to go to lunch
please go as you wish also signed up to
Beerman good afternoon it is afternoon
Nancy Beerman um I'm reading testimony
from a friend of mine Danielle um
Danielle holds a degree in social work
and spent years as a mental health
professional before walking away when
treatment turned into a billing game
driven by profit over care she once
dreamed of running a therapeutic farm
for kids to give them purpose and
self-esteem through Hands-On work and
agricultural setting but she left that
Vision in the field behind as she
watched the Focus Shift to money never
in mental health history has treatment
been built on a lie every approach from
therapy to meds has aimed at helping
patients face reality childhood trauma
or adult delusions until we started
lying to kids she's not debating
appearances I'm not saying biology
doesn't Bend but no one can change their
sex and prescribing anything under that
pretense is unethical worse it demands
Society to buy the lie too a 15-year
study from the University of groer
published in The Archives of sexual
behavior in 2024 attracted
27272 kids from 11 to mid-20s at the
start 11% felt gender discount
discontent by 25 only 4% did up to 83%
moved past it naturally without reality
based care brains don't fully develop
until 25 so we've always leaned on
minimal interventions for minors that
changed in 2013 with DSM 5 update which
retooled gender identity disorder from
DSM 4 for to Providers to treat
distressed flipping care from reality to
deception it Unleashed a 500 million
doll um industry pre 20103 puberty
blockers for gender dysphoria barely
registered in the US maybe 200 kids top
pieced together from early clinics like
Boston and San Francisco now nearly
5,000 us kids start them between started
them between 2017 and
2021 alone surge tracked by insurance
claims with numbers still climbing look
at Lupron approved in 1989 a pro for
prostate cancer it's a hormone
suppressor so strong it'll cause
chemical castration in 1999 prison
Journal studies showed it curbed
pedophilia urges with therapy the ACLU
backed it as a voluntary option for
offenders but Flags it as dangerous as
it forces it's forced or permanent we're
handing to kids to stall puberty and the
damage is clear a 2015 clinical
Endocrinology study found lower bone
density in treated kids osteoporosis
wrist by their 20s women who took it for
took it it reported uh brittle bones
joint pain depression seizures lifelong
scars the fda's 2022 warning cites brain
swelling but long-term bone effects
still unknown not enough studies cross-
seex hormones hit harder you're down to
seconds um she goes I'll leave this for
you but again this is A500 million
dollar industry let them wait till
they're 18 to weigh the stakes and
hopefully till 25 until their brain um
forms enough is enough stop this medical
abuse thank you any questions
representative
Weber thank you Insight thank you for
taking my question so do you believe
that all the people who testified here
wrong I'm not going to speak for
them and I don't think children should
be taking these drugs you cannot change
your gender you cannot change your
to any other
questions oh Miller the other side too
close you couldn't see me uh thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question uh you brought up the financial
side of this implying that this is a
money grab rather than actually
providing health and I'm curious do you
feel the same way about other drugs that
have been developed and possibly used
off uh label such as OIC which was
developed for type two diabetes or
Viagra which certainly has generated
plenty of money for fiser over the
years pharmaceutical companies are in it
to make money and if they can provide um
or think they can provide some kind of
benefit without all thinking about all
the side effects I mean all of the typ
all the people that are taking OIC that
are not type two diabetics and are
taking as a weight loss they are
suffering severe consequences and side
effects to it and um so just because we
can doesn't mean we should follow follow
following up on that is your is your
claim here that these side effects are
not properly disclosed not properly
understood or just being
ignored I think people want a quick fix
and their Quick Fix is here let me take
this pill let me take this injection and
all of my problems are going to be
solved and that's not
true one more followup one more follow I
may sorry given the duration described
by all of the other people who have
testified here saying that none of this
was quick you still believe that this is
actually a quick fix not a multi-year
thing that is actually necessary for
these people not when I've heard stories
of people going in to plan Parenthood or
other facilities and within 30 minutes
of talking to someone there're given uh
hormone drug thank
no other questions yes
representative thank you for M Mr chair
thank you for taking my question um on
another thought if my child was born
implant that's not that's not the same
thing I'm not sure how you're equating
that I think it I guess I think it is
but if my child Do It um I know a child
who only who has um
chromosomal dis is issues like the
Turner syndrome boy that spoke and they
had to choose their child's
gender um so will this will this bill
stop them from being able to do that
I don't think that this bill is
prohibiting those types of medical it's
geared towards doctors doing this gender
affirming whatever care that they think
it is I don't think it is stopping
someone that has a genetic um
abnormality or and mutation from getting
the treatment that has been standard
care for
years other question
returned yes I have um thank you for
taking my testimony my name is Amry
Banfield I'm a parental rights advocate
in New Hampshire I've been doing this
for over 20 years um and I'm a parental
rights Advocate but I don't Advocate
when something's going to hurt a child I
I draw the line in the sand and so on
this particular Bill the first thing I
did is I called a nurse a pediatric
nurse and I said what are some of the
side effects what are some of the things
that can happen if you're put on these
puberty blockers blood clots infertility
cancer depression testosterone rage uh
she reported that child uh girl put on
testosterone to trans into a boy
destroyed a a a medical room she they
were they were in the in the um Hospital
destroyed the medical room and they
attributed it to the testosterone and
earlier we heard about anorexic if
you're anorexic do you give medication
to an anorexic of course not um so there
are limits that are placed on uh people
all the
time if anybody here has high blood
pressure pressure you're not going to be
approved to to donate an extra part in
your body a kidney you can't Mass
General will not take you as a Kidney
donor for somebody who could you can
save somebody's life because somewhere
down the road that could become a
problem so they're looking out for your
best interest this happens all the time
this is children these are children who
do not have the capacity to think long
term once they become adult there's
nothing nothing in this that prohibits
them from taking this medication they
can wear different clothing they can use
different names they can use different
pronouns nobody's stopping them but when
you're talking about a child who does
not have the capacity to make these
decisions of lifelong
harm then yes we can protect that child
we do it all the time and we even
protect children from their parents
sometimes when they're doing something
harmful um you cannot sell your kidney
the federal federal law will not allow
you to sell your kidney an extra part
that you don't need I can tell you I've
got a third kidney in here I've got
somebody who donated a kidney to me so I
know all about it you can't sell it you
so this body autonomy thing is not
necessarily true in many
cases
um as I said I I'm a parental rights
Advocate and the first one of the first
calls I got on transitioning which was
years ago was from a mother who adopted
a three or four-year-old Twins and that
three-year-old had grown into a uh
16-year-old she had been physically and
and brutally um abused as a young child
so she had adopted these two children
the girl when she was 16 had started
dressing as a boy things like this and
it wasn't because she thought she was a
boy it was because she didn't want that
male attention and so so she was seeing
somebody she was seeing a therapist and
they were working through that and they
were working through those things and I
can remember the the person that called
me is you know if if they had gone in
that
direction permanent damage could have
happened to her but she was just simply
trying to keep male attention off of her
thank you for your testimony any
questions not seeing any thank you thank
you
Cornell walkwell Cornell
okay hi my name is Rockwell Cornell and
I oppose this bill because it does not
protect anyone and will significantly
increase harm to vulnerable children
throughout the St there are far greater
risks to the safety and well-being of
the children in this country but today
we are focusing on deciding if
transgender children get to have medical
treatment needed to accept their bodies
as their
own deciding if puberty blockers and
hormones are needed for a child is a
serious decision that should not be made
lightly but most importantly this isn't
a decision that should be made by the
government this is a decision that
should be made by parents who listen
carefully to their children and their
doctors restri restricting puberty
blockers and hormones from trans kids
won't change who they are it only makes
it 72% more likely that they die before
they reach adulthood this bill poses
children as political pwns to distract
from the greater issues of independent
freedoms at risk in this country I
oppose this bill because I want kids to
stay alive and I think all children
including trans children should be given
the resources they need to make it
safely to
adulthood thank you any
Cary you said it right the first time
most people don't get it right the way I
had a little help so I hate public
speaking so I'm gonna read because not
GNA so I'm speaking today in support of
HB
377 I was diagnosed bip with bipolar
disorder when I was 18 I've spent 22
years living with mental illness and
working to help erase the stigma and
working hard to build a life that's
fulfilling meaningful but also based in
reality spending two decades deep in the
mental health space I can tell you that
there are no other mental health
conditions where we allow the patient to
dictate the standard of care gender
dysphoria whether people like it or not
is a mental health health condition and
should be treated as such I think back
to the few times in my life I have been
suicidal what would have happened if I
had gone into my doctor's office and
said I no longer want to live this is my
truth I know my mind better than you and
this is the answer and then said
doctor gave me a prescription for lethal
doses of medication if my doctor allowed
me to dictate my treatment plan I know
many people have come down on state reps
saying they have no business legislating
standards of care but I would ask those
people to realize this is something
that's happened for decades and for good
reason having been hospitalized I'm am
unable to purchase a firearm now is that
because you legislators think I'm cuckoo
for Cocoa Puffs or is it because you
understand that someone with my history
of mental illness sometimes needs to be
protected from the deception and the
delusion that bipolar disorder creates
in my mind I personally believe it's the
latter before 2014 the standard protocol
for gender dysphoria was walk for
waiting and in over 60 to 80% of the
cases once puberty was established and
these kids were able to explore who they
were through therapy and other means the
Jud andoria resolved on its own in the
state of New Hampshire we don't allow
children to get tattoos buy cigarettes
or alcohol we have these laws because
the adults know that children ultimately
cannot process or fully comprehend the
consequences of their actions we have
these laws in place to protect children
and HB 377 in my opinion Falls in line
with New Hampshire's strong history on
airing on the side of caution when it
comes to the protection of children with
the findings of the cast report in the W
path files every other country has
paused the standard of care and we have
the medical evidence to back up the
plethora of reasons that we need to be
following suit I would ask you to vote a
to pass on this bill so that we can
follow the science and help protect
these children thank you thank you any
lmore so I came back my name is Donna
Peterson I had a brief appointment I had
to step out come right back okay well I
I've called Naomi Naomi at lore you you
uh hi there thank you for giving me the
opportunity to speak today uh my name is
Naomi lmore I'm a resident of Dover New
Hampshire and I'm here to testify
against HB
377 the vulnerable child compassion and
protection act offers neither compassion
nor protection and the name itself is
derived from an inflammatory choice of
words meant to create a false sense of
danger when no threat exists the title
of the bill attempts to emotionally
manipulate a valid Precinct of thought
when the only real precinct for this
bill is intolerance and
bigotry gender dysphoria if identified
and treated early can only improve
quality of life parents and families
should have the option of pursuing
hormonal treatments because that outcome
can only and will always be reached by
having a healthy dialogue with their
children and acknowledging their
feelings and experience the sort of
dynamic that should exist in every
healthy household Healthcare Providers
should be able to have the freedom to
engage in conversation and educate
families deciding to pursue this and
administer treatment if the family
consents to it it is a private personal
matter and this litigation withholds
access to life-saving care and fosters
an environment of fear and
misunderstanding healthc care providers
are not prescribing this in a predatory
fashion and no danger exists in that
regard this should be a family decision
with the power vested in them and not
the
state postponing puberty to address and
discuss dysphoria does not cause harm
and is reversible by ceasing the
medication furthermore being able to
address those symptoms early through
gender affirming care changes lives for
the better the prevalence of suicide and
self harm so often used to discredit
people who are transgender and the
treatments they undertake only exists
because of the ignorant and hurtful acts
of others their learned intolerance
stemming from pathologically maladaptive
ideas of what normal should be this
litigation limits common access and
knowledge about gender care and will
propagate harassment because of this
personally I'm concerned this bill is
primarily a stepping stone to try and
block the same treatments and gender
affirming care for adults it seeks to
Chisel a small foothold of constraint
against excuse me transgender rights to
use in the future to introduce laws
targeting everyone for the purpose of
banning hormonal replacement therapy
this bill only serves to answer problems
that do not exist and to be intimidating
please vote no on HB 377 it helps
nothing thank you any questions
representative kessle ring so thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question if there was studies to prove
that children are being harmed or
there's possible long-term effects would
you change your stance and say that we
should pass a bill that would stop these
procedures from be going forward thank
you for the question um I think that
that
still the the decision would still have
to lie with the medical professional um
administering the treatment and the
family um all treatments and all
medications come with side effects and
it would be a matter of weighing what
those negatives versus positives would
be based off how severe they would be if
that hypothetically were to
happen other
you okay and also signed up to speak is
Donna
Peterson thank you very much chair Vice
chair members of the committee for
allowing me to speak um I'm coming
because I'm going to ask you to vote a
to pass on HB
377 I firmly believe it is for the
protection of children um I have
personally known um young women who have
transgender
as teenagers and have regretted it and
have then gone on to De
detransition and it is not true that the
hormone blockers and the um the puberty
blockers and the hormones do not have
any longlasting effect they will attest
to that they will have to shave their
face for the rest of their life their vo
is deeper and I know at least one of
them is deeply distressed by the fact
that if she ever decides to marry and
wants to have children she'll never be
able to breastfeed her children children
under the age of 18 young people do not
have an adult brain they cannot make and
should not be expected to make
life-altering decisions over their
bodies that can never be reversed these
treatments sterilize children and if
they decide later on in life that they
want to have a family they will be
prohibited from being able to do so you
have a child you have a six-year-old
child a young boy for example you know
one day they want to be Batman two days
later they want to be a girl five years
from now they wish they didn't
transgender and they wish they were
still a boy they need to be I have
friends who are transgender I have
relatives who are transgender and I love
them dearly but they had the benefit of
making these decisions as adults with
the ability the cognitive thinking
skills to look at all the um issues and
look at all the potential long-term
consequences and I think every person in
the state of New Hampshire deserves the
right to make a decision that they're
capable of making just as has been said
before you can't you know buy cigarettes
if you're under 18 you can't buy um
alcohol you can't get your ears pierced
without a parents permission you can't
get a tattoo so why are we having them
make life-altering permanent changes to
their bodies that they might regret
later granted not all of them regret it
but they should be making these
decisions as adults when they're 18 so
this is U my testimony and I thank you
very much for your
consideration thank you any
questions seeing done thank you okay
thank
you also signed up to speak is Joselyn
Seager
all right hello my name is Joselyn
Seager lifelong straight cisgender New
Hampshire resident my connection to
trans Youth and their rights lie in the
over 20 years I've spent working with
New Hampshire youth through drug and
alcohol misuse
prevention representative merer I
watched your segment on conquered
conversations and I wish I could say
that I could accept what you said at
face value that I could believe that you
introduced this bill with no hate or
discrimination addressing the committee
ma'am not just one individual oh my
apologies I can withdraw
that all right um You may actually
believe that anyone who introduced this
bill can believe that they have nothing
against trans people but that's all this
bill is if we actually thought that
puberty blockers were dangerous this
would be a hearing about whether or not
puberty loers should be legal for all
youth under 18 years old it is not this
bill specifically outlines that this
intervention should be denied
specifically for youth seeking care for
gender
affirmation I'm not hard-headed I'm open
to new and developing science and
information so far I have yet to hear
anything compelling enough to agree that
a bill outlining puberty blockers
altogether should be pushed through if
these are these medications are as
dangerous as you are implying come back
with a bill that supposedly protects all
youth from these medications and if you
want to make these medications less
necessary may I recommend ceasing to use
trans youth as political pwns of
division if you truly love all people I
implore you to do some
self-reflection how do you advocate for
the protection safety and acceptance of
trans youth especially non-binary youth
because take it from someone with
Decades of experience sharing Community
with both teens and adults who are trans
and non-binary
nothing is more destructive than
watching people and politicians argue
about your identity as if you know
nothing of your own lived experience or
that you have no understanding of
yourself when ignorant politicians and
antagonists claim their pronouns are USA
and kiss my ass do you push back on
their egregious misunderstanding of the
English language or point out how
offensive they're being to the valid
expressions of gender that fall outside
of our traditional understanding outs
outside of outlawing these medications
that help buy time for youth to explore
and realize their identity what else do
you do to help these folks you claim to
care so much about one of the biggest
causes of suicidal ideation and using
drugs and alcohol as a coping mechanism
come from isolation from the society and
Community you're surrounded by every
time one of you introduces the bill
targeting the trans identity you
validate those who look to dismiss
ridicule and isolate Youth and adults
for that matter who don't conform or
find Comfort 15 seconds please wrap up
in the gender they were assigned at
Birth I'm not here to say puberty
blockers are for everyone figuring out
their gender identity I'm here to say
that puberty blockers may be for some
youth in some circumstances and that's
enough reason for me to oppose the
passing of this Bill thank you any any
also signed up to speak is Kimberly
Liberty you've asked for five minutes
again please keep it to
three thank you to the committee my name
is Kimberly Allen I am the chairman of
moms for Liberty Hillsboro County I am
here today in favor of House Bill
um the urgent need
to safeguard adolescence from puberty
blockers and hormones the rapid increase
in the administration of puberty
blockers and hormones to adolescence has
raised significant concerns among
parents as responsible adults and
caregivers we must prioritize the
well-being and safety of our children by
taking a cautious approach to these
powerful and potentially life-altering
medical
interventions several key factors
underscore the urgency of protecting our
children from puberty blockers and
hormones the longterm term effect of
puberty blockers and hormone treatments
on adolescent physical mental and
emotional development are still not
fully understood these treatments can
lead to irreversible changes including
ster uh being sterile and loss of sexual
function which may cause distress and
later regret in
life puberty is a crucial phase of
growth during which children experience
significant physical and psychological
changes by interfering with this natural
process we risk disrupting essential
development
milestones and impending the formation
self-identity the complexity of the
risks and consequences associated with
puberty blockers and hormone treatments
can be difficult for adolescence to
fully comprehend this raises questions
about their ability to provide informed
consent and increases the likelihood of
regret or negative
outcomes many adolescents experiencing
gender dysphoria may be struggling with
occurring mental health challenges it is
crucial to address these underlying
issues before considering invasive
irreversible treatments ensuring that we
are promoting long-term psychological
well-being that being said I don't think
there's a person in this room who is not
that doesn't possess compassion for
these children I think there's some
sense that we all want what is best for
these kids it is our job as a adults to
protect our
children our children cannot give
consent for medical procedures why would
we go ahead and give that consent for
them thank you thank you any
you also signed up to speak is Sarah
Smith
good afternoon members uh thank you for
taking my testimony my name is Sarah
Smith I live in Pembroke New
Hampshire well uh and have been a New
Hampshire resident for well over 40
years um and
um I I want to talk about the the
Medical
uh interventions that we're talking
about and H uh some people brought up
the cash report and with and uh and also
the fact that it's been debunked a lot
um so I was looking up some things and I
came across a a report from France that
was their medical team and what they
thought would be appropriate
treatments um and it it did it did
debunk a lot of the cast report but to
tell you the truth
when I read through that report I
couldn't really understand it because
there were medical terms in there that I
didn't know about um and and even if I
got a definition of those terms I didn't
have the background uh in medicine to
really understand um so this is why I
think that the the medical experts who
have given
testimony should be the ones making
these kind of decisions I think that
that when a parent brings their child to
a medical professional and they have a
discussion that that should be
respected I don't think that a political
body should be making these
decisions uh this so this is a
fundamental uh disagreement with this
whole process and why I oppose this um
at I've heard a lot of testimony very
interesting which I frankly disagree
with um at one point people have kept
talk talking about how this is
irreversible I know a lot of trans
people I know a a trans non-binary
person who has who has um gone back and
forth you might say she's taken male
hormones then they then then they
decided to have children they have two
lovely children now so the idea that
things are
irreversible is not actually
true and and in in
um in other aspects of this uh I I I
know someone who
uh came out to their parents that they
were
transgender and their mother who
happened to be an OBG n simply said well
uh this person was Mell
I think you should B Bank your sperm in
case you want to have your biological
children later that was it you have 15
seconds thank you very much um that's my
main point let's listen to the doctors
thank you any questions representative
Castle ring just have a quick one um
thank you Mr chair and when it comes to
the other states that have passed laws I
believe it's around 26 uh that have
passed different types of laws and all
the other countries I'm sorry I'm hard
of hearing I can't hear what you're
saying could you speak Lou
yes I can trying to get
this so the other I believe it's 26
states that pass laws to you block
puberty blockers and things like that um
including the other countries have you
done any research on what their findings
were because you said you disagree with
a lot of what was said today yes I think
I think this is um
basically uh a political climate that
we're in and these are political
decisions that are are targeting a small
minority of people as somebody that they
can control and then that that control
then starts to extend to the rest of us
that's what I think is what is happening
here and it's uh uh people and I I do
think there's Prejudice I think people
in their mind have been brought up to
fear people who are different and then
that that makes them want to say I've
got to get I've got to eliminate them
they're SC of
them follow up so the question
specifically would be have you
researched any of their findings have I
read well I'm not a medical doctor U so
I can't research that but there are
medical doctors who will answer those
questions and so I will defer to them
and I hope you ask the that when a
medical doctor stands up here please ask
that question because it's a very
important question yeah thank you the
followup okay anyone else any other
questions okay thank
Hughes believe it's Patricia
Hughes did they have to leave I'll put
it aside for
good afternoon members of the committee
um my name is Emma svenia I'm from New
Futures uh Brianna had to was initially
covering for me but uh luckily I made it
in time so do we have a do we have did
you fill out a pink card um I didn't but
I can yeah yeah but well after you get
done please fill one out absolutely um
and I just want to thank you for hearing
my testimony today new Futures is a
nonpartisan nonprofit uh organization
that supports uh polic supports change
through policy change or supports Health
through policy change sorry uh new
future is here in strong opposition to
House Bill 377 because it attacks a
Minor's ability to feel supported by
their families and communities and it is
go governmental overreach that will
limit transgender Youth and their
family's ability to seek necessary
care trans youth face um higher rates of
discrimination in bills like this and in
their uh daily lives and communities
that feeling of rejection contributes to
higher rates of anxiety depression and
poor mental health outcomes they are not
uh they're not inherently more subject
to uh poor mental health outcomes it's
because of instances of
discrimination hibiting gender affirming
care such as this eliminates the Privacy
rights of those minors and their family
to choose the most effective level of
care for their needs these um feelings
of rejection and lack of privacy are
also contributors to poor mental health
outcomes this goes against
recommendations from the American
Academy of Pediatrics the American
Medical Association and other major
bodies that of medical
professionals um early intervention and
treatment using G affirming approaches
May alleviate some of the mental health
consequences that are associated with
these feelings of rejection and
discrimination and so for those reasons
new Futures ask the committee to itl
senate or House Bill 377 happy to take
any questions thank you any questions
representative Castle I'm gonna thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question I want to pose the same
question in a different way that I just
asked last time there's approximately 26
States and several countries that have
banned the use of puberty blockers and
minors do you agree that they are on the
wrong side of this issue or are they
completely making laws and rules that
are not right for the country I haven't
had the chance to review those laws so I
can't say whether or not they are right
or wrong but I can say the
discriminatory laws that prohibit
medical care for are necessary medical
care for individuals who face
discrimination and uh have been shown to
improve uh increased poor mental health
outcomes are are uh not an appropriate
use of time follow thank you um as a
followup you said necessary care could
you define how this would be necessary
care for a minor um I think that is
between a minor a family and their
provider um what is necessary and what
isn't other
questions staying done thank you thank
you
also signed up to speak is Heidi
Carrington
outright honorable members of the
committee thank you for hearing Our
Testimony today I'm Heidi Carrington
Heath and I serve as the executive
director of new Hampshire outright we
are New Hampshire's oldest lgbtq plus
organization and our work focuses on
serving supporting and advocating for
lgbtq plus Youth and their families
we're here today to ask you to vote itl
on HB
377 we are deeply concerned about the
loss of access to evidence-based best
practice medicine for the young people
we serve this is proven care that has
allowed transgender young people to
thrive into to succeed one of the best
ways to protect health and well-being
for Trans young people is to ensure that
they can continue to access essential
age appropriate rigorously vetted
Medical Care from licensed clinicians
who are practicing according to
wellestablished standards of care and
this is done in close collaboration with
their parents Banning this medically
necessary care puts transgender youth at
increased risk of serious harm including
depression self harm suicidal thoughts
or behavior and more when trans youth
like all youth receive the medical care
they need they are able to thrive and
have access to a happy healthy childhood
that sets them up to go on for Success
are outright young people have grown up
to go to medical school serve in the
military serve our communities and More
in part because of access to this kind
of care it can be hard to understand
what it is like for parents and famili
to have a transgender child our parents
and caregivers like all parents and
caregivers want their children to have
access to the best possible medical and
health care and the spaces and places
that their children need to thrive they
want their children to grow up into
healthy and Wells supported adults when
I sit in a room with our parents and
caregivers right now I can feel their
fear that these life-saving well-vetted
supports for their children will be lost
no parent or caregiver should have to
fear losing their child due to a loss of
appropriate health care we appreciate
that you might have questions we
encourage you to ask for clarity from
the medical experts that you will hear
from today and via email if a
conversation with one of our parents or
caregivers would be helpful we're happy
to connect you please join us in the
work of supporting this vulnerable
population of granite Staters and vote
itl on HB 377 thank you
thank you are you taking questions or I
don't Happ to take questions if there
are any any
questions oh representative
delus thank you Mr chairman just um I
know you had said age appropriate do you
have a definition of what you feel is
age appropriate I'm not a medical
professional so I'll defer that question
to those folks okay thank you thank you
other
questions seeing on thank thank you very
much
scare good afternoon chairman and
distinguished committee
members I'm speaking in favor of this
bill the state already interferes with
medical care with its conversion therapy
ban which makes it a crime for a
therapist to question a gender identity
even though gender identities are
entirely
imaginary also medical decisions that
are made out of coercion with suicide
threats aren't informed decisions and
and parents are emotionally
blackmailed you any of you could check
this quickly the 1% regret rate doesn't
even measure regret the main feeder into
this group of studies um measures regret
or detransition is someone who went
ahead and went on the hormones the
opposite sex then reapplied to be the
other sex and went ahead and changes
their name I didn't I know a lot of D
transitioners but not one would qualify
under these conditions and even by the
those standards we don't know the regret
rates because the Dropout rates was
about 30% the follow-up rates were as
short as less than one year for for
these studies and some of them have
nothing to do with actual regret like
one was a choice of um a surgeries and
did you regret your choice of
surgeries the also these were done on
adults who were heavily vetted with not
under the affirmation and there has
nothing to do with this puberty blocker
cross-x hormones protocol that we have
now and the goal of healthc care isn't
lack of regret it's health and right now
what we're seeing on social media is um
media influenc who identifi as the
opposite sex who are letting clinicians
torture them to death without ever
expressing regret these don't measure
Health as far as asking for the data no
one's been keeping it in 2009 when the
gems clinic in Boston started this
letting kids say I've got this gender
identity and what's affirmed with
puberty blockers and hormones right away
they should have been enrolled in
clinical studies they aren't Dartmouth H
is a CL clinical Hospital why aren't
they showing you their their data so we
have absolutely nothing W path started
regulates this or sets the standards
started um a a systematic study they
didn't like the results so they told
John Hopkins who's conducting it don't
release these results at all more
recently uh researcher Olson Kennedy
took 10 million bucks from the federal
government and then after she looked at
her her results deci decided they would
be weaponized in situations like this
and refuse to release them so what we
have are the European studies not only
the cast review but but also from
Finland and swen Sweden and we know the
drill if it doesn't support this
ideology then of course someone put some
something on paper saying they're
immediate they're discredited the
suicide stats people quote by the way
are meaningless suicide ideation so you
have 15
seconds is suicide ideation is very
common among teens 30% of all girl high
school girls seriously contemplated
suicide in the last
year so thank you thank you any
questions representative CLE R thank you
Mr chair I have a question I'm reading
testimony of a previous uh person that
spoke and it says in 2024 46% of all
transgender and non-binary youth
seriously considered attempting suicide
um as you said the statistics are not
really uh taken well or not given
information they don't really cite the
statistics here so what would you say
about that my guess is that's the Trevor
Project sta St istics the Trevor Project
is a and like the transgender survey
they solicit these online through social
media from young people and we what we
have for all high school students is the
cdc's youth risk survey and what what
that tells us is
that about 30% as I said of all teens of
all high school R seriously contemplate
suicide 12% of all high school girls
will will report they attempted suicide
in the previous years the good news year
the good news is if you look at the
cdc's suicide completion rate is only
0.14% people that have actually studied
the suicide rate for transgender youth
find it again to be extremely rare and
someone mentioned uh people at Taven
stock dying while they were waiting for
care people studied the youth at the
tavestock whether they're waiting or not
out of 15,000 people four people died
died of suicide and what they concluded
is that people are dying of suicide not
because they're transgender but because
of the coexisting um conditions that
lead to their confusion about their
gender especially autism and
PTSD other
you also signed up to speak is Chris
Urkel from
or thank you chairman members of the
committee my name is Chris urell I'm a
New Hampshire licens attorney I have u a
lot of experience litigating um about
barriers to access to health care for
transgender people I was on the
litigation team that challenged
Florida's ban on um medical care for
transgender adolescence and I'm here on
behalf of glbtq legal Advocates and
Defenders also known as glad law um
denying people access to Medical Care
that they need is unconscionable but
it's also unconstitutional and I'm just
going to tell you three reasons why the
bill that you're considering today is
unconstitutional number one it singles
out transgender people for different
treatment number two it deprives parents
of their fundamental right to consult
with medical experts and make decisions
about their children's healthare number
three it targets the speech of not only
Health Care Providers but everyone else
by criminalizing the mere suggestion
that an adolescent with gender dysphoria
might need medical
treatment as you probably know the
Supreme Court is currently considering a
constitutional challenge to Tennessee's
ban on medical care for transgender
adolescence and I'll admit that I don't
know what the outcome of that case will
be nobody does uh but we may not know is
that this bill will be challenged
regardless and it will be if and um
depending on the outcome of that case uh
in the Supreme Court it could be
challenged on a different basis um it is
never ever a legitimate or compelling uh
government interest to stop people from
living as a different sex and that's
really what's motivating this bill to
stop people from living as a different
sex and how do I know that that's what's
the Met what's the real motivation here
it's because um there are other bills
that could be introduced that would
address some of the justifications that
people are raising here including
concerns about access to Quality Care
people for several decades the Supreme
Court has been clear that discrimination
on the basis of sex is anathema to our
constitution
tion uh yet this legislation does
exactly that the basis for denying
medication to an individual under this
bill is that individual's sex whether
you define it based on their birth sex
or based on the sex in which they live
the Supreme Court has also said that
it's impossible to discriminate against
a person for being transgender without
also discriminating against them based
on sex that is why this bill is a
violation of every gender person's right
to equal protection of the
laws the parental rights um sorry the
right to direct the upbringing of your
children is enshrined in the 14th
Amendment and has been uh is deeply
rooted in this nation's uh
constitutional history and this bill
clearly takes away parents rights to
make medical decisions on behalf of
their children um and uh all right I'll
just leave it at that and I'll let you
know that I'm open to taking any
questions that the committee might have
thank you representative Weber and then
representative
Castle thank you so much um I'm
wondering if you could elaborate a
little bit more what are the um issues
with speech both for um medical
providers and others that you have
concerns about yeah let's look directly
at the thank you so much for the
question uh representative let's look
directly at the text of the bill where
on line 17 of page one it says no person
and of course person is defined as any
individual above no person shall engage
in counsel make a referral for or cause
any of the following practices to be
performed and then it goes on to list um
you know prescription of uh puberty
blocking medication or uh prescription
of crossx hormones and so that is a
pretty broad swath it encompasses uh I
mean on its face the language says I
mean the the words Council and uh make a
referral for aren't defined but on its
face it would appear that uh having a
conversation with somebody who uh you
think you know who any individual thinks
might need access to Medical Care would
violate the plain terms and it would be
a
felony
followup could that also um be construed
to prohibit um somebody counseling for
example um a parent to have a child um
do social
transitioning uh living in the clothing
and under the names and pronouns of the
other gender as opposed to something
which is actual hormon hormonal
changes well what I will say is that the
language is is pretty vague and
undefined right I mean we don't know
what it means to engage in counsel or
make a referral for uh medication that
that that that uh could lead to to
gender transition and and um and so I I
would just say that the text is
unclear representative
Kastle thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I'm hoping that you
being a lawyer and dealing with this can
answer a lot of my questions and I can
stop asking so many of them um first you
outlined uh here in this first paragraph
but I want to bring you to uh paragraph
28 where it breaks in it basically adds
a provision so that certain uh people
don't fall under this category or
certain uh health conditions do not um
would you say removing that uh or
leaving that changes the bill in any way
because you're you're citing issues of
constitutional constitutionality well so
yeah I mean that's a really good point
right so you're you're you're making the
point that there's an exception to
prescribing this kind of medication if
it's to treat a disorder of sex
development and uh a disorder of sex
development is defined in a um in a in a
different you know subse of um the same
chapter um in the rsas and I'm I think I
have it here let me see if I can find it
it's um happens to be in the bill text
of a bill that's being considered this
afternoon anyway um regardless yes it
makes an exception for certain kinds of
care so it shows that this bill is in
fact targeting one class of people and
that class of people is transgender
people um and so the very fact that it
carves out an exception for people who
are not transgender um shows that yes
this is in fact a discriminatory piece
of legislation follow up follow up so I
guess the legal question that I'd ask
you um what would the legal
clarification of what a gender
is because that would be your your
argument here is there a legal
classification of what a gender is I I'm
not sure that I understand the question
repres is there a differentiation in the
legal side for a gender versus male or
female oh your question is is there a
legal difference between the word sex
and the word gender well just how it's
clarified under law okay um legally the
terms have historically been considered
interchangeable in Court decisions and
other and other places and um the way
that they've been used in statutes has
been inconsistent so there's not really
a clear answer to the question of what
the difference between gender and sex is
okay one last question One Last Promise
um okay so comparing this to the Florida
law that you said you spoke against how
is this what where current bill is
differ from that um that's a really good
question I mean a lot of a lot the
differences are extensive right I mean
we could talk about the differences
between the plain text of the bills but
I don't think that's really um
significant because they block the same
essential set of medications I mean one
difference in the Florida bill is or
sorry the Florida law is that it
included a grandfather pres provision
that allowed people to continue care uh
this bill does not have such a provision
um another issue with the legislation in
Florida was that it um also impeded uh
access to medical care for transgender
adults in some respects which this bill
does not um but you know the there are
many other differences as well it's they
just to be the legislative history
behind the two bills is completely
different and um you know so so so it's
comparable in that it's also a legis a
piece of legislation that singles out a
class of people to deny them access to
Medical Care that they need solely
because of a characteristic that's
protected under the
Constitution other questions
representative Weber and then
representative delus
thank you thank you for taking another
question from me that's arrives out of
your answer to um an earlier one so um
online 28 and 29 it says paragraph one
of the section shall not apply to a
procedure undertaken to treat a minor
born with a medically verifiable
disorder of sex development as defined
in RSA 332 M2 comma colon
to so am I right in thinking that if
that ction does not manage to completely
capture every
possible um verifiable disorder of sex
development that the people who don't
fall under that definition would also be
forbidden treatment even though they
have a verifiable disorder thank you for
the question for sure I would be
concerned about access to care for
people who have uh who have uh disorders
of sexual development that aren't
enumerated in the other um statute this
referenced in here thank
you I'll set uh one more if if you know
because this may not be your Bailey Wick
um do you have any indication from other
jurisdictions that have proposed bans
that
um um pediatric endocrinologists are not
necessarily as willing to practice there
is there any kind of information on that
if there isn't that's fine um I will
just I'll answer that by explaining that
many pediatric endocrinologists have had
to close their practices and leave
states where they were previously
providing care because uh because of
laws that prohibit them from from um
from from prescribing medication to
transgender
adolescence representative
damus thank you Mr chairman um as I read
this intended uh uh new chapter
prohibiting medical procedures and
treatments intended to alter a mind
minor gender and you had said that it
was all about sex
I'm just just thinking that you're sex
meaning male female whatever but isn't
it really more about age this bill this
bill is I believe isn't it supposed to
be addressing age thank you for the
question representative um I'll just REM
um bring up a a Supreme Court case from
the 1950s Brown versus Board of
Education which was about segregation of
school children based on race and of
course the people who are being
segregated were all children yet the
Supreme Court looked at their race as
the cause for the Discrimination in this
case it is the sex of the children that
is the cause for the Constitutional
infirmity that I'm um talking about here
today thank you any other
questions okay all right I'm seeing none
thank you to the committee thank you
next up is McKenzie and I believe it's
it how do you pronounce that West a West
oh is that oh that's an S okay I'm sorry
I I have bad handwriting I should be
so to the members of the committee my
name is McKenzie West and I and I am I'm
here to testify an opposition against HP
377 ignoring the simple and reductive
definition of Sex and the rudimentary
understanding of biology that is put
forth in this bill to make the
definition that it does and ignoring the
fact that medical consensus is
overwhelmingly in support of gender
affirming care for minors from the
American Psychological Association to
the American Academy of Pediatrics and
the world professional association for
transgender health
we know that treatment is safe and
effective in lowering rates of suicide
and depression while providing better
outcomes for Trans youth but what
message does this send to the people of
New Hampshire and Beyond it tells
families that they are not welcome here
that ch's children will not be able to
find care in this state and that famili
is looking to flee these laws elsewhere
in this country that they should keep
looking because this is not a state for
them I was recently doubting my future
as a transom in the state when
testifying against HP 148 and as the
daughter of a trans woman when I think
about starting a family of my own bills
like HB 377 further my doubt that this
state is worth staying in if I am to
have children and start a family what
would I tell them that you can be any
that you can be who you are and you can
be anything just maybe not
here it leaves me sad and seeing how the
state I've long wanted to call home may
be closing the door to Bright Futures
for already for already marginalized
people like me and the families that
thrive with resilience and hope through
the attacks of the State live for a die
is the motto of the state but now is
this not increasingly an illusion when
we put the state in decisions that
should be between F between families and
medical professionals dedicated to doing
the right
thing thank you any questions no good
pounds you've written four minutes I
would remind you please keep it to
three yeah thank you thank you Mr chair
and thank you committee
um appreciate being able to do this
first I'm going to be candid I think
um surgery and hormones to people
minors um is child abuse in my
opinion
um I have a friend who has lifelong
damage from hormone treatment he had
surgery and hormone treatments he had s
suffered childhood trauma that led him
down this
path um
when he got correct psychological
counseling the gender issues just just
fell
away um now he tried to commit suicide
twice he he he he got jokes about it he
said you know I almost succeeded the
second time like he was proud of it and
he was uh told me that it wasn't because
of the issues the transgender issues
it's it's it's that it didn't you know
going down the path didn't solve the
trauma and once and it was the
underlying conditions that let him down
there and that's what L
him um he you know he he's cried on my
shoulder as a result of you know
realizing now that after going through
surgery it cannot be undone and then
hormones it's well understood that
depending on how long and how many and
damage um also um I've heard the story
you know
know um parents are told that if you
don't allow your child to go down that
path they'll commit suicide it's uh they
say psychologists are trained to say
would you rather have let's say a uh a
dead son or a live daughter and my wife
and I have experienced that
firsthand um also I'd like to note it's
well established from Dr Ken Zucker that
90% of Youth out of their gender
dysphoria if they're just left alone so
that's a pretty significant number and I
think if they're allowed
to um or push towards the transition it
can do irreparable harm um when they
it um there's a high-profile
psychologist Dr Keith ablo um I've
talked to and um often times when people
are given the cross sex hormones it
brings them out of depression and I
think that falsely leads them to
believe that they actually may be the
opposite sex and he said that's because
they're a steroid and those will do that
and it's only a temporary effect and he
said he he he he was kind of candid he
said I can do the same thing with
cocaine so um you have 15 seconds please
wrap up yeah thank you well I'm just
wrapping it up so um anyways these are
these are some of the things dealt with
personally and from what I understand
from um a medical
perspective um and so I'm I'm in favor
of passing this bill to protect our
youth thank you thank you any questions
uh representative
Miller uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question uh you cited
uh Dr ablo are you aware that his
medical practice license has been
revoked I'm not aware of that no would
you be surprised if I told you it was
true um no I wouldn't be surprised but I
I'm just not aware of it so I'd take
your word on that but thank you y thank
you any other questions saying none
thank
Ro
Terrell uh thank you Mr chair and
members of the committee for hearing my
testimony today my name is Parker
Terrell I'm a 16-year-old sophomore at
Plymouth Regional High School could you
move could you move a little closer to
the microphone please Sor I'll move the
microphone closer to yeah oh okay
um uh my name is Parker Terrell I'm 16
years old a sore at pth Regional High
School and a lifelong resident of New
Hampshire like every other teenager I
worry about school grades and what my
future will look like after graduation I
work I spend time with my friends and I
try to navigate the ups and downs of
being a teenager in almost every way I'm
just normal kid except for one thing I'm
transgender I've always known that I was
different my family has always supported
me no matter what As I Grew Older I
realized the truth I'm transgender and
that's okay I can live a full productive
and happy life exactly as I am just like
any other person but I can only do that
if I if I have access to the med
medically necessary care that allows me
to be myself I believe that much of the
fear and misinformation surrounding
transgender people especially
transgender youth comes from the lack of
understanding I would bet that many
people of of many of the people writing
bills like HB 377 have never met or
spoken with a transgender person so let
me say this clearly there is nothing
wrong with me I am not a danger to
anyone I just want to live my life in
peace like every other person person in
this room I'm here to ask you today why
am I not worthy of the same Medical Care
as any other
teenager my family supports me my
friends support me my doctors coaches
and therapists all support me so why
can't my government do the same why am I
being singled out every other teenager
in this state is trusted to make Med
medical decisions with their parents and
doctors why am I treat treated
differently why don't I deserve the same
level of
respect can you look me in the eye and
tell me that I don't deserve the same
rights this same medical Freedom the
same chance as at a healthy future as
any other citizen of New Hampshire I
exist I'm here and I deserve the same
rights and freedoms as everyone else
please vote itl on HB 377 help me stay
safe help me stay healthy and help me
live thank you any
questions representative kessle ring
thank you Mr chair just I want to be
clear you're you're actually taking
hormone replacement medication yes okay
follow up follow up so were you told the
side effects or the potential side
effects of what could happen by taking
those just before the even thought of
taking any kind of hormones I had to go
through years of therapy I they told me
every symptom multiple times many times
time again after every single cons
consultation they told me that there if
I would didn't want certain effects to
happen there were ways that they could
prevent that and different things I
could do to purer uh pursue my right to
be a trans to be a girl in this state St
follow is there any specific side
effects you'd tell me I'm just curious
because I don't know I've not researched
it for myself um I don't think I could
think of any side effects that I'm
comfortable with
sharing y thank you anyone
you also signed up to speak is Kina con
Cory
good
afternoon thank you for having me here
my name is Corey con at the age of 15 I
was diagnosed with what today would have
would be called gender dysphoria or in a
previous generation gender identity
disorder at age 18 I undertook estrogen
hormone replacement therapy and at the
age of 19 I had what is Cally known as
sex reassignment
surgery as a result of these treatments
uh particularly the surgery I was I've
functional and uh nevertheless
immediately after commencing these
treatments I went from being a lonely
isolated boy to a much more confident
and outgoing woman or so I thought so
over the course of the years one of the
things that I realized is that it's
impossible to change
sex and unless we understand that as a
fundamental truth that your sex is
innate and immutable and that the only
thing that these treatments can do is
change your sex characteristics
then we can't even create uh rational
policy and that's part of what you are
here to
do before I gave my testimony I engaged
with some of the people who have come
here with different
opinions and uh many of them had never
even heard of wpath which is the
organization which sets the guidelines
for this but I wanted to address
something very important because the
term medical necessity has been
spoken about again and again in this
committee I'm in I am a witness in the
Alabama lawsuit which surfaced some of
the internal Communications from
wpath among those Communications is a
discussion that medical necessity is
only for insurance companies to have the
justification to cover these procedures
under their policies there is no
evidence of medical necessity I also
want to point out a log logical fallacy
that I've heard a number of times which
is do we really need this regulation
barring evidence that uh this is a
harmful treatment this is not the
standard for medical uh research the
standard of medical research is are
these treatments
helpful I have heard a number of people
from uh the other opinion come up and
present to you outdated evidence and
outdated talking points but every single
day we are finding more and more
evidence that these treatments are not
beneficial you have 15 seconds left to
the health or to the mental health and
they are not they're not means to find
out who we truly are the only way to do
that is to live your life and experience
the world thank you any
questions representative castling thank
you Mr share so it sounds like you speak
with a little bit of regret could you
maybe give us a little bit of your like
history and where you got and if there's
any regret you have uh thank you
representative that's such an
interesting word to you is
Regret I
have it is it's difficult for me to
understand this as regret because it
would be like if you were a child and
you had accidentally knocked over a
candle and burned down your house it
would be difficult to experience that as
regret even though a tragedy happened
because of of something that involved
your actions but there are so many for
these children and and as was the case
when I was 15 and and a teenager there
are so many people adults in these
children's lives who are providing
affirmation but uh when all of this is
happening to you even though you may be
traumatized by it even though it may be
confusing to sort out even though it may
cause challenges that are unique to the
situation it's difficult to understand
something this large and uh mind-bending
as as a form of regret so I regret
offending friends um I regret attending
law school for a year uh it's a lot
harder for me to regret this because
it's it's the enormity of it is is too
that um yes representative
Drew thank you Mr chairman
um how thoroughly did you understand the
long-term medical impact you said you
were diagnosed when you were 15 and at
18 you undertook HRT did you understand
then what you know now about the
through from my own experience and from
listening to the other testimony today I
can tell you I don't think very much has
changed in the last 30 years as you get
involved in these communities of
affirming
individuals what you will hear 99% of
the time are the benefits and what you
hear about 1% of the time are the
drawbacks or the damages and and in fact
and I know that this is true today
whenever there are people who Express
regret or talk about the side effects
that that are medically harmful to any
of these
treatments those individuals are told
not to talk about their experiences
because it causes anxiety to other
people or they are told not to talk
about it because it could threaten their
ability to gain access to what they
Healthcare I did because although the
information was presented to me it was
not something that I was able to
adequately develop informed consent to
understand because I was in a a state
of basically Obsession on my my target
for transition so in my opinion medical
providers have a higher Duty than to
Simply present a form to patients or a
packet I think one one person said that
they received a a large packet of
information I don't understand how
anybody can take that packet and uh
synthesize it and turn that into an
input for their decision it's too much
and in my opinion talking with other
people who've been through these
procedures doctors do not tend to
develop to their own assurance and
understanding that the patient that
they're treating has received the
was that follow
up okay um and during this process where
were your parents or caregivers were
they able to do that uh that is a great
question although there are I've I've
seen today there there are very
passionate parents that are involved and
I I think that there's some great
upsides to that in my case my parents
were not involved but in either case one
of the things that was
part of my experience learning more and
more about being trans is to be
inculcated with the idea that parents
are going to try to stop you or
interfere with your abilities to be able
to access these types of care um I have
I have seen from forums and uh talk
channels uh like Discord where young
people are coached on what to say to
their parents I've heard stories of
parents who receive notes that are
coming out out notes that are basically
uh matched to online templates that they
can use
so
it's in some cases there may be uh
enough clear communication between the
parent and the child that the child
knows what's happening my belief is that
particularly the social aspects of this
issue cause there to be a lot of
Division and and lack of alignment
between children who identify as trans
and their
parents any other questions seeing none
thank
you is a Courtney Tanner come
back or is she expect oh there she
is that's okay they're working on that
two places in one thing you perfect it
let me know I'm working as a mom I I'm
working on it it's getting better um so
for the record Courtney Tanner I'm the
senior director of government relations
at Dartmouth health and
um we oppose this bill um we have some
concerns we have a lot of concerns about
the prohibition of access to care um the
the implications that this would mean
for our providers and their ability to
practice care within um uh within their
license and uh you've heard today uh
this I know this hearing was scheduled
for for 90 minutes and we're well into
your lunch hour so you've heard a lot of
testimony today about um concerns about
access to care I am want to just
highlight a couple of those um pieces
that have not been raised up to put a
finer point on concerns about
Recruitment and Retention of our
Workforce we are um the largest health
system in the state of New Hampshire
we're also the largest provider of
psychiatric services here in New
Hampshire including um we just now um
have taken operational control of the
Hamstead um facility which is the uh us
psychiatric facility in the state in the
southern state of New Hampshire and um
we have concerns about the implications
for um our patients that are receiving
psychiatric and Behavioral Health
Services and also those who are um
accessing pediatric um endocrin endr
Chron these are big words sorry endr
chronology Services too when we think
about what a pediatric endocrinologist
does they are um not just treating
patients who are seeking gender from in
care they may be treating patients who
have uh adrenal disorders diabetes
calcium metabolism other genetic um
syndromes and so when we as an
institution have to recruit and retain
um specialty providers it's not just for
providers that are going to provide
gender firing care but we need to make
sure we're providing services for um our
young patients across the state that
need access to other services like
Diabetes Care I do have some questions
about the bill as drafted there's is an
effective date of um January I believe
January 1st 2026 and so what would this
mean for patients who are receiving
puberty blockers today and would need
potentially need to be tie traded down
from their care I am not a clinician I'm
an attorney so would have some grave
concerns about a um a quick stop and
care and what the implications of that
would mean
clinically there's been a lot of talk
today about parental rights and informed
consent and um pediatric ascent and I
just want to underscore that um informed
consent is something that is not only
important to Dart Health it's a
principle and a value but also the law
and something that we um take very
seriously so that all of our practices
all of our policies and procedures
contemplate informed consent both with
um parents and also for those
adolescence that are engaged in this
treatment we also engage in Ascent too
so that PA patients and parent patients
parents and their provider are working
collaboratively as they engage in this
care you're down to 15 seconds sure one
other point just to put a a finer point
on this um questions around clinical
collaboration and whether or not um
patients providers are exploring
Innovative treatments we see this
outside of the gender affirming care
spaces we see this in rare disease
States we see this in oncology and um
without access to care and without
access to research we're not going to
see medical Innovation so I just want to
underscore that too I'm I am happy to
take questions any questions
representative Castle thank you Mr chair
so I have a I know you're not a medical
professional you're a lawyer so I'm
going to ask you this in a legal term so
on Dartmouth hedgcock website um it
specifically says for most transgender
patients hormone therapy is the first
step so we've heard different things
about requiring you know therapies and
different things ahead of time but why
would Dart Hitchcock take the on their
website take the approach that that's
the first step I wish I had the website
up in front of me because I I don't um
that's not our first step for this
patient population I have learned a lot
about gender affirming care because
we've contemplated it in this state
house in the last couple of years um for
children young families who are
accessing this care um it's a multi a
multi-disciplined team that's working
with um these families and we are
there's a lot more social transition
that's happening even before puberty
blockers which puberty blockers is the
only thing contemplated in this bill and
that social supports is a a child that
is supported by a multi-disciplinary
team the provider is only one person
there are social workers there are
psychologists that are supporting the
patient and their family as they
navigate
what is this um next step for us as a
family so that's number one that social
piece then there's questions around
puberty blockers you've heard from
families today that have that have
shared their journe Journey with great
courage and so I'm not going to
reiterate their stories but um that
would be puberty blockers would be that
next step and then uh hormone therapy
and patients are going to navigate that
with their providers they're going to be
very unique I was listening to the
testimony uh with a young man who has
Turner syndrome and talk about a very
unique patient who's going to be
navigating some medical complexities
with their provider who's not a state
provider not Dartmouth health and um
their and their their parents okay
followup perck followup okay so uh Trump
had an executive order that blocked or
changed this how does that affect the
because you're legal legal side things
how does that affect what what's
happening in the state when it comes to
that yeah it's my understanding there's
a stay on that executive order to date
okay Al set I got one quick follow up
okay um so does the dmouth Hitchcock
metal I've asked this several times does
background t are do you take a stance
that P puberty blockers are safe and
effective it's Dartmouth Croc has
concerns with this bill because it
prohibits access to care for a specific
patient
population anyone else yes uh
representative ran thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question how
many children are we talking
about um so I've asked this question of
our it's very small um of our patient
population um the amount of children
that are receiving puberty blockers
after much uh careful consideration with
their parents and their providers is is
extremely small a percentage of a of a a
small percent I'm going to represent R
so okay I'm going to circle back with
you because I don't want to give uh
definitive numbers here but it's a small
percent of patients who need puberty
blockers and an even smaller percent um
who even walk to that next step and so I
want to be really careful about
protecting this patient population
representative Lucas thank you Mr chair
and thanks for taking my question um is
it true that pediatric
endocrinologists also care for children
with uh type 1 and type two
diabetes thyroid disorders adrenal
diseases and pituitary abnormalities yes
absolutely along with with turn Turner
syndrome calcium metabolism um disorders
yes followup followup and do you have
any idea how many of those different
disorders maybe total attend uh are
attended by Dartmouth uh pediatric
endocrinologist yeah I'm happy to get
numbers for patient volumes for this
committee thank
you okay anyone else I'm almost afraid
right so my question thank you Mr
chairman um do you as an organization
track statistics and outcomes for the
patients who go through this care and if
you do how long do you do so is this a
lifelong
process
um I am going to have to take that
representative jman have to take that
question back to our team um there are
so I think you're asking about clinical
trials and it's not I don't have my
finger on the pulse of what clinical
trials we're engaged in um but I'm happy
to take that back to the team the
clinical team I'm specifically not
talking about clinical trials I'm
talking about the work that Dartmouth
Hitchcock is doing with specific
patients
so I guess I'm not understanding the
detail of the question I'm
sorry okay I'll try to explain it better
does Darth does Dartmouth
Hitchcock a after these treatments are
performed do you have an understanding
of what the outcomes of those treatments
are for example if you have someone who
goes through these treatments and then
regrets it or de transitions or you have
someone who goes through the treatment
and is happy with it and continues on
with their life do do you have any idea
of how those outcomes turn out I think
that that I think that information would
be contemplated in clinical trials I'm
happy to talk about I'm happy to to ask
our team that but I think that that type
of information that you're seeking would
have to be contemplated in a clinical
trial and I also um am very concerned
about treating this patient population
different from other patient populations
for example if there's a Peds um a Peds
GI patient who has a rare esophageal
disorder and is engaged in an FDA um a
not yet FDA approved clinical trial
there's not we're not looking to follow
that patient for the life of the patient
so I I would take concern if we're going
to be talking about treating one patient
population in a different way but I will
take the question back to the team I'm
that yes sign out of a castle I'm gonna
ask one targeting question do you know
the number of children that have
transition through Dartmouth Hitchcock
Medical Center I will take the number
back I will take the question back to
the team thank you
okay let's move on thank you very much
oh representative
delus thank you Mr chair you may never
leave today oh just well I am hungry we
needed lunch at some point so I I may
have missed I may have missed some of
the information that you imparted sure
uh what are the ages of the children
that you treat sure roughly yeah so as I
was explaining um we we have a gender
affirming care clinic and so there are
patients and their families that come to
us that are seeking gender affirming
care that would start with a social um
uh transition and then may nav they may
navigate to puberty blockers they may
navigate to hormone uh treatment and
they and Beyond um and so children can
come to us at a at a very young age and
are supported by a multi-disciplinary
team you've heard today from patients so
I don't want to their their stories are
much more important than the testimony
that I'm giving follow
what's the youngest patient that you
have who is on blockers oh
representative D I'd have to get that
that back to you and and I have to be
very careful too because this these are
this is sensitive patient information
and none of us would want our patient
information to be public and so I have
too okay representative TZ uh thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question then you can run the lunch um
we heard previously and I apologize if
you while we grabbed lunch if you
mentioned this but we heard previously
that there's um Workforce impacts in
places where these kinds of laws are
enacted yeah um and you mentioned how
you have a team of pediatric
endocrinologists we know that you were
the premier tertiary care academic
center for our state um what is sort of
the um and we and and how much the
Pediatric endocrinologist care for
children with many other conditions as
well can you paint for us a picture of
like what kind of impact this would have
on the workforce if at all possible this
would have a significant impact on our
Workforce particularly um it's really
challenging for us in New Hampshire
we're a very rural State our patient
volumes are pretty low it's very hard
for us to attract specialty providers
and it's even more hard to attract
pediatric specialty providers and so um
we uh would have grave concerns about
our ability to attract and retain the
ped's Endo Endocrinology um Workforce
here in New Hampshire we've actually
been the recipients um
of other types of providers that have
come to New Hampshire because they don't
want to practice in certain states that
have other restrictions and so we are
seeing that patients are um deciding
where they live based on their ability
to
practice the final question on this
subject with this witness and I'm here
as long as you all are so final question
thank you Mr chair um oh dear now I've
lost the question are you federally
funded yes you are okay we um well
there's some nuances there um Dartmouth
Dartmouth Health has um we are a public
um institution that has um patients who
have Medicaid coverage Medicare coverage
um we we take all um patients regardless
of their ability to pay we also our
research institution very proud of the
the work that our um our facilities are
doing and so yes we have we do receive
federal funds for research as
well I I believe that was the question
let's move on
much did Patricia Hughes ever come
back no no apparently not okay also
signed up to speak is Simon
um that's Simon Amaya price I have two
last names sorry no worries it happens
database
breaker um good afternoon thank you for
introducing this bill and allowing me to
testify my name is Simon Maya price
today I had sit in front of you as a
20-year-old man but for 3 years I
thought I was a girl I received my
bachelor's degree in music last December
with additional coursework at Harvard
University and statistics I remember
being 14 I was sitting in my
pediatrician's office explaining to him
that I was transgender and that my
father wasn't affirming my new identity
so my pediatrician asked my father would
you like a dead son or a living
daughter I was in the room when he asked
this question there's no other situation
when a doctor is allowed to suggest
suicide like this to a patient and quite
frankly it's medical malpractice if you
ask parents of trans identified kids and
other d transitioners you'll discover
that this is a common line used to
manipulate parents du to consenting to
these procedures despite being referred
to my local gender Clinic three times by
three separate doctors the emotional
blackmail and my gender dysphoria
diagnosis my father refused me to take
refused to take me to be medicalized and
I hated him for it at the time but now I
am deeply grateful and it's not just me
3% of my generation identifies as
transgender between the time I left my
high school in 10th Grade and my class
graduated one sixth of the boys in my
class started identifying as trans many
of whom medicalized my girlfriend is a d
transitioner and I can't do much more
than pray that if and when we decide to
have kids that despite the double
mastectomy which prudes her from ever
breastfeeding and the four years of
cross- seex hormones she was given
starting from when she was a minor that
she is able to carry a pregnancy DET
term the other side believes that if you
don't give trans identified kids puberty
blockers cross- seex hormones and
surgeries they will kill themselves that
is a damned lie I am living proof of
that fact I was not put on hormones I
was not operated on and I've grown up to
be a healthy and happy 20-year-old man
I've also talked to parents with
d-transition or children who killed
themselves after realizing they
regretted what they had done to their
bodies what would you say to those
parents the other side of this issue has
both psychological and economic
incentives to oppose this spill imagine
if you will having administered cross-
seex hormones or puberty blockers or
referred children to have such
procedures what would you do if you were
presented with the evidence that what
you were doing wasn't helping your
patients but indeed permanently harming
your patients I know I would have a very
hard time accepting that transgender
healthcare is a multi-billion dollar
industry though estimates vary the
lifetime cost of providing a
trans-identified individual with
hormones and surgeries exceeds $100,000
on average what would you do if you were
a hospital administrator or doctor who
made a million dollars for every 10
patients you treated if you are serious
about protecting families and the health
of children you must Vote for This Bill
thank you very much thank you
representative TZ thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for taking my question I
apologize I where did you say you were
from Massachusetts Live okay thank you
um follow follow were you paid to give
wish anyone
else representative of lus thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um what influenced your transgender
identification I experienced two years
of near daily homophobic bullying in
seventh and eighth
grade I was called the F slur which I
will not repeat on a near daily basis by
my classmates and I received little to
no sympathy from the administration I
moved to a new school in nth grade um
shortly after my my friend group left me
and I was sexually assaulted by an older
boy who was 18 at the time on a school
trip I started looking for answers I
didn't understand what I was going
through this distress I was feeling was
real I joined the gay trade Alliance or
the gender and sexuality Alliance and we
watched this trans YouTuber called
Contra points who is a male to female
transitioner this is where I learned
about the concept of gender dysphoria
and the fact that there is a a clear
pathway to solve what I thought I was
feeling I was uncomfortable with my
secondary sexual characteristics I was
uncomfortable with being a man and I was
dissociated from my body it didn't help
that in my health class I was taught
about the gender unicorn and the teacher
asked me and my classmates to place our
our identities on of sex gender identity
gender expression um romantic attraction
and sexual attraction on these these
Spectra and um
I think that that sums it up pretty well
additionally um I am bisexual and I am
autistic and I suffered from a lot of um
internalized homophobia obviously and um
difficulties pertaining to socialization
due to the fact that I am
autistic just actually a second question
act uh with kind of coat tailing off of
uh representative tus um so why are you
here today to testify to us then
I am here today because I have I have
lost two of my friends to
suicide in my generation and in my age
group rather suicide is the second
death this is a large population level
problem and it sickens me that trans
rights activists are using my dead
friends as bargaining
chips my girlfriend has been permanently
harmed by these Medical Treatments my
friend Corey over there has been
permanently harmed by these Medical
Treatments kids are being lied to
parents are being emotionally
manipulated and I personally think that
this is the worst medical
experimentation we have seen since World
War II the same hormones we are giving
young boys were the same hormones we
administered to Alan Turing in Britain
to cure his homosexuality this is
unforgivable additionally I take deep
offense with those to
compare people like me advocating for my
side to to Nazis I'm
Jewish people have called me a Nazi for
speaking up about this yesterday
somebody tried to dox me the other side
doesn't want people like me to exist
because I invalidate a central tenant of
their ideology that's why I'm here today
thank you so much representative kessle
wi thank you Mr chair I'm going to ask
you a question specific to like other
people that have testified today is
there anything that you had for
therapies or anything else that you that
you have dealt with over the years that
helped you through the process of
anything I was extremely lucky um to my
my dad actually helped me a lot um he
was able to find me a better therapist
uh compared to my my previous gender
affirming therapist um who was able to
deal with my underlying problems my
sexual trauma my depression my anxiety
my PTSD like symptoms
and um learning to accept the fact that
I'm autistic I also found um joining a
sexual assault Survivor support group my
second year of college very helpful um
at the end of the day 75% of it was luck
25% of it was maybe my dad saying no he
did not affirm me and 5% of it was my
own critical thinking skills the more I
talk to other D transitioners um the
more I realized just how close I was to
doing irreparable harm to my body and
I've had nightmares for years about
waking up paralyzed on a surgeon's table
looking down at my genitalia and seeing
the penile and virgin surgeries which
are done on boys like
me Al
set one final question
yeah thank you Mr
chairman um so what would you say to
it might be hard to understand right
now
but if you don't do anything to
permanently alter your body you'll be
healthier in the long run you won't risk
regretting the permanent harm you've
done to your body and someday somebody
will love you for who and what you are I
didn't believe it when I was 14 I didn't
believe that for years but I have been
lucky to meet some very special people
you know my girlfriend um not least of
which of wh whom rather um have loved me
for me and accepted the fact that I am a
man it was very difficult for me growing
up because I felt like masculinity and
being a man was villainized I grew up in
in Boston which is a very liberal City
and I felt like I was the the kind of
the the subject of this Collective guilt
that all of the crimes that men commit
people would talk about how men commit
all of the murders all of the rape all
of the sexual
assault and that all men Were Somehow
guilty of that that weighed very hardly
on me and um I'm you're loved you will
be loved
regardless of the fact that you are a
man we need men there are many ways to
be a man
you don't have to be a gun toing
Southern cowboy hat Yeehaw type of guy
you can be feminine you can be pretty
you can love other men and none of that
makes you any less of a
man thank you all right uh with that
thank you very much thank
recess
e
okay thank you everyone for your
patience and that Indulgence the clerk
and I had been sitting here continuously
since 9:30 this morning and mother
nature just wasn't willing to give us
any more uh forgiveness or tolerance
so anyway U moving on uh next up to
um did I pronounce it
correctly Mar okay Maru okay push the
button on your
mic um I just want to preface this by
saying that I have done an online
testimony already and I just wanted to
uh make a few comments to clarify some
things that people have been asking
about um gender affirming care
I am the parent of a trans child and I
have seen them through their
transition and I want to clear up some
misconceptions about
how um the availability and the ease of
getting transgender affirming care
because my child started showing signs
of being trans right around four by the
time they were in fifth grade they were
referring to themselves as a male and a
male name
also and by the time they were 14 they
decided that they wanted to besides
socially transitioning all this time it
was a long process they wanted to do um
hormones now the process is not very
easy first you need to call your doctor
and you need to get a referral and those
referrals take at least six months to
get an appointment and when you
get
there you have to be psychologically
evaluated you have to have a physical
exam you have to State out why and how
long you have been transitioning and how
you feel about it and then after all of
that which takes months it could take up
to six months to or more then the child
decides if and when they're going to
take
Purity blockers or hormones my child
they gave them a choice how would you
like to
proceed in your gender affirming care
and my child says I would like to take
hormone blockers and hormones and they
said okay make sure all of the health
things and all of the uh psychological
things are in place between all that
time from the very beginning to the
journey
of getting that referral to getting
hormones was over two
years now my child has already spoken
today my child was on hormones like he
said for a year and then he got cancer
and he made the choice to get off of
hormone therapy because he didn't want
it to interrupt he was given a choice to
stay on hormone therapy if he wanted to
he chose not to and during that time
while he was going through Cancer
Treatments he reverted back to having
menstruation
being more feminine likee there were no
effects that were not
reversible and then after he finally
became you know cancer-free thank
goodness stage four cancer he went back
onto hormone treatment continue just
about 10 seconds okay and I just wanted
to you to know that I'm here to answer
questions that you may have about
timelines and how long
this process takes thank you thank you
questions no questions wow okay okay
Terell we need a pink card from you um I
as myself um Sarah Lind Sarah asked
to oh you had already spoken yourself
yeah um well is there a written
testimony you can just give us then
Sarah her well if you've already spoken
though we only usually allow one person
to
oh
you this testimony is on behalf of Sarah
Terell my name is Laura
kitzy I'm not speak just speaking to you
today as a concerned citizen I'm
speaking to you as a mother a mother who
loves her child more than anything in
the world a mother who like every parent
wants nothing more than for her child to
be safe healthy and happy and yet I find
myself here once again pleading for my
right to provide my daughter with the
life-saving medical care she
needs in every other circumstance our
State trusts parents to make medical
decisions for their own children parents
decide when their child needs therapy
when they need surgery and when they
need medication but with this bill the
government is telling me that I as a
mother am incapable of making the right
medical decisions for my child that I
don't know what is best for her that my
daughter's life her very existence is a
political issue rather than a deeply
personal medical bill medical one let me
be clear this bill does not protect
children it puts them in danger I
strongly oppose this bill the risks to
transgender youth are not hypothetical
they are real Studies by the American
Academy of Pediatrics have found that
more than half of transgender male
adolescents attempt suicide for
non-binary youth the number is
41% for transgender female adolescence
it is 30% these are not just numbers the
a real children children like my
daughter who are crying out for help and
we have the power to help them I'm not
willing to gamble with my daughter's
life I am not willing to sit by why
politicians who have never met her who
do not know her heart or her struggles
make medical decisions on her behalf I
refuse to let my government strip me of
my right and my responsibility to
protect her every time I come before a
committee like this I look each of you
in the eye and beg beg you to help me
keep my daughter alive I am doing that
again today please please let me care
for my child let me do what every loving
parent strives to do keep my child safe
I promise you she is worth it thank
you thank you representative Drew I was
just going to say ma'am could you uh let
me have that written testimony so I can
enter it into the record oh sure thank
golden you've asked for five minutes
again limiting testimony to quick as I
can guys thank you so much for allowing
me to be here in front of you today uh
my name is Eric golden I'm a resident of
Belmont and I'll try to uh get through
this as Speedy as I can I just want to
start with a few relevant points here
that came up during the course of
conversation that as a father of a
transgender child that I would like to
give my uh my insight on I've been doing
this for quite some time now since about
2017 uh so our growing International
consensus that was brought up during
here today of some European countries
that are on they're trying to outlaw
this sort of practice I don't know
anything about that but uh I don't I'm
just wondering when uh New Hampshire
started caring about what other other
people did right uh I also want to say
that the result of transgender suicide
is not the fact that people are
transgender the result is federal state
and local governments social uh problems
and and unsupported family members drive
people to have to feel like there's
nowhere else for them to go so suicide
is not is not a byproduct of being
transgender uh no no support system in
place is really the cause and that's
what this bill uh is is will only serve
to
um this bill flies in the
face of the trusted relationship between
mental health care providers
and medical providers and the ability of
families to be able to navigate this
homes people talk about well we don't we
Outlaw tattoos we Outlaw cigarettes we
Outlaw tobacco but these things are are
publicly available over the
counter my child has to go through
mental health evaluations it's been
she's been going through this for years
it's not something we just walked into
to the doctor's office and decided that
hey let's do this oh you know you're
transgender great let's get you on
hormones it doesn't work like that and
if anyone's telling you that it does
they're lying to you or they don't know
what they're talking about so thank you
for that I would just leave it one more
one more
thing to in rhetorical question to our
cisgender people in this room when you
were four when you were three when you
were five did you question at all what
you
were and if not which probably the
answer is no why is that opinion any
less relevant than a child who does
question who they
relevant I'm going to read something
that I wrote in 2017 as a Father's Day
piece and I've Rewritten it here to fit
the to fit this uh scenario so please
bear with me when my family began this
journey I was given advice by someone I
was close with they told me to continue
insisting that my son was that my
daughter was my son 15 seconds Sir so
please I have six copies of this and
it's one page if you if I can just get
through it well again I can't extend it
beond the 15 seconds I'm sorry that's
unfortunate but but but but please
distribute it the bill is is uh is uh
clearly but please please pass it out we
do want to see
need any questions for this Happ to take
questions any
questions uh representative Lucas thank
you Mr chair and thanks for answering my
question uh you said something about a
uh something you wrote for Father's Day
and this is a subject that's very
important to you I'd like to know
why I am uh I'm just an average American
white cisgender guy and I don't didn't
have the language before I had children
that taught me the language and for me
to I'm not gonna we talk about
experimental drugs right I'm not going
to experiment or gamble with my who my
child says that they are just because I
don't believe it I'm not gonna do I'm
not gonna do that because somebody
mentioned oh well you know would you
rather have a a son that's alive or or a
daughter that's alive or or as the case
may be or a son or a daughter that's
dead I'm not even asking myself that
question the answer is my children know
who they are and it's my job it's my job
to follow their lead and help them
mindfield how can a governing body come
in and try to get between the
relationship of mental health experts
medical experts and family Dynamics it's
belong thank you for your question
representative thank you anyone
else seeing no one okay thank you sir
thank
you also signed up to speak is AJ kidi
from
gtown I didn't really prepare for this
bill honestly but I just have something
to say anyway can I just ask did you
spell your last name CI TTI it's c o l e
TTI okay great thank you yeah um these
kinds of legislative proposals are
rooted in nothing other than Prejudice
and therefore fallacy
I haven't heard a bit of reason or
legitimate evidence to prove why this
kind of stuff should be codified by law
only disputing a personal fears and
opinions from both sides the difference
between the queer community's fears and
opinions is that we aren't asking for
them to be made Superior or necessary
for anyone else to believe Through The
Binding force of law all we want is to
exist without being afraid of who we are
not be anointed righteous by her majesty
Elon Musk I don't know why I wrote that
I was just sitting right there um we
could could easily agree to disagree if
those who disagreed with us would end
there instead of further persecuting Us
by making our livelihoods illegal Our
Lives us people were only as harmful or
harmless as anyone else as a person's
Worth or moral goodness has nothing to
do with physicality there's a
fundamental problem with having to argue
about this type of stuff and it's one of
extremes you can't sit up here saying
all trans people are this and I can't
sit up here saying all Republicans or
whoever are that because we don't live
in a world nor have we ever lived in a
world where it is reason or intelligent
to generalize anything since the dawn of
time all that's happened is a bunch of
natural exceptions quite literally the
reason we're standing here today is
because something wildly unexpected
happened in a tiny concentration of
immeasurable energy randomly started to
expand the point is some of us
desperately need to reevaluate what we
believe to be true because the world is
not black and white never has been and
never will be stop making it so hard to
just be okay with being gray making it
illegal won't change the laws of nature
I would also like to address the thing
that that guy said he asked the question
he was like did they tell you the side
effects before you got on hormones um
yeah they did you know when they didn't
tell me the side effects of sorry
things when I took birth control when I
they gave me the pill they didn't tell
me the side effects of those and those
are the same as the hormones I'm taking
to be trans same thing same with
anti-depressants they didn't tell me
those side effects like you know when
you hear the end of a commercial on TV
and it's all those horrible things they
told me that for testosterone not for
other things so I just want to make that
that abundantly clear and then the 99%
of the time things someone said 99% of
the time you hear about how people are
all happy about it and not that they
were like upset by their decision to
transition probably because 99% of the
time people are happy about it and I'm
genuinely sorry for the people who have
had terrible experiences but how many
times are we going to treat the symptom
and not the cause because someone
someone who literally told us why they
thought that they were Trans in the
first place was not because of the woke
liberals it was because they were
already being persecuted for being a
feminite as a man so like isn't the
cause here a little bit different than
what we're trying to get at with this
bill seconds that's I'm I mean actually
let me just make
sure yeah I don't know it is life saving
for some people um what are we defining
life saving or safe by is something safe
completely harmless and never has hurt
anyone in the world cuz then safe
doesn't exist everything on this God
Green Earth can hurt you anyway okay
that's that's it thank
you well did you have questions probably
not you guys want to get out here we're
gonna we're gonna be here for a while we
got another bill yet so I have latero
okay for
L okay thank you also signed up to speak
you yeah after a bunch of Massachusetts
people testified but thank you for
listening yeah I'm a New Hampshire
resident so um I'm not going to read
this whole thing you have a copy and a
lot of it's been reiterated but I will
tell you that as a parent of a
transgender now 24 year old or almost 24
year old who came out as transgender a
15 he's still
transgender he will always be
transgender he knows who he is and so do
we as parents and I believe in science
I'm a registered nurse and I find it
deeply offending offensive that some
people in here accuse me of doing things
like mutilate allowing me to mutilate my
child excuse me I work with a population
that um terrorizes and abuses their
children do not how dare you do not
compare me to one of those people how
dare
you I've had I've been doing this since
2018 my child is transgender he's not
going to change his mind we went through
like everybody else said multiple time
multiple sessions of therapy with
psychologist therapist psychiatrist
endocrinologist primary care doctors
we've been through it all and you don't
just walk in nilly Willy and say oh I'm
transgender give me some testosterone
today it's stupid and I'll tell you
something
else the Republicans are the ones that
always seem to have a problem with
transgender people stop using my child
and other transgender people as
it
you also signed up to speak is Dr
Michael
Lon I'll take less than two hours k I
think we're almost done um Mr chairman
members of the committee thank you for
allowing me the three minutes to testify
um hearing previous testimony I want to
call out that my testimony will be
limited to normal physiology and
specifically to Pediatric and Adolescent
young adults under the age 18 years of
age as that's how the bill is
written going through um I'm going to go
kind of fast here um I'm going to start
by going back 3,000
years I think everyone in here has heard
uh someone named hypocrates primum non
noer first Do no harm for those of you
who have actually read the Hippocratic
Oath literally the very next sentence is
a promise by physicians not to offer
poison to their patients even if the
patients ask for
it slightly past
hypocrates a man named
Aristotle came up with the term sexual
dimorphism and actually pondered how not
only humans but other animals are
sexually dimorphic that is there are two
Sexes skipping forward just a little bit
of History because I think we are here
to understand are we actually doing harm
or potentially doing harm um to
Children normal physiology I have heard
people say sex assigned at Birth that is
absolutely asinine it does not follow
science after conception whether you XX
or XY whether you have testes in a penis
is determined by a gene called sry it's
actually normally found on Dy chromosome
people who have things such as Turner
syndrome which would be not covered by
this law they're actually accepted by
this um can be explained by the SR y
Gene actually being transcribed instead
of being on the Y chromosome it can be
found on the X chromosome this was found
in
1990 um that particular Gene if we're
looking at development normal physiology
at 6 weeks begins to be expressed at
that point normal human fetus developing
has both male and female
genitalia as soon as sry is expressed at
eight weeks of
development if the person is going to
become a male all of the female tracks
have already degraded takes a little
longer than women it's actually out to
about 12 weeks at which point um the
wolfy and ducks and women would have um
degraded at six months six months baby's
still in the
womb testosterone reaches a level in the
developing fetus that Rivals that of an
adult 20-year-old male which I'm far
past um but when males have um really
their their Peak conditioning around the
20year age
range I think it's important to
understand when we're talking about
normal physiology that hormones are
responsible for long term remodeling of
the human body okay um if you want to
look whether drugs are reversible um
please don't don't look to me don't look
to anyone in this pull up the drugs
which have been approved by the FDA
every one of them carries the strongest
warning possible for
suicide thank you thank you are you
taking questions happy to take questions
any questions for Dr L representative
delus thank you Mr chairman um do you
have experience in hormone research
thank you for the question um I'm a nerd
um I actually started doing biomedical
research when I was in high school after
college I had studied both biochemistry
chemistry I was offered an opportunity
to join a lab which I never thought I
would do it was a wonderful opportunity
and I studied female hormone
biosynthesis for over a year before I
went to Dartmouth medical school I have
a PhD not MD um that was wonderful I
learned their hormones it's like a
chorus
my my mentor there hormones in the human
body are a chorus it's an orchestra if
you will you can't simply change out one
tenor you can't change out one person
Orchestra representative King thank you
Mr chair question um was asked before
about if uh puberty blocking hormones
are FDA approved are any of them FDA
approved are they FDA so yes with a
caveat are they approved and how they're
used Physicians can use anyone who can
prescribe a drug in the state of New
Hampshire and I don't remember where the
line is drawn between NPS and other
qualified Healthcare Providers can
prescribe drugs beyond their intended
use it it happens all the time I work in
oncology cancer medicine we very
regularly use that if you look at the
G&R agonists if you look at the drugs
that are called puberty blockers now
they're used in other things um are they
approved as intended have they been
researched there
um I would encourage you and other
members of this committee they're called
um the package insert you can literally
if you go to one of them it's called
Lupron I'm not bias towards any I have
no financial interest in this ad.com at
the end lie and say you're a healthcare
provider right at the top it'll say
prescribing
information it's very easy to read
what's on there you don't need to
understand the doses Etc all of the
warnings are provided right there the
most strong warnings that the FDA issues
are called blackbox warning there's a
thin black line around it um as I
remember Lupron actually has some pretty
strong warnings on it that uh if you're
going to give the drugs to children it's
up to this committee to take a look at
and see followup so as a followup in
your extensive research it sounds like
you've done research on this on hormone
stuff would you say that changing
hormone makeup at an adolescent age
definitely changes the a lot of
different things and not just one
specific thing that we can point to
could cause other issues so the impact
of hormones is absolutely multifactorial
it goes through a whole list of body
processes your the brain the muscles um
the the volume that you're able to take
into your lungs the endurance that you
have um psychosocial there there are
many many things that the hormones can
do have there been formal studies
evaluating this to say if I give someone
a hormone what spec and we start at
childhood what specific changes are done
there are not many um well-controlled
studies uh describing that so I I I
can't say because the data is not
questions representative lontine thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um but it it seems like you're
saying that there's a whole mix of
hormones in our bodies and that all of
us are born with
um testosterone and estrogen and it
manifests in different to different
degrees correct we all have some
both ye so that is true there are males
have
a the sex related hormones testosterone
is dominant there it generally is formed
in the
testes it can also be formed in other
tissues fatty tissues the research is
still ongoing and that this has been a
big curiosity um and interestingly men
you may want to know without estrogen
you wouldn't have the same bone density
that you have now um similarly in women
the estrogens which is actually a class
of steroids are the dominant hormone
that are there yes they generally come
from the ovaries they can also be
produced in other tissues as well um and
this whole cycle actually when we were
talking about puberty blockers I call
those out specifically they actually
Target the pituitary gland um to stop
two hormones there a different class of
hormones they're not steroidal hormones
but those are signals that come down and
actually directly impact um the goads in
both male and female
else hopefully answered the question we
could spend hours on this just a brief
followup followup it's okay
um I believe it's um one half of a
percent and possibly more babies are
born with ambiguous sexual genitalia and
also their hormones may also not fit in
what we normally would see as male or
female and do you think it's
possible that um it's harder to
identify individuals who are male or
female um because they lack having
something so visible as ambiguous
genitalia and that perhaps for certain
percent of the population they truly
feel that they're not male or female or
perhaps have the wrong um manifestation
of what in their body they feel is
something else do you believe that's
possible so that's an excellent question
that was actually the topic of a plenary
talk I believe it was 2017 at the
American Urology Association back in
1973 the United States passed
legislation um I believe it was DDT that
had been the Hot Topic at the
time drugs called estrogen memetics if
you think of soybeans these are one of
the classic ones you can have drugs that
mimic estrogen and if they happen at the
right point in development you can
absolutely get androgynous genitalia um
following in that same class are also a
condition called hypospadius and
micropenis um well micropenis is obvious
what it is hypospadius don't Google it
around lunch it's also a devastating um
condition are these people potentially
confused absolutely they re they require
Medical Care and compassion does it mean
they're trans not
necessarily they absolutely need care
this has been something that uh has been
brewing for quite a while and I it this
it's multifactorial how that uh how that
arises anyone
else seeing no one else thank you thank
you thanks for staying so long oh thanks
for your
patience also signed up to speak is
Steven
leond okay thank
testimony the direct harm that this bill
would do has been thoroughly stated
today I'm going to talk a little bit
about the secondary
effects the Bill's short title is the
vulnerable child compassion and
protection act
transg excuse me transgender children
exist they are at risk what they need is
understanding and compassion and most
importantly belief from the important
people in their lives they exist and
this bill further stigmatizes something
that is already incredibly hard to deal
with for the person going through
it researchers at the Trapper project
the leading Suicide Prevention and
Crisis Intervention Organization for
lgbtq plus
people published a study in a PE review
journal Nature human behavior that found
anti-transgender state level laws have a
significant and causal impact on suicide
risk among transgender and non-binary
young people across the United States
laws like this one increase suic rates
of suicide attempts by lgbtqia plus
youth by as much as
72% and that's among a group that is
already more than four times more likely
to attempt suicide than the general
population previous testimony that cited
outdated and debunked studies would
happy believe that suicidality in
transgender people isn't a real problem
I would encourage you to do your own
research there have been accounts today
related to people being pushed into
transition I'm not here to advocate for
that and you've heard from parents today
who've told you that that's not what
happened with their
kids the medication should be prescribed
along with therapy and only after long
and careful consideration together with
the child and their
parents the aim of these medications in
regard to chance gender health is to
reduce harm and banning their use is not
the
answer the decision of whether or not to
use prity blockers ought to rest with
the physician their parents and the
child and not with the government this
bill would deny access to medication
that can save lives and in all
likelihood lead to an increase of
suicide attempts by vulnerable children
in New Hampshire I oppose this
Bill thank you any
questions seeing none thank you thanks
okay one last call Patricia Hughes did
Patricia Hughes ever come back I don't
see her apparently not okay thank you
and the final person to that as far as I
know at least that who signed up to
speak Jamie Reid from the courage
coalition
please put your microphone on good
afternoon my name is Jamie Reid I hold a
master's of Science and clinical
research management I am a lifelong
Democrat a mom of five boys three of
whom were adopted out of the foster care
system and I am a lesbian I am also the
public whistleblower from a pediatric
gender Center where I worked where I saw
patients from the age of three until the
age of 26 and I worked with nearly 1,500
unique patients I worked in pediatric
gender medicine for nearly 5 years and I
was once a True Believer what I learned
is that these are interventions based on
poor research with poor evidence and
poor outcomes I believe that my time
best today will be used simply
explaining how a puberty blocker is
clinically used and how it came to be
used in children three mental health
providers in the Netherlands
hypothesized that the reason why
transsexual adults were not doing well
was because they could not pass
primarily men could not pass as women
they hypothesized that they could inter
in early childhood to cosmetically help
them look better as adults so they
devised a study giving a puberty blocker
when children reach Tanner stage 2 they
believe that the puberty blocker could
be part of a diagnostic determination
giving children quote a time to think it
did not work that way it became a
one-way pathway and nearly every child
ever put on a puberty blocker has gone
on to cross- sex hormones they tested
this thre part protocol step one a
puberty blocker step two cross- seex
hormon step three surgery they tried
this first on 70 children so-called
patient X is a young lesbian in fact 68
of the 70 young people admitted that
they were same sex attracted as a
lesbian This concerns me because most of
us EXP experienced profound questioning
of our sexed bodies in childhood and
Adolescence in the first study one young
person died they died because the pubal
blockade meant that their penis never
developed and they were unable to have
the type of vaginoplasty that would
invert a penis instead the surgeons had
to use a portion of their colon they
developed a massive infection and this
young person died the first study
concluded that these patients might be
feeling better because they actually
completely switched the measurement
scales the British then tried to repeat
the puberty blockers study in 2011 the
outcomes were so poor they refused to
publish the results the researchers
found quote puberty blockers had not
changed subjects well-being including
rates of self harm within the United
States a puberty blocker study has been
completed in a New York Times article on
October 23rd the reason why we have not
yet read it was finally explained Quote
us study on puberty blockers goes
unpublished because of politics Dr said
the leaders of this long running study
said the drugs do not improve mental
distress thank
you did
I representative Kastle I me thank you
Mr chair so I I've heard a lot today
about statistics and different
information uh it sounds like there's a
growing concern there's not enough
research uh is there any other specific
research that you can cite because I
haven't heard anything else that says
that it could be to follow up to my
question safe and effective absolutely
so when we look at research we have to
look at something called the Pyramid of
evidence at the very top of that pyramid
is something called a systematic review
of evidence basically it looks at every
single study that's published and they
systematically review all of those
studies to find out what the weight of
the evidence is is it good evidence is
it bad evidence we have had multiple
Nations across the world complete
systematic reviews of evidence they've
reviewed puberty blockers cross- sex
hormones surgeries they've reviewed
everything even binding and tucking what
they have found is systematically the
reviews of evidence show that there is
little to no statistical support that
these interventions treat what they are
intended to treat that does not mean
that individuals will not say I quote
feel better we do not judge a medical
intervention based unfortunately on an
individual's response we have to look at
it from a systematic level the countries
that have completed systematic reviews
of evidence are almost all primarily
liberal Northern countries in Europe
Finland Sweden the UK the UK's
systematic review of evidence took four
years the outcome of that study was to
ban puberty blockers in a bipartisan
manner from the use in England Canada
released two more systematic reviews of
evidence just last month they reviewed
puberty blockers and cross- sex hormones
both of those systematic reviews of
evidence show little to no so support
for these treatments when you have poor
support for the treatment you have to
then look at how bad are the possible
bad outcomes so if we can't prove that
it works well we then have to make a
decision could it really hurt and what
we know is that we don't have evidence
that they work well and what they really
hurt is that they sterilize children
they remove sexual function and they
systems that's it any other
questions representative
Drew do you know of any other models
where people treat based on a patient
self-
diagnosis no and what's so challenging
with this is that so many people today
said things like this take so long that
the diagnostic process process is very
you know indepth that they had to see a
therapist what I can tell you is that
this diagnostic process which is based
on something called the dsm5 so this is
a considered a mental health condition
the reason why we pay for this with our
insurance is because it's in the
dsm5 the way that people actually
diagnose this is based on written
criteria that criteria includes things
like a strong desire to be of the other
G gend or insist that one is the other
gender most gays and lesbians do this in
childhood the other elements to this
diagnosis include a strong preference
for cross-gender roles and make believe
so if a child wants to play the prince
or the
princess that is how the dsm5 is
diagnosing gender dysphoria in childhood
in addition if you prefer to play with
toys of the quote other gender if a
woman a girl grew up wanting to play
with Legos instead of Barbie Dells she
would meet the criteria in the dsm5 for
gender
dysphoria in boys if a boy rejects
typical masculine toys games activities
or prefers to play with girls they would
meet meet criteria for gender dysphoria
in the
dsm5 when I have read all of the
criteria in the dsm5 to Gay and Lesbian
adults they meet every single diagnostic
determination this is the most
homophobic protocol I have ever seen
devised and we were once forcibly raped
to make us straight and we were once
chemically
treated to make us straight and we are
now using the current dsm5 to say if you
are not a stereotypical boy or girl you
meet criteria for gender
dysphoria other
questions yes representative Miller
thank you Mr does Meeting those criteria
hormones no thank
you no so what happened you answered the
question thank you you can she can speak
did did you want to elaborate or yes
absolutely so what happens is when we
have young people children who do not
fit the stereotypical role of their
Early Childhood what used to happen is
those boys or those masculine
little girls would be brought to a
therapist and that therapist would tell
the parents whether or not they should
socially transition the child what's
happening now is that older adolescents
we see this as a true social contagion
as well older adolescents are
identifying and stating that they meet
this criteria they will come in to a
therapist and the therapist does not do
anything else but say do you identify as
trans the young person says yes I do and
then in my own Center that was enough
and yes children were receiving cross-
seex hormones and puberty blockers after
one meeting with the child therapist and
one meeting with the Pediatric
endocrinologist it was a very rapid
protocol so yes you can essentially walk
yourself right in and get yourself on
hormones anyone else one one followup
one question thank you Mr chair so that
brought up a really good point uh I
mentioned before the Dartmouth had it on
their website that it was the first
thing that they do when it comes to it
was the hormone uh in the first step and
their medical
step in your professional experience
how is It Broken Out In most other
places or in your experience what is it
how was that process done um thank you
for your question I'm was really
appalled that Dartmouth could not answer
the question how many children they have
medically transitioned I can let you
know that between 209 and 2023 they
medically transitioned 76 patients at
the dartman hith Hitchcock Medical
Center at the Dartmouth Hitchcock Clinic
they medicalized three patients they
wrote 353 prescriptions they buil build
close to $100,000 in submitted charges
this is over a 4-year period And this is
only the patients that they collect
correctly build to insurance so this
data is there I cannot believe that they
would not answer the question on how
many people that they have done this too
however in a center like that I also
worked in a multidisciplinary center
exactly like they have set up at
Dartmouth the wath guidelines themselves
essentially state if a child states that
they are trans and at least one parent
or legal guardian agrees with that
assertion then that child can be
medically transitioned no questions
asked okay any final questions
representative
delus thank you Mr chairman um you
referen the um cross- seex hormones do
puberty blockers uh does a puberty
blocker followed by sex hormones result
in eventually permanent stability
absolutely if you follow the protocol
correctly as it was created by the Dutch
you start a puberty blockade at Tanner
stage two at Tanner stage two the penis
is not developed the testicles have not
dropped and the testicles do not have
the pathways to create sperm so women
are born with all of our eggs that we're
ever going to have and ever be able to
use for our fertility boys actually have
to grow the pathways into their fertil
ility if you block at Tanner stage
two and go on to cross- sex hormones
infertility and sterility is a 100%
guaranteed in clinical Theory we were
hypothesizing that if we go in and
harvest a portion of that testicular
tissue and freeze it if that young
person later decides that they want to
have biological children of their
own what the
hypothesized clinical idea is is that we
could actually implant that testicular
tissue into a pouch on the
abdomen let that testicular tissue
revascularize and grow and see if it
could later go through the process to
create sperm we have no no protocol to
do that
it is guaranteed that if you follow this
protocol correctly a young male at 10an
or two cross- sex hormones will be
sterile it is a true human rights
people I believe it's a human rights
violation to take away from my community
from protog gay boys the right to their
future fertility I think it's a human
rights violation against
them follow up is it a quick one yeah
thank you um at what age does does this
stability occur I mean is it later is it
earlier than I would imagine I don't
know so Tanner stage 2 is not an age
Tanner staging is how we determine how
far along someone is in puberty Tanner
stage two in boys I think we actually
even heard a young
young man was started at the age of 10
most girls start puberty earlier boys
start puberty later we actually have a
whole chemical question right now
younger and younger ages are being seen
in girls there's an issue here that does
need to be looked at most girls will
start puberty earlier than boys if you
catch the boy at Tanner stage two and we
give that puberty blocker as soon as we
start dosing with that cross- seex
hormone that fertility is essentially
damaged for life in my Center we were
putting Boys on a puberty blockade and
leaving them on that I think also you
heard from some older trans identified
men yes it seems to me that the answer
is going Way Beyond the question which
was at what age and we are now talking
about theal treatments and I'm a little
concerned about those people who have
been waiting for almost two hours to get
to the next bill point of order she can
speak she has a right to speak well she
she does but but yes sorry age is just
not the answer it's based on clinical
question that was award it yes the
answer is basically there is not an age
this is based on clinical guidelines for
when Tanner stage two
occurs any final questions I would like
to move
on okay thank you thank you okay I
hopefully have not missed anyone we had
a huge stack of people Tes Ying huge
stack of the pin cards hopefully I have
not missed
anyone I don't think I did all right so
at this point I'm going to close the
public hearing on HB 377 FN I am going
to open the public hearing on HB 712 FN
and recognize once again the prime
sponsor uh who is once again
representative merer from
Grown we are going to be changing the
sign to reflect the hearing that we will
be the bill that we will be
eat thanks for coming
too many I'm just making
sure I'm not going to get out of here by
5 o' there's a problem for the staff but
can lunch we've done everything we can
to
this just got a one quick question start
Sor no that's okay anybody mind if I
open the window no not at all I may jump
did I think so sounds like don't
know s me what that is yeah because I
can amend it still before we vote on
it
you just for a second I think yeah
yeah
yeah theal health and Ary space is where
sector thank you everyone um thank you
for that uh brief Indulgence we want to
move on to the second bill of the day HB
712 FN and once again recognize the
prime sponsor who is once again
representative Lisa merer representative
Maser can we shut that door play thank
you thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee again for the record my
name is Lisa merer I represent District
44 the towns of gtown and
wear I am here today to present
legislation that limits gender surgeries
for minors while allowing breast surgery
exceptions for cases of medical
necessity minors undergo significant
physical and psychological changes
during adolescence medical experts
acknowledge that breast development
continues into the late teens and
surgical interventions at a young age
may carry unnecessary risks it is
essential to ensure that miners have the
maturity and informed consent capacity
to make such life-altering
decisions you will hear many compelling
stories today and although an individual
story can be very compelling and we've
heard many of them today it is not a
basis for an experimental medical
protocol carrying a heavy medical
burden gender surgeries whether for
augmentation reduction or other
non-medically necessary purposes carry
potential complications including
surgical risks such as infection
scarring and complications from
anesthesia the possibility of future
medical or psychological regret impacts
on future breastfeeding ability and
sensation ation medical ethics emphasize
the principle of Do no harm in cases
where a Minor's physical health is not
at risk postponing surgery until
adulthood allows for fully informed
decision making my testimony this
morning applies to this bill as well
while restricting elective procedures
this legislation appropriately provides
exceptions for medical necessity
including severe cases of juvenile
macromastia which is excessive breast
overdevelopment that causes chronic pain
or posture issues cases of significant
asymmetry that result in physical or
psychological distress reconstructive
surgery due to trauma congenital
conditions or other medically Justified
needs and more these exceptions ensure
that minors who truly need surgical
intervention for health reasons can
still receive appropriate care as I
mentioned earlier today you will hear
today that if these children don't go
through these procedures they are more
likely to commit suicide I referenced it
this morning but page 195 of the cast
report showed that again child sex
procedures don't actually prevent
suicide and the ACLU attorney admitted
that as well just last year a young
autistic woman in New Hampshire filed a
lawsuit against her former
endocrinologist and other medical
providers saying she was misled into
inappropriate gender affirming surgeries
and treatments that left her in pain and
have ruined her life according to the
lawsuit she cannot get back the life
that was stolen from her she will never
be able to conceive and bear a child
even if she could conceive a child she
would never be able to breastfeed her
child she lives in Daily pain from the
effects of the unnecessary surgeries and
years of taking enormous amount of
cross- seex hormones she will never look
the same and has to deal daily with
severe alterations to her female body
such as bone structure and unwanted body
and facial hair she cannot get back the
life that was stolen from her as a child
under Dartmouth Hitchcock's care they
performed a double myectomy as well as
removed her uterus ovaries and Fallopian
tubes she also had a procedure to close
her vagina according to the lawsuit
already hospitals and medical facilities
across the world and our country and yes
someone mentioned earlier that why are
we paying attention to all these other
countries because they are doing studies
that we are not and they are going
through um way more protocols than we
are here and we need to pay attention to
that um
so yes even Boston they're curta
curtailing and ending miners access to
these harmful
procedures so this is Nationwide and
global the Journal of sexual medicine
and I mentioned this study this morning
just put out a new study last week very
recent of a 100,000 plus patients they
found that those with surgery had
significantly higher rates of depression
anxiety suicidal ideation and substance
use div disorder versus matched controls
without
surgery this study found that gender
affirming surgery is a associated with
increased risk of mental health issues
this legislation strikes a necessary
balance between safeguarding miners from
premature elective procedures and
ensuring that those with legitimate
medical needs can access care I urge the
committee to support this measure to
protect the well-being of young
individuals while allowing room for
appropriate medical
discretion thank you
questions representative Woods
thank you Mr chair um and thank you I
just perhaps U these are sort of
technical issues with the bill um on L
page two uh line 21 it refers to
uh surgery as defined in uh 329 colon
53x um there's been an addition by the
bill uh but there's no uh section 10
I'm not I'm not seeing the line number
that you mentioning uh line 21 on page
two yeah minor me number the way yours
are so I've Got Mine mine's taken right
from the site so it's right under
chapter 332 M it's about two sentences
okay yep chap yep okay under uh three uh
colon or Roman 3- a mhm the the second
line down it says RSA 32953
comma X that refers to what was added uh
above U but there's no um section
10 okay
um also on same page line
34 um it says breast surgery subject to
the conditions of um
um 329 colon 54 Roman 2 a through F uh
and that refers to also what's been
added but there's an e but no
F okay we can make those changes I'll go
back and look at them thank you just y
technical issues sure thank you for
questions representative
Weber so this prohibits all
surgeries with the exception of specific
procedures referred to here and specific
conditions referred to
here can you guarantee that there are no
other conditions that occur in miners
that might require
surgery uh this we went through when
this bill was drafted we had a
discussion with medical providers and
encompassed every possible aspect of it
that they thought would be applicable to
this
so
yes follow up and is there a
concern when you testified you talked
about medical necessity and um um you
talked
about major needs for these
surgeries um how are providers supposed
to figure out where the line is between
something that isn't bad enough for
surgery or something that is bad enough
for
surgery thank you I I believe the bill
kind of takes that into consideration in
the exceptions I mean it it it it Maps
so representative Lucas has a question
okay representative Lucas
sorry I you I was wait we're waiting for
an answer still to your question
she answered it okay go ahead represent
thank you for taking my question um just
uh also was uh a kind of a point similar
to what uh representative Woods made um
in the uh last portion of the section
above chapter 332
2B the procedure is needed to remove
malignant tissue and an appropriate
margin you see that M there's no mention
nodes lymph nodes
okay lymph nodes are not breast tissue
but they're often removed as part of a a
surgery for breast malignancy if we feel
that that needs to be part of amendment
we can to we can add that if once we
yeah I'm just I'm just pointing out that
thank you thank you y anyone
you also signed up to speak is Courtney
sure thank you honorable members of the
committee for taking the time to hear my
testimony for the record my name is
Courtney Reid I serve as policy Advocate
with the ACLU of New Hampshire speaking
in opposition to House Bill 712
uh the bottom line of this bill is that
like the earlier uh bill that we
considered
today this bill would subject a class of
people transgender adolescents to
differential treatment by restricting
Health Care to treat gender dysphoria
with a specific carve out for treatments
for gomasa and
macromastia permitting the same
treatment for cisgender adolescent
experiencing different disorders of sex
development but barring these same
procedures for transgender
adolescents this is unjust and
unconstitutional sex
classification and again this bill uh
raises constitutional First Amendment
concerns by prohibiting referrals for
these procedures in other
states this G this bill would prohibit
families from making uh private
healthcare decisions and it puts a
legislature in the middle of medical
decisions despite that surgery for
transgender minors is extremely uncommon
this language sends a message that the
healthcare needs of trans people are
less valid than those of other people it
suggests that the Judgment of trans phys
Physicians and Care teams can be
dismissed and tossed to the
wayside it also disregards associations
like w paath the American Academy of
Pediatrics and the endocrine
Society further the criminal liability
is hovering over the heads of Physicians
is also concerning it is unclear how
bills like this will affect access to
care should it remain legal after dobs
we know that bans and Care affect
physician Recruitment and
Retention and Within These Within These
criminalized practice areas so the
bottom line to keep this brief is that
this bill singles out transgender Youth
and again if safety and regret are
really at the Forefront of concern for
this committee there are different
Avenues to address these like continued
studies or uh considering guard rails
and care so with that in mind I urge you
to oppose House Bill 712 to protect the
rights and well-being of transgender
youth in their families and to keep
medical decisions between doctors
parents and adolescents thank you and
I'm open to any questions thank you any
also signed up to speak is
Alon thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee for the record my name
is Erica Leon I represent Rockingham 13
which is the town of
dairy when it comes to medical
procedures they get to be pretty complex
you know I grew up in southern
California when I've gone back to visit
I've actually been shocked at the number
of young High School age women who have
had implants during sophomore junior
year of school that was never acceptable
that was never normal when I was a kid
but today that's happening and today
there are young minor girls who are
receiving breast augmentations in this
country with doctors performing
that having a breast augmentation with
implants means that you will be having
surgeries and replacing them because
they have health
risks this is a health risk no matter
how you were born but to have an
augmentation and add an implant is a
major risk um there's also the issues of
removing breast tissue uh there's a
young woman who was not able to join us
today because she it's really difficult
to testify on this she's a DD
transitioner she had a double m to me
she's had a child there's still stranded
um tissue in there that's still creating
milk that was causing her pain but she
wasn't able to feed that baby that she
was holding to her chest there's Real
and True consequences here so it's
important to make sure that any of these
procedures are because we are treating a
a physical medical need now this
language um we've looked we we went
through we tried to figure out all of
the details and all the specifics on
when breast surgery is indicated um it
is possible that in the future we may
have some new indication for breast
surgery for young girls if that happens
and that emerges in the medical
literature we'd be able to add those
exemptions but I I have a hard time
seeing how that wouldn't be covered by
malignancy or infection or damage
because if there's malignancy infection
or damage that breast tissue can be
removed and that can be treated um
right now when you talk about what mean
what it talks about when you need to
know whether or not it's allowed the
specific definition definition of
symptomatic m
macromastia is the definition of when
you have such large breasts they cause
nerve problems they cause back problems
and they
symptomatically have a reason why you
need to have a a breast reduction
regardless of your age because it can be
quite shocking um it can be quite
significant and and that is specifically
protected in this bill the point is to
allow you to develop to figure out who
you're going to be and learn how to
become comfortable with that because
watching the kids who grew up in the
area where I did who instead of deciding
that they need to figure out if they're
comfortable with how they are and how
they're developing instead they have the
peer pressure to go and get implants to
15 seconds yeah they go and get implants
because there's a PE peer of pressure
because they're allowed to do it let's
protect childhood and hold off on these
procedures unless there's cancer or an
infection or trauma physical trauma
questions seeing none great thank you I
could have gotten into all the details
questions also signed up to speak is
hello again Mr chair and my colleagues
for the record I am representative
alandre Murray from Manchester Ward n
and I'm here testifying an opposition to
this bill similar to my testimony on the
other bill this morning at the end of
the day I do not believe the legislature
should be making healthc care decisions
for any individual especially for
children who are involving their doctors
and parents in these decisions already I
will share some data on the topic but I
also wanted to share my own experiences
with accessing gender affirming surgery
I've been considering Top surgery for
the past decade but have faced barrier
after barrier and actually getting this
care only two surgeons in the state are
covered by my insurance policy and for
different logistical reasons that I
won't get into for the sake of time I'm
not able to go to either of these
surgeons my only option is to pursue out
of network care considering these
surgeries cost thousands of dollars and
will likely put me out of work for weeks
I have been at a standstill for years
where I am literally unable to get
health care that I need that my doctor
knows I need and this is my experience
as a 30-year-old now imagine how much
harder it is to access these surgeries
as a minor all of this is to say that
not only are these surgeries uncommon
but they are actually inaccessible to
many people with gender dysphoria
especially since trans individuals are
more likely to experience poverty and
less likely to have health insurance
coverage you must intentionally seek
this care out and you must be able to
afford it those are two huge Turtles
gender airic surgeries are rare in
minors with 282 masectomy performed in
2021 by contrast 20,000 people a year
undergo treatment for male breast growth
a study published in jamama Pediatrics
medical journal researched the effects
of female to male Top surgery on chest
dysphoria among transmasculine and
non-binary adolescents and young adults
it included 70 patients half of which
underwent surgery and half of which did
not this study found that gender
affirming Top surgery across the board
improved feelings of dysphoria gender
congruence and Body Image in young trans
adults and that surgery complications
were extremely minimal data has
demonstrably proven that gender
affirming surgeries not only have a low
rate of regret but also one of the
lowest rates of regret amongst all
surgeries a total of 27 studies
conducted by the American Society of
plastic surgeons pulling
7,928 transg transgender patients who
underwent any type of gender affirming
surgery concluded that the prevalence of
regret after surgery was less than 1% in
other words
99.7% of trans individuals were
satisfied with surgery meanwhile up to
30% of individuals who undergo knee
surgery experien regret up to 25% of
people regret getting heart surgery 30%
report regret after a prostate ectomy
and
19.5% express regret after a bariatric
surgery yet all of these procedures are
still legal when it comes to
detransition according to 2022
statistics only around 3% of trans
people experience 15 seconds some form
of regret but may not D transition
conversely 97% of people who transition
are happy with their decision I'll send
more of these uh data points later to
ensure you can understand them but only
5% of people who detransitioned did so
because they felt transition was not
right for them that's 0 4% of all trans
people we should not be changing laws
based on the opinions of point 4% of a
1% of the population okay thank you any
questions representative
Weber thank you I wasn't writing fast
enough so thank you for taking my
question thank you Mr chairman um you
talked about
282 uh mastectomies for gender
transition was that in state or is that
nationally that was nationally okay and
if I may have a followup follow up and
what was the statistic for um reduction
for um is it
macromastia um for for male breast
growth yes yes 20,000 people a year 20
okay thank you very much representative
Kastle ring thank you Mr chair so I
didn't hear it specifically did you say
that these numbers were for people under
the age of 18 for the um the
mastectomies yes for the um for the uh
for male surgery I'm not positive if
that one was specific um but I will I'm
going to send all of the um data I'm
talking about in my testimony to the
committee
afterwards other
you also signed up to speak is
thank
you there's a lot of testimony from
Dartmouth Health when we go through
these
bills and they say a lot of things
sometimes they say things don't
happen well I wanted to just talk about
something that I have seen myself with
someone who is personally known to me
and that would be a a girl who was about
16 years old at the time and she had a
double mastectomy it was um I consider
it elective
surgery myself because she had it in the
process of
transitioning she has detransitioned and
has a child she would not be able to to
breastfeed when I was a firsttime
mom
every uh Penny had to be watched very
closely one thing that made life a lot
better for myself and my CH my child was
my ability to breastfeed it was much
cheaper than using
formula and there were a lot of times
when I had to I was working full-time
and a lot of times when I traveled for
business and you couldn't you couldn't
pump you were on the convention floor
all
day that was extremely painful and
that's because you're
you're used to nursing or pumping at a
certain time and when you can't do that
it's very
painful I can only imagine what it's
like for someone who has no way to
relieve that no matter what after you
have a a child your body does naturally
produce
milk I would not like that I would not
wish that on anyone I had some breast
surgeries between my two children to
remove tumors they turned out to be
benign thankfully and then other times
um other tumor that may not have been
benign
but I wasn't able to nurse on one side
it was a it made a big difference in my
life and my ability to um take care of
my child uh there are tremendous health
benefits in
breastfeeding uh I think
that teenagers are too young to make
these decisions we as a legislator have
made decisions about teenagers we do it
all the time that they're not allowed to
buy scratch tickets they can't go to a
tanning
bed scratch tickets okay so if they're
not allowed to buy scratch
tickets this kind of surgery is also
something that I think they're not
mature enough for give it some time let
them grow up thank you that's that's my
tesy any questions yeah any questions
um laa from Bradford New Hampshire I'm
not Peri is
it looks like k i r u TS
y
kitzy oh okay I'm
sorry okay I'm
sorry okay also signed up to speak uh is
leave is she out
there no
okay all right next up uh to speak is
Diana
George hello
again thank you for taking the time to
listen to
me I'm again not going to read my whole
thing again because it's very similar to
the last one but I will tell
you that after my son started
testosterone well first of all I'm going
to tell you that I have permission from
my 23-year-old son almost 24 to testify
about this very very personal matter
that is none of your businesses
none but I will since you're forcing me
to when my son after being on
testosterone and puberty walkers for a
couple of years he wanted to have what
the transgender community refers to as
Top surgery a double myectomy if if you
want to be medical about
it at first we were very
hesitant it's a very very difficult
decision to make as a parent for your
child and it includes a lot of medical
research in talking to your medical the
medical doctors the therapists the
psychiatrist and so on and at first we
tried to ask to assuage him
by allowing him to wear What's called a
breast
binder I don't know if you guys have
ever put one of those on it's similar to
a sports bra but even more tighter it's
extremely
hot so we did this for a while and it
skin So
eventually deciding that he knows who he
is we've been doing this for several
years
now we're going to allow him to do this
and so we
did he is now almost 24 years old he
just graduated couple years ago from NYU
Tish he's a successful thriving person
and yes he doesn't have female breasts
anymore because he is not a
female he is male and he goes to the
beach and he takes his shirt and yes he
might have a few
scars big deal he's happy he's thriving
mind your own business and as for the
person talking about breastfeeding not
being able to breastfeed how stupid I'm
a woman I tried to breastfeed it didn't
work out so I switched to formula having
being able to breastfeed is not all
about being a woman or
okay moving
on also signed up to speak is nathy
Nancy
Beerman she left
okay also signed up to speak uh is
Courtney Tanner from Portsmouth uh
Dartmouth
Health good Afternoon brother record
Courtney Tanner senior director of
government relations at Dartmouth health
and we are here to oppose um House Bill
712 um as testified earlier we concerned
about the interference with patient
provider the patient provider uh
relationship also have concerns about um
access to Medical Care necessary medical
care when we take a bill and codify the
practice of medicine there was
assertions made that um if there are
exceptions that um need to be added to
the bill later in time we can do that
but we have we have
concerns um in a broad brush way of when
we when we codify medicine RIT large
there are um there could be gaps in time
where this legislative process takes
time patients might need to access care
in that time and so um always think that
it's uh uh very dangerous to legislate
medicine at large
um we also have concerns about uh a the
inability for a provider to prefer this
type of care here in New Hampshire we
actually don't provide Top surgery for
minors so um while the vast majority of
the bill wouldn't impact access to care
for patients in New Hampshire right now
we do have referrals for the this
patient population that are referred to
out of state so um we would be concerned
about access to care for the very very
very small number of patients who need
referrals for this type of care that
receive this type of care out outside of
New Hampshire I am happy to take
questions
um that that's simple testimony uh
chairman McDonald thank you very much
anyone any questions representative
Weber thank you very much and thank you
for taking my question harking back to
the uh Workforce concerns that we had in
the earlier bill can you see anything in
this bill which might impact the
decision of somebody who provides this
kind of
surgery uh from that that might deter
them from coming to the
state and thus providing surgery not not
to the very few but to the many who need
them right so I think you're referring
to patients who are over 18 and older um
so yeah we would have concerns about um
P providers who are providing gender
affirming care for the adult population
um who may be concerned about providing
that type of care here in New Hampshire
we also would have concerns about again
that Peds and Endo um chronologist
Specialty Care providers who um would
have concerns about their ability to uh
provide their patients with a warm
handoff for care that they needed
outside the state of New Hampshire this
is um uh it's scary when the legislature
starts to criminalize and penalize
practice of medicine even a referral
thereof other
you Al also signed up to speak is
Katherine uh
time can you just turn on your
mic there we go okay honorable members
of the committee my name is Katherine
sarus and I am a Performing Artist and
educator I urge you today to pass this
bill HB 712 during my early puberty I
would often lie on my chest hoping and
praying that I could keep my breasts
from growing or um forming as a survival
of childhood sexual assault I was
terrified of becoming a woman I viewed
being a woman as making me vulnerable to
further sexual assault moreover because
I had a dream of becoming a dancer I was
convinced that I needed to lose weight
and have a flat chest because within the
classical Dance World emaciated
prepubescent looking dancers were and
still mostly are the ideal as a
10-year-old I managed to lose 20 pounds
in 10 weeks through self-
starvation and I experienced routine
suicidal ideation I've already expressed
in my previous testimony how I weathered
the storm of puberty and was able to
heal from the trauma and the childhood
sexual assault that I experienced the
reason that you don't see more
detransitioners and desisters coming
forward isn't because they don't exist
it's because standing up here in front
of you is really hard every time any of
us come and tell you a part of our story
we have to relive part of that
trauma it's absolutely impossible for
many of these people because I I tell
you I'm from the dance Community right
and it's a hot bed of lgbtqia plus
ideology I have listened for over 15
years to the stories of my colleagues
and co-workers
many of them my dearest
friends so many heart-rending stories of
childhood drama sometimes inflicted by
their
parents it's really really
important that you guys don't allow this
kind of Mutilation of the body to
continue to minors when people are
adults they have their own ideas they
can change their bodies however they
want when we are children we should be
protected and we're looking to you the
state of New Hampshire is looking to you
the next generation is looking to you
are you going to protect these
girls or are they just going to be a
casualty
again we've fought so hard to get to
being having equality in sports to being
able to be the women that we are to
having women serving here in this room
are you really ready to now Rob us I
can't tell you how many times I go into
an audition and the boys get like seven
times that they're shown the the the
combination and I'm shown the
combination one time and then there's a
guy who wants to do my part and put on
my point shoes like I'm already 103
girls to seven boys down 15 seconds so
in short I just really want you to
rethink this please vote for this bill
pass this Bill thank thank you so much
for listening to my testimony thank you
any
here I think you can go ahead okay thank
you
herzler good afternoon my name is Seth
herzler and as I said before I am a
21-year-old transgender man and I vly v
I oppose this bill um I understand uh
Lisa merer that you are the primary
sponsor of this bill I request that you
please address your comments to the
committee as a whole okay yes but I
request that you listen to what um the
people that would be affected by this
bill have to say like genuinely listen
um I had a double mastectomy when I was
16 we paid for it out of pocket after
losing a year-long battle with insurance
I assure you that I was told at every
possible juncture about the risks I was
not pushed into getting surgery in fact
it was an uphill battle the entire time
but when I woke up tired and in pain
after my surgery I did not regret it and
I have not regretted it in the 5 years
since you are not proposing protections
for children with this bill you are
simply harming them your exception to
the rule written out in chapter 3
32 um M makes this painfully clear you
allow for male circumcision surgery for
surgery on minor miners with disorders
of sex development among others these
are all gender affirming care fathers
choose to circumcise their babies
because it conforms to their perception
of what a man's body ought to look like
men and boys with gamasa chasa remove
excess brush tissue for the same reason
parents can sent to surgeries for their
intersex newborns because they want
their baby to conform to the
expectations about the
conflation of sex and gender these are
surgeries why are these surgeries often
done without the child's consent okay
but a child a trans adolescent deciding
to get Top surgery is
not thank you for your time and have a
good day thank you any
questions seeing none thank
good afternoon
again I've been testifying in a number
of States including that in my home
state of Indiana and so I wanted to make
the committee aware of this anecdote
which is not only in Indiana because
I've I've heard similar cases from uh
many different states and uh Jamie might
be able to validate this as well um when
I was giving testimony on a similar bill
in Indiana that prohibited all
clinicians from doing these types of
procedures on children uh one of the
heads the co-heads of the Riley
Children's Medical Center in
Indianapolis gave testimony that none of
these surgeries were happening in the
state I had independently been told uh I
had no evidence but I'd been
independently told by other sources that
they were doing these surgeries in the
state so after testimony and we went
into the hallway I approached the other
doctor who was the co-head of the clinic
at the time and I said I've heard other
evidence that they are doing uh double
masectomy on girls in this state can you
can you tell me why I've heard that and
he said well you know we're not we're
not doing gender affirming care but if
these girls get referrals to surgeons
and they do a little breast reduction
that really has nothing to do with
us uh in my own history I have had
doctors um before before this was
considered a field transgender medicine
and what I was doing was considered a
lot more uh subversive I had
endocrinologists who would use false ICD
codes to describe my care so as to avoid
uh any problems with the insurance
companies so my ICD code would have been
listed as other endocrine condition uh
likewise these girl who are being
referred to breast reduction surgery uh
coincidentally that they are patients of
gender affirming care clinics are very
likely being coated to have breast
reductions when in fact they are having
uh gender affirming double masectomy so
um I wanted to make you aware of that
because the the people who are who are
providing these types of procedures know
they have a place book on how to hide
the ball so that they can either get
around legislation or that they can get
around
Regulators uh if it's happening in
Indiana Midwest fly over country um it's
not a surprise to me at all if it's
happening in a state that is the
neighbor of one of the largest child
gender clinics in the country thank you
thank you representative
Drew thank you Mr chairman Corey as an
adult who clearly has transitioned as
far as one can go would you tell a young
child that they can successfully
transition
uh uh representative uh transition to
what
please transitioned uh from male to
female from male to female um one cannot
change sex one can have a number of
procedures to create the
the appearance The Superficial
appearance of changing sex uh although
as we're seeing more and more some of
these procedures uh for the double
masectomy uh have additional
modifications I saw a photo of a girl
recently who had her nipples fashioned
into Hearts so uh that's I wouldn't call
that uh to try to transition to the
seeing none thank you oh sorry
representative
damus thank you Mr chairman um Do You
Believe minors should be allowed uh to
have surgical interventions related to
their
gender surgical interventions for gender
uh this is this is one of the weirdest
conundrums for all of us to face which
is that if you believe that you're
authentic self is more feminine in your
male or masculine in your woman then for
some reason these surgeries are supposed
to somehow confirmed that so if if you
are already authentically suppose we
take the uh presumption that that
somebody does really identify as the
opposite gender let's just take that
sincerely uh there shouldn't be a need
for additional surgical modifications to
make that any truer or more factual than
the assertion it doesn't it doesn't
build on the assertion so really what
we're doing is providing uh
surgical uh affirmations to somebody's
identity and I don't I don't know of any
other use of medicine where we affirm
medically other
questions okay I think it's safe this
banama uh hello once again I just like
to say that I had to write my legal name
just because this is the legal setting
uh but I would prefer that to be
referred to by Oliver in future like
questions I understand you just rating
what I put I have no um issue with that
um so I'd just like to start by the
people who are saying that sex is binary
it's actually not it's a bimodal
distribution which essentially means
that there are right it's on spectrum
and there are two main categories people
tend to fall into one certain range that
we consider male and one certain range
that we consider female the range in
hormone levels the difference in various
secondary sex characteristics are all
examples of the fact that sex is in fact
not a strict binary um I'd like to just
address real quick the kind of people
we're talking about so we're talking
about people so the medium age for these
surgeries this is according to the
National Institute of Health by the way
um the median age of these people is
17.1 and the mean age is 16.9 so these
people are very well close to adulthood
um
they also have had to have prevalence of
dysphoria and diagnosis for four years
as well as significant counseling um for
those who are saying this is
experimental this surgery has existed
since the
1930s um and this is only a surgery
that's happening to point quote uh to 0
2% not even uh children who are trans um
there is a 0% rate of people attempting
to reverse these Ser surgeries and they
have a 90% success rate um in reducing
suicidality and depression um compared
compared to 20% for anti-depressants um
the decrease in depression specifically
diagnoses went from 68 to 44 and anxiety
from 70 to
44% um the median regret rate on the 100
point scale was Zero um and additionally
according to the American Society of
plastic surgeons uh the to in order to
access these surgeries they must have uh
persistent documented distress informed
consent and only before are these
surgeries are only performed under the
age of majority when delaying surgery
would cause notable harm to the patient
um so I'd like to just note that these
are happening on an extremely rare basis
is in the case where this child very
often will not survive or will not
survive very well to the age of
adulthood when they would typically get
these surgeries um I'd also like to
bring up earlier how we t uh the the
treatment of intersex children and
circumcision is not brought up and this
would more be re relevant to uh previous
genitalia bills that have attempted to
be passed um but those are not excluded
in this bill which I find uh intriguing
given it specifically seems to be
transgender youth that you were
targeting rather than the larger issue
of for example CIS girls getting breast
augmentation which actually has a much
higher regret rate again which has
already been stated um I'd also like to
bring up the fact that um the majority
of people who are trans um and go
through these surgeries again have very
low regret rates um and I'd also like to
bring up the uh um descriptions of such
treatment as child abuse I will be
quoting my mother here who has a
doctorate in Psychology and does trauma
informed trainings and did her
dissertation on gender and child abuse
um so this is going by the state
definition of child abuse it is harm
inflicted Upon a Child um it tends it
does psychological harm to the welfare
of that
child yep the research will show that
transgender children who receive support
from their caregivers including medical
transition have better psychological
outcomes contrary to the definition of
psychological abuse and I'd also just
like to add one last thing um the people
who were saying the dsm5 just involved
um how you perform gender and like the
toys you play with that's just not true
it's a market in congruence between
one's uh experienced gender and primary
and secondary sex characteristics and
desire to move against those thank you
very much does anyone have any questions
thank you any questions representative
Weber I just wanted to be sure thank you
for taking my question and thank you Mr
chairman I just wanted to be sure that I
understood the statistics you were
quoting on the median age of 17.1 and
the mean of 16.9 that is the median and
the mean matically among the very small
percentage of minors who have breast
surgery yes who like act specifically
gender affirming care that is the mean
and median age like mathematically okay
thank you yeah representative Kastle
rang thank you Mr chair so I was trying
to follow you just to make sure I
understood everything so you specified
in there that about death for people
that so you said something about death
that doesn't happen for based on getting
care I don't know if you remember what
you said I don't believe I mentioned
death can you put the context around it
for me I'd have to go back and watch the
video but there was a specific part
where you said something about that
causes death so just curious uh let me
read through my notes real quick and
okay oh are you referring to the part
where people who would typically either
attempt like are notable I was referring
to death in the sense that these
children would typically attempt or
possibly successfully attempt suicide by
the time they reached 18 if they were
not to acquire these surgeries okay okay
yes yeah so it's specifically death
usually related to extreme psychological
distress that is being caused in part by
gender
dysphoria and this is the uh like
acknowledged course of treatment by
pretty much every ma Major Medical
Association in my previous uh written
testimony there's a whole list that's
else saying no one else thank you thanks
so much
scare good afternoon distinguished
chairman and members of the
committee I urge you to support this
bill Claire a 20-year-old ER
transitioner said of her mastectomy at
14 if a 14-year-old girl comes to you
and says this isn't just teenage angst I
actually have a magical male gender
spirit and you need to cut parts of my
body off or I'm going to kill myself
your response shouldn't be right away
sir our bodies are real gender
identities are imaginary based on
stereotypes discomfort and fantasy if
Health experts s think I'm mistaken I
defy them to define gender identity
without relying on circular reasoning
but we teach girls the opposite troubled
girls especially those with autism or
trauma are taught that their bodies are
mistakes that stand in the way of them
being their authentic selves my friend
pra Mosley was going to come here and
testify she had a breakdown when she was
on the flight and couldn't make it she
sent me this I had complications as a
result of the double myectomy I was
prescribed to cure my mental distress
years after the surgery I detransitioned
my detransition led to a pregnancy and
complications arose as a results result
of giving birth my milk came in but
because of the nature of my surgery my
nipples are decorative they were removed
reshaped and reattached in the wrong
spot I had no way to feed my baby the
pain was like none I've ever felt before
and changed my whole perception of pain
as a whole no girl should have her
breast removed because she is sad no
child should be deprived of his mother's
milk because a surgeon made money from
someone's pain I urge you to protect
girls from this destructive ideology and
let them reach adulthood with their
bodies intact girls are wonderful as
they are and they don't need to remove
body parts in order to mature into Happy
adults um I also remind you of my
testimony about these regret rates and
how they're entirely concocted with
irrelevant data High Dropout rates and
shortterm
follow-ups thank you any
also signed up to
Barry good afternoon um thank you for
taking the time to hear my testimony my
name is Brady Barry I'm a resident of
Rochester and I'm here to test by an
opposition of HP
712 this bill would take away the rights
of transgender non-binary kids and take
away their autonomy to make healthc care
decisions with their caregivers and
doctors I personally got gender
affirming Top surgery on June 29th
2023 I was lucky to have my mom at my
side as I woke up from the anesthesia
and the first thing I remember saying is
this is the best day of my
life I can confidently say that getting
surgery changed my life
at the time I was 22 so while this bill
would not have stopped me from receiving
care there are many youth who deserve
access to gender affirming care which
includes these
surgeries getting surgery and before
that starting gender starting hormone
replacement therapy saved my life I say
that confidently and without
exaggeration I'm part of the statistics
you hear so often and you've heard today
about lgbtq plus Youth and suicide and I
spent years struggling with my mental
health I was hospitalized twice at after
attempting to end my own life but let me
be clear the problem was never my gender
or the fact that I'm transgender the
problem was lack of access to care and
the hate for the lgbtq lgbtq plus
community that I'm a part of this bill
would put young people at risk of mental
health struggles that can be potentially
fatal there's an easy to seee impact on
my own mental health from before and
after I received gender affirming care
meaning that after I started hormones I
stopped hurting myself and have not been
hospitalized again after my top surgery
this trend only continued and I have
never been happier as a trans kid just a
few years ago and having I was a trans
kid just a few years ago and having
access to gender affirming care ensured
that I could grow into a happy trans
adult I urge you not to take I urge you
not to take this opportunity away from
youth in a state where we so proudly
tell our residents to Live Free or Die
Why are we not giving this Val
vulnerable group transgender and
non-binary youth the opportunity to live
free please consider opposing HB 712 to
help ensure safe access to gender affing
affirming surgery for youth thank you
for your time thank you any
you also signed up to speak is Doug
pounds
Mr chairman and committee thank you
again um round
two um I'll make this brief um I just
want to make what I believe are some U
my inter for some clear distinctions in
the bill which I support one is um
surgery for physical pathologies those
exceptions I think are are pretty clear
and I think um from the transgender
perspective it's a
psychological pathology and don't treat
psychological pathologies with physical
surgical responses in
general um so I think the Bill's pretty
clear on that and offers affords good
protections um I just want to rate
relate a quick
story um my wife and I have had uh
Dartmouth Hitchcock as a provider at one
point and uh my uh my
bride um was was talking with her
provider I and the
provider was kind of a little bit be
beside himself of course you know not
violating any of the HIPPA laws or
anything but um had a patient
um um who was 16 and and confided that
the reason she was there was because she
was dealing with um female changes as as
an adolescent and
lied about being transgendered to be
able to have surgeries to um get rid of
her female parts to not have to deal
with um the the tribulations of
menstration and whatnot um
so I I just find it odd you know that a
16-year-old um you know what it what
what's going through their mind you know
when you
know at those times and and lied about
it so
um I
think
the our young uh minors need to be
protected against things like that
because that could be a very disastrous
decision I think um if she was allowed
to go through that and later had serious
regrets um that's all I have to say on
this topic for now thank you very much
and any question questions thank you any
lucier um hello again I am speaking in
opposition of this bill and I'm going to
go right into discussing the process of
getting Top surgery to start this
surgery cannot um be performed while the
individual's breasts are still
developing this is only performed on
older
teenagers now to even get access to this
surgery you must get a referral to an
endrocrinologist these doctors are not
the ones who perform any surgery they
prescribe
HRT after waiting several months to get
an appointment the individual must be
evaluated by one sometimes two
therapists before this surgery is even
considered most surgeons require that
the individual has been on HRT for one
or sometimes two years as there are
changes to muscle mass and fat
distribution in those first two
years after the work with the therapist
or therapists the individual will will
either start HRT or in those very rare
cases they will get a referral to a
surgeon
for that process they are first going to
be evaluated by a therapist again to
have a statement written deeming this
person ready for this surgery that
letter deeming them ready will be sent
to the surgeon's office and the
individual will again wait months for
this consultation
appointment that appointment the surgeon
will also assess if they believe this
individual is ready for this surgery and
tell them all the side effects of it
if they then pass that evaluation they
will move on to health tests to make
sure they are even capable of handling
any sort of surgery only if those tests
come back clear can they actually
prepare for any surgical
procedures this process takes several
months sometimes years personally I've
waited three years to even get into the
process of this
surgery this is not a procedure being
done on a whim minor are not getting
this surgery in schools or in their
primary care physicians offices they are
going through years of preparation to
get to this point this bill aims to take
away Top surgery for only those born
female not those born male who develop
excess breast tissue if you don't want
people to change the body that they were
born with because they aren't old enough
to make that decision then CIS male
miners shouldn't receive gender
affirming care either it's no one or for
everyone you don't get to pick and
choose I would like to add this bill
targets once again only people born
female and the arguments I have heard
are all about reproductive Health do not
tiptoe around what you are saying say it
outright you only see people born female
as reproductive
stock my sources are included with my
statement online I will not be taking
questions and thank you for your time
Warner Dr Warner left
okay also signed up to speak is jacquel
I thought he was going to steal my
thunder anyhow thank you to the chair
and to all of the distinguished
committee members for hearing my
testimony today in front of you can you
hear me
yes I am Jacqueline pounds currently res
residing in gtown New Hampshire
as a four-time breast as a four-time
cancer survivor I am well acquainted
with the pain of multiple
surgeries in
2006 2008 at 47 I was diagnosed with
breast cancer upon my doctor's advice I
chose to undergo a radical Mass ectomy
with hormone suppression to give me the
best chances of a five-year survival
rate faced with that
decision you can imagine I was under
much
duress I can personally attest that this
surgery was extremely
painful and extremely
disfiguring my choice seemed obvious
just get rid of it I was told we will
build you a new breast
Mound I noted that
my surgeon my plastic surgeon refused to
use the word new
breast promises
promises my Plastics oh I got that
sorry also consider the emotional pain
of losing such an intimate part of your
body I was a very anxious young woman
making a very difficult
decision today I live with a hard
Mound which no longer even looks like a
breast I have no nipple and I have
encapsulation I must not have been
part I must now pay close
attention to everything my doctors tell
cancer these young girls I'm sorry I
can't speak from this anymore these
young
girls depend on us their parents to make
decisions for them I was not ready at 47
years old to lose a breast and we're
letting 18 year olds 17 year
olds I'm sorry but even younger lose
theirs
when I was a young
girl I hated my breasts they hurt I
hated mensturation you seconds thank you
thank you for your
you also signed up to speak is Chris
Chris herchel from clad law um I am not
going to reiterate everything I said
previously but uh I oppose this bill
because of the same constitutional
infirmities as the other Bill we were
discussing this morning but I would like
to talk specifically um about the uh
referral provision in this bill uh
surgery is very serious um and it's very
rarely indicated for people under the
age of 18 when it comes to gender
transition um but I just want to draw
attention to the fact that this bill
prohibits referrals and you know free
speech is a concept that is cherished in
both our state and federal
constitutions um and the right to free
speech doesn't just include the right to
communicate information to express
yourself even if you're a medical care
provider but also it includes
encompasses the right to receive
information the right to receive
information and advice from people who
have expertise to help you figure out
what the best path forward is for you
and for your family um I'm drawing
attention to this because I want you I I
really think it's important for
everybody to imagine the situation in
which there's there's a if it's possible
that there's one 17-year-old who might
need surgery maybe once they reach the
age of 18 one 17-year-old whose distress
is so severe and they are being blocked
from getting information from doctors
about possible courses of care that
could relieve their distress if there's
one person who could experience that
level of distress that that could reach
you then please consider amending this
bill uh to eliminate the provision on
referrals um I'm happy to take questions
thank you any questions representative
kessle thank you Mr chair so I had to
look it up because I wanted to know
after the last hearing you mentioned the
constitutionality so I wanted to get
your opinion on something um article
four of the New Hampshire Constitution
gives us the right under the law and all
the challenges that have happened on
specific cases where the legislature has
enacted laws for health and safety I'm
just curious how you would say that this
article 4 uh let's say how that affects
this because you're talking about the
constitutionality of both of these bills
okay so referring back to what I was
talking about the Constitutional
infirmities of the bill this morning I
was referring to the 14th Amendment of
the US Constitution which protects the
right of individuals to be freed from
discrimination and the rights of parents
to make decisions on behalf of their uh
of their children to direct the
upbringing of their children um so when
when the New Hampshire Constitution
allows for uh the right for the state
legislature to govern for safety and
health which in fact is um you know um
assumed or presumed to be the right of
State legislatures under the US
Constitution as well under the
principles of federalism uh there are
limitations on what that when when it
comes to discriminating against people
and when it comes to interfering with
the right to raise your children right I
mean the question when it comes to um
the right to access medical care for
your children it's who gets to decide do
parents get to decide or does the state
get to decide and I understand that the
state is responsible for governing
health and safety but the fundamental
question about who gets to decide I
think the our federal and state
constitutions have long said that it's
up to parents it's up to parents to
decide what's best for their children
because it's not the role of states to
do that yeah I was just curious if you
had any reference because I know the US
Constitution but I was article four is a
little different than other states
because a lot of them don't have the
same rules that we have and that's in
court that's how the provisions have
different things lawsuits have been put
aside let's say so I'm just curious on
that but oh so to clarify the US the
14th Amendment of the United States
Constitution applies uniformly to every
in every state in the constit and sorry
in every state in the country regardless
of what the state constitution
says anyone
scare hi I'm Beth scare I'm a
grandmother from Nashua and I'm here to
testify my strong support for HB 712 to
protect girls from double mctoy D
transitioners Katie Anderson and Pria
Mosley had their breasts removed Katie
also had hysterectomy and had her
ovaries removed Katie was married in
nashwa a few months ago and because of
these missing body parts she can never
have
children pra had a baby last year and
she can't breastfeed him and suffered
terrible pain because of the milk
trapped in her milk
Ducks too many girls are having this
done at a young age what is the rush to
have their breasts
amputated why is it so critical to have
this done when these vulnerable girls
are 13 14 15 16 many of th of those who
support medical transition protest
loudly that kids aren't having these
operations even they are horrified that
it's happening these girls are suffering
from anxiety depression PTSD from sexual
abuse or the difficulties of a DHD or
Autism they are promised that when their
breasts are gone their problems will be
solved for a short time some feel the
Euphoria of getting rid of the supposed
source of pain but then the reality hits
that it didn't fix anything they have
the same problems they had before
compounded by the pain and Trauma of
losing healthy body
parts vot ought to pass on HB 712 to
protect vulnerable girls from losing
healthy body parts
thank you any
you also signed up to speak is Nancy
Brennan
I I still want to give testimony but I
was okay well that's it's good because I
I prefer one person testify at a time
so what you want me to go for yeah go
ahead he's Paul he's doing his card okay
seean I had yours all I was gonna do it
so
well Nancy Brennan I live in weer and I
appreciate all of you sharing this very
long very tough tough day with us um
there's not a lot I can say I I agreed
with the uh transgender Youth and those
who support their care I do not feel
like this is a good bill um but I would
be
remiss if I didn't say at some point
today that this bill the one we heard
this morning the one that just passed
out of executive committee on bathrooms
etc etc etc are part of a larger program
to other and even eliminate the
transgender Community we have a
president who spent
$222
million in hate ads before he got
elected and he said on several occasions
that little boys are going to school and
when they come home they're little girls
and I think you as legislators when you
go to vote on these you need to do a
couple of things one you need to make
sure that all the
socalled reviews and whistleblower
reports and so forth that those are
accurate you need to do your own
research the other thing I'd ask is that
pretend this
bill exists on its own here in New
Hampshire there we're not seeing this
kind of thing happening across the
country mostly in red States where
people have
decided politicians have decided that
this group of people is one that we can
go after you know there's a musical
called wicked and in it the wizard says
nothing brings people together like a
common enemy and for the transgender
community and their supporters as well
as for the immigrants we have found
those and I really hope you will look at
the health what the experts say there
are a lot of experts and I hope you will
look at what they have to say when you
questions okay also signed up to speak
thank you Mr chairman sorry about my uh
my tardiness and getting in the card a
little bit late uh thank you honorable
chair and committee members my name is
representative Heath Howard I represent
the towns of straford and barington and
straford District 4 it is my opinion
that as legislators we should always be
searching to do the most good and do the
least harm but this legislation provide
prevents access to a surgery that can
benefit the day-to-day lives
of its patients as someone who has had
multiple surgeries unrelated to this
topic it provides a perspective of how
someone feels when they're in pain I had
to wait four months with a broken back
to get surgery during covid because it
was quote an elective
procedure while it is a different
situation I understand what it's like to
suffer after being denied more immediate
treatment I see my situation no
differently than any other individual
seeking any treatment of any kind
if you are suffering you should be able
to you should be allowed to discuss
treatment options with your physician
and pursue whatever works best for that
patients needs this tramples all over
the individual liberties that we pride
ourselves on and ultimately removes
access to our right to bodily autonomy
this is no different than access to an
abortion or back surgery please leave
medical decisions up to their patients
and their medical providers thank you
thank you any questions
you also signed up to speak is Simon
Amor
price good afternoon my name is Simon
Amaya price thank you for introducing
this bill and allowing me to speak uh as
I mentioned earlier today my girlfriend
is a d transitioner her name is Luca
Hine you can look her up it's spelled l
u k a he i n she has told her story on
many podcasts and she is currently
involved in a lawsuit against her
healthc care provider uh she was given a
double mastectomy uh when she was 17 I
believe and she was placed on cross-
seex hormones for four years starting
from when she was a minor uh today she
regrets those decisions and has to and
has had to pay out of pocket for D
transition procedures including her
electrolysis and a tracheal shave to
remove her atoms Apple induced by
testosterone she is one of the many
detransitioners and regretter and larger
uh group of young women who have had
their breasts removed in the name of
what is essentially become a death
cult they say that if we are not given
these elective surgeries we will kill
ourselves this sounds very famili
familiar to me uh to Scientology for
example and there are many people who
have talked about these
comparisons um I will also venture to
add that my friend pra who unfortunately
couldn't be here is another D
transitioner who had her breast removed
uh now has a child and is unable to
breastfeed
um when I was 16 I was in my first year
of college I went to college two years
early and I went to college specifically
for um people who want to go to college
early
my first week was the first time I saw a
mastectomy scar it was on a 16-year-old
girl who had gotten it the year before
when she was
15 she was deeply
distressed and knowing her and being
close to her she was not in the right
mind I could not imagine how she could
have been in the right mind to make that
decision I had many other friends
growing up and recently who underwent
double mastectomies and these gender
affirming surgeries on February 25th a
study came out with the biggest sample
size of American patients we've seen yet
107,000 published in the Oxford press of
taking from NIH data this is a matched
cohort so we compared uh gender
dysphoric uh children or people
generally speaking it's not just
children um who did gender affirming
surgery and those who did not do gender
affirming surgery and those who did do
gender affirming surgery ra of
depression and anxiety were twice as
high all of the research we've had up to
this point is not longitudinal suffers
from high Dropout rates and essentially
is statistically
insignificant my girlfriend didn't
realize that what she did was wrong
until she was four or five years into
identifying as trans down to 15 seconds
yeah if you pull uh those from the D
transitioner subreddit how long they
identified as trans it averages six
seven eight years none of these studies
account for that W path recently
admitted that the D transition rate is
at least 30% they're an activist
organization so that's going to be
conservative estimate I am happy and
willing to answer any and all questions
you may have of me thank you any
questions representative
delus thank you Mr chairman um you
mentioned that you know quite a few
people who have had the double
mastectomy and and regret it were most
of them below the age of 18 all of them
were below the age of
18 um all of them were survivors of
sexual assault as well oh my god
um thank you
I anyone else representative K Castle R
thank you Mr chairman I was just curious
um with the experience that your
girlfriend has gone through has there
been any other adverse side effects and
issues that you've had to deal with
seeing it from the other side um the
reason she can't be here today is
because she suffers from chronic joint
pain uh related to the fact that she was
put on the wrong sex hormones for four
years of her life
um traveling is very difficult for her
and it makes her joint problems uh worse
um she would have liked to be an EMT she
can't she can't stand for that long she
she physically can't because these
so-called gender affirming procedures
have robbed her body's functional
ability to do a job which she's dreamed
of doing since she was a
child so
yes other questions representative
now tagging onto the qu onto this
question were were was she informed was
your girlfriend informed that this would
possibly keep her from doing the thing
that she wanted to do the most in life
no not at all and the reason for this is
poor Research into the side effects of
these surgeries and these crossx
hormones and the fact that in a lot of
cases contrary to what others have said
the evaluation period is very short uh
there was an article recently about the
Boston Children's gender Clinic which
I'm sure many people in New Hampshire
have gone to um they recently lowered
their intake um period from about like
some uh multiple meetings over a month
or two uh to get hormones down to just
two
hours other
Drew why didn't you do this you were on
track uh to get hormones and to to get
Top surgery and possibly bottom surgery
it my father said no way in hell he
cussed out my pediatrician he cussed out
every single Doctor Who referred me to a
gender Clinic my pediatrician quit a
year later so I think that has something
to do with it um if not for him if he
were affirming I wouldn't be sitting
here today maybe I would be dead maybe I
would have osteoporosis maybe my
genitalia wouldn't be intact
maybe I would have one of the the many
complications that so many of my friends
have to live with for the rest of their
life for example my friend Richie who
has to um do dialysis on a daily or
weekly basis for his Neo vagina uh for
the rest of his life due to the penal
inversion
surgery other
here
black thank you I appreciate you
allowing me to speak
chairman I submitted my testimony online
um I also have this one written copy my
name is Jennifer black I'm from Windam
New
Hampshire I would have given anything to
not have
breasts when I was two I started
screaming whenever my mother tried to
put me in a dress and frankly if someone
tried to put me in a dress now I might
scream I despise dolls my favorite toy
was a truck I wanted to be one of the
guys and for a long time I was I played
baseball climbed trees split wood jump
bikes and hung out with the boys
everything was
great but then puberty reared its ugly
head I watched in utter dismay as my
body transformed the identity I had
created for myself was upended I was no
longer one of the guys they looked at me
differently talked to me differently I
felt like I was a no man's land no pun
intended girls were not my friends I
didn't really to them at all boys were
treating me like an alien I became
reclusive and shy if only I could have
been born a boy if only I could stop the
growth of these breasts that were a
symbol that everyone could see that I
was what I absolutely did not want to be
a
woman that was then I am now a happily
married mom of six children all of whom
I nursed including twins I stand here
today grateful that I grew up in the 70s
and 80s and not today I stand here today
with my heartbreaking for the girls who
are not given the privilege I had to
grow up without chemicals and surgery I
shudder to think where I would be if I
grew up in today's environment of quick
fixes and instant gratification I
shudder to think what would have
happened if the trans industry existed
back then and offered me the opportunity
to become a boy to remove my breast I
have no doubt that I would have leapt at
that opportunity and I would have faced
a lifetime of regret
my heart aches for the young girls who
are being told that they were born in
the wrong body and need irreversible
surgery and chemicals to fix it that's
not what they need what they need is
what I was privileged to have they need
the gift and privilege of time to mature
and grow and gain perspective and time
to learn to accept their body and
understand that their body is a special
gift they need affirmation that although
being a woman is an immutable
characteristic there are infinite ways
to be a woman
they need affirmation that we are all
created in a unique way and bring a
multitude of characteristics and traits
that are combined in our body to make us
a special person not one person is the
same as another and above all they need
adults to be
adults we are tasked with raising and
protecting children sometimes having to
protect them from themselves you're down
to 15 seconds we have the perspective
and experience to be able to tell them
that puberty is confusing and difficult
but they are strong and will'll get
through it just like we all did in
conclusion I ask that you please be the
adults in these girls' lives when so
many others are failing them stand for
keeping their beautiful bodies intact
stand for allowing them the privilege
and time to grow and mature and accept
their bodies as God created them give
them the opportunity to reach the
conclusion that I have reached that
being a woman and a mom is an incredible
blessing that I wouldn't have traded for
anything please vote for HB
colot hello
again all right this one I actually
wrote at like prepared for it at the age
of 19 and2 years old I underwent a
double Mast ectomy Top surgery on
January 14th 2025 my consultation for
this surgery took place at the age of 17
years old in early September 2022 you
may be wondering wondering why it takes
so long well cuz getting approved by
insurance and on the o schedule for an
elective surgery takes a long time this
is one of countless reasons why these
kinds of bills are pointless as their
sponsors continue to draft them as if
there's a pop-up gender clinic on every
street corner offering walk-in Services
clearly these people haven't a shred of
a clue of what reality truly is members
of both the state and the federal
government's insistent comp incessant
compulsion to propose legislation which
targets our individual rights as
Americans isn't just absurd but utter
waste of everyone's energy you cannot
call yourself a granite stator and rep
to live for your die motto if you
advocate for or comply with folks's
private medical business being put in
the hands of anyone but themselves or
their doctors these kinds of bills would
massively fail to Garner a whiff of
support if instead of merely appearing
to threaten queer people's ability to
access proper care their true purpose
was written in bold New Hampshire
lawmakers should have more control over
citizens' livelihoods than they do open
your eyes people the fear that you've
been conditioned to feel towards the
your community is ruining your lives
perhaps as much as it does ours because
admit it or not we are the same as you
I'm pretty sure sorry no I'll Circle
back to that in a second we all struggle
under and are subjugated by the system
in which we live so I'm sorry that you
see us as enemies for we could just as
easily be your neighbor if you gave us
the chance to show you who we really are
not what someone tells you we are let us
working folks stick together we are more
powerful that way and then I also just
wanted to address some crap that's been
being said someone just said not one
person is the same as another so why
would they stand for a bill that is
assimilating people or putting people
into boxes it doesn't really make any
sense to me it seems completely
contradictory if you think there are
countless countless ways to be a woman
then why would you be in support of this
kind of proposal that is giving strict
definitions to certain things
um yeah also people are told straight up
the surgery you're receiving will not
cure your dysphoria people are pred far
in advance by everybody involved in the
process so long as the doctors are good
doctors like not every doctor is a good
doctor and they might screw up but it
doesn't have anything to do with it
being trans care sometimes people suck
at their jobs and are incompetent
doesn't have to do with the fact that
trans people are the ones receiving
their care that doctor just might be
inept but anyway if it isn't an inept
medical system or facility or office or
whatever you do get warned this is not
going to solve all your problems you're
just chopping your boobs off that's what
it is that's what we all know it is I'm
just happy I did it and that's the
bottom line like we're happy about it
some people aren't you're right some
people are in so much pain from their
decisions but why would we make a law
that prohibits such a large portion of
people to not feel Joy just so a couple
of people can feel protected and
comforted this is the name of safety not
Comfort remember what this committee is
for it is not public Comfort it is that
jakow my name is Lind Jak housee I'm a
non-binary person and I had Top surgery
just before my 26th birthday day April
will be the 9th anniversary of my top
surgery and to this day it's one of the
best decisions I ever made that improved
my life for the better and the best
money I ever spent when I was going
through puberty I felt extremely
uncomfortable with my chest before I
knew the words transgender or non-binary
I wish I wished my chest could stay flat
forever I would wear multiple sports
bras in an attempt to flatten my chest
starting around age 10 or 11 when I was
a teenager I saw a documentary about a
trans man getting tops or and was
incredibly jealous of it and wished that
I was a trans man so I could get top
surgery in my early 20s I met a
non-binary person who had gotten Top
surgery and felt a ray of hope that I
could too I started wearing a binder to
flatten my chest which was very hot and
got filled with sweat in the summer and
I'll admit I wore it longer than the
recommended 8 hours at a time which can
make it hard to breathe qualifying for
Top surgery was not a quick and easy
process I had to see a gender therapist
for at least a year before getting a
letter of recommendation I was lucky to
be on my mom's insurance and to have her
support overall Top surgery cost around
$8,000 half of which was covered by my
mom's insurance and I saved every penny
I could over the course of a year on a
low salary job to come up with the other
$4,000 I had to pay out of pocket when I
woke up in the surgery room I had the
biggest smile on my face and I felt like
a weight had literally un figuratively
lifted off my chest and shoulders I felt
more confident and at home in my body
than ever before
many Studies have shown that regret
rates for Top surgery are 1% or less I'm
sorry for the small percentage of people
who have gone through the lengthy
process of being informed and then
regret the procedure but again that's
far lower regret rates than many other
medical procedures that we wouldn't
dream of banning I was fortunate to have
excellent healthc care and to be able to
make this decision for myself along with
my therapist and the surgeon without
politicians putting any additional
barriers in my way I hope to be a parent
someday and if my teenage child needed
top surgery I would support them every
step of the way although I was an adult
when I received this care it's no secret
that those who put barriers in the way
of trans people accessing Health Care
have moved the bar into bands on adult
care Arizona Georgia Idaho Kentucky
Mississippi Oklahoma Texas and Virginia
are seeking seeking to stop medical
Medicare Cade funds from being used for
this Health Care furthermore it's
discriminatory to ban the same procedure
for Trans people while allowing it to
continue on non-transgender girls who
have cancer or boys who have unwanted
breast growth it's the same procedure
yet it's only stigmatized by certain
politicians when it applies to
transgender or non-binary people stop
this double standard and oppose HB 712
and I'm happy to take questions any
you also signed up to speak is
representative Timothy
Horgan can take your code off first if
thank you very much um I don't want to
prolong your long day too much although
I did fill out a pink card so um this
bill I think this is a as I'm sure
you've heard uh heard before but just
very quickly this is something that um
you know young people and their families
and their medical uh professionals are
going to uh are going to should should
decide for themselves without like a
bunch of politicians like us inserting
ourselves into into the decision and
also
uh and uh so there are certainly
circumstances where uh so-called Top
surgery is probably most most people get
it are are
are adult age but there are some
legitimate reasons when minors uh miners
when miners need to need to take
advantage of it and um
so this is uh I think this bill uh this
bill is Bill is itl it's part of like
frankly a lot of uh anti- anti-trans
hatred you know directed at a uh
directed a very small community whose
lives are very difficult anyway and also
point out just the whole process of
transitioning is very very difficult so
a lot of the comments I've heard in the
past about it seem to think it's really
simple like to say oh a guy can just
foot of a wig or something but no it's
there's is
um regardless of whether you're adult or
a minoring to start it's an
extraordinarily difficult process and
people do it just because they know know
who they they already know who they are
so they uh want their bodies to conform
to who and what they already um know
themselves to be and um I guess I'll
just one thing I add new is that I have
a uh some friends who uh one of their
children belongs to a uh group on the
west Coast kind of a fren religious
group and they they firmly uh so they
firmly believe that you shouldn't assign
a gender to a child until the child's
old enough to speak for themselves and
so their their daughter gave birth to a
child who um clearly would normally be
assigned female at Birth everybody uh
you know so it was hard hard for them
for the first few years until the uh
child began speaking not to refer her
refer her as she but one of the very
first utterances uh that little girl did
who was a you know CIS female said I am
a girl and that's the same for you know
trans girls who maybe chromosomes aren't
the standard XX or otherwise for some
other reason are signed female male at
Birth they usually know their girls
right from the beginning from what I've
heard and uh just and uh you trans trans
boys usually know their boys right from
right from the beginning and so um so
this is a you know so usually the the
vast majority of cases uh you know the
person has an inkling right from when
they begin to have a sense of themselves
or be able to speak for themselves that
they are they are trans rather than uh
CIS like me so I'm just for the record I
am a CIS male so I'm my gender identity
is exactly what you'd expect from my
gender expression the way I look so at
least I hope that I you know I identify
as male exactly exactly what you would
probably think from from looking at me
and deal with me but that's that's not
true true for every 15 seconds okay
thanks well just I would say just please
itl this bill it's uh unnecessary and
have many many bad consequences so
thanks for your time okay thank you any
questions for representative Oregan I'm
right also signed up to speak is
hello members of the committee turn
hello members of the committee my name
is McKenzie West and I and I am here to
oppose HP
712 the truth of the matter is that
chest augmentation for gender
confirmation is of great importance to
many trans masculine and non-binary
individuals and miners undergoing such
procedures make a very small portion of
such procedures this law specifically
targets transmasculine and non-binary
individuals in a blatant to attempt to
discriminate this law cares out
exceptions for the medical necessity of
cisgender individuals often to reaffirm
their gender identity but why do we give
less Credence to trans masculine and
non-binary identities the surgical pre
prerequisits of chest augmentation of
often require years of therapy and many
many Hoops as others have stated the
barriers are already high and we regret
levels are low so why are we once again
trying to insert the state into medical
decisions of our families and their
doctors the few adolescents that this
bill affects know who they are and they
have known for a while jumping through
every hoop placed in their way to prove
it to others if we look at the timeline
of these surgeries for the few
adolescence that this bill affects we
can see that these kids are often coming
out of high school or preparing to to do
so and many are looking to go off to
college and radically changing lives
ahead of them often trying to escape the
bigotry and harassment that has followed
them for
years when you ask why they don't just
wait until adulthood it is simple it is
a radically changing time for many young
folks and they deserve to start a new
chapter of their life without bigotry
and dysphoria following them and
allowing them to really feel themselves
I urge you to vote itl on HP7 12 and to
Futures a set any
bakus thank you hello again
um I'm just going to quote something
from the an article in the American
Medical Association Journal of Ethics uh
the article is called what's wrong with
criminalizing gender affirming care of
Adolescence in the section
care the criminalization of gender
affirming care for adolescence is
emerged in multiple US states in the
last two years 25 us states have
introduced bills to restrict a access to
gender affirming medical care for
minors for example in 2021 Arkansas
became the first state to Outlaw
Physicians from providing gender
affirming care both hormonal and
surgical to minor patients via an
override of the governor's veto of the
bill in 2022 the Alabama legislature
passed and the government signed into
law a bill known as the Alabama
vulnerable child compassion and
protection
act prohibiting Physicians from
providing gender affirming care both
hormonal and
surgical to
minors often the motivation behind such
bills is political a new front on the
culture War targeting transgender
citizens for example in 2020 in January
2020 the South Dakota House
Representatives passed a bill
criminalizing provision of gender
affirming treatment to transgender youth
under the age of 16 shortly after the
legislator's failure to pass a bathroom
bill you might remember the bathroom
bill that was in front of the house
Judiciary Committee
recently poos genders affirming care
restrictions coming after failure of
bathroom bills are not unique and are
evidence of political animus as recently
noted in the Harvard Law review the
shift from stigmatization and
vilification of trans youth in the
bathroom bills to the victimization
narrative embodied in the gender
affirming care bands illustrates how
opponents of trans identity are adopting
their rhetoric in response to changing
legal and social attitudes towards
transgender
children there's more to the article I'd
yourselves please leave trans kids alone
I oppose this Bill thank you thank you
any
you also signed up to speak is Jamie
good afternoon this bill is critically
important for one simple statistic 73%
of those going to Pediatric gender
centers in the United States right now
are girls this is at the heart of the
huge debate over this care globally when
I started working in a pediatric gender
Center I had four to five new patients
per month and most of them were boys
when I left 5 years later I had 40 to 50
new patients per month and most of them
were adolescent females this sex
reversal has been reported in clinics
from Western Europe from Canada and the
United States and this has left many
scientists incredibly concerned in
England 15 years ago there were just 250
referrals to their gender service and
nearly all of them were boys 5 years ago
there were 5,000
and 75% of those were adolescent girls
this kind of complete and utter reversal
for a clinical presentation is almost
statistically never seen one hypothesis
is that these girls are just now feeling
free to identify as boys another
hypothesis is that we are actually
seeing a new kind of socially mediated
looping
Behavior what I know as a scientist is
that the safe thing to do is not to
remove any healthy body parts from any
miners until we actually have clear data
to understand what is occurring and that
means that this bill is necessary I also
work directly with patients who have had
these bilateral momies as
minors one of the most heart-wrenching
patient cases that I worked with had
this exact kind of surgery she was trans
identified when she had the surgery and
within 3 months she called the center
and begged for the surgeon to put her
breast back
on the surgeon refused to take her call
and refused to call her back the surgeon
punted that follow-up call to
me why because she had absolutely no
idea what to do in this situation and
she simply could not fathom that it
would have ever occurred the surgeon
also told me that she would not even
meet with this patient again until she
had an entire year worth of therapy and
a full psychological evaluation
that young woman re was required to have
neither of those things before we cut
off her
breasts the last I heard in this
follow-up case was that that young woman
was now pregnant she also grew up in
foster care and she had experienced
sexual trauma and had a substance abuse
disorder I also want to share that my
former spouse has also had this surgery
she was trans identified for years
before she had it and she now
permanently Mourns the loss of her
breasts it took years for her to process
this and to come to understand what
occurred for
her it was never in the original flawed
study to perform surgery on any minors
at all and it should not be allowed in
any state in America for surgeries like
this to continue I urge you to please
pass this
Bill thank you any questions
representative kessle ring thank you Mr
chair I have just one question is there
any um SA Statics because you've talked
a lot about statistics today and
different things that specifically
relate to uh other side effects that
could come from having these uh this
breast
surgery thank you for your question um
in my own spouse's case she had her
breast removed was in recovery and was
being given morphine she
coughed and suddenly had intense pain on
the flank side of her chest she had
actually torn open the inside sutures
and began to bleed out inside of her
chest she had to be taken in right away
right back in put back under the entire
thing had to be opened back up and she
had to have this emergency surgery to
repair the internal hemat she was
bleeding out inside of her
chest my close friend pra Mosley had
this surgery as a minor
she became pregnant she's had a baby we
now are seeing D transitioners who have
some of their milk Ducks still left in
their chest wall milk Ducks will create
and fill with milk once baby is born
regardless of some of these surgeries or
not she was in so much pain that she
could not hold her baby because she
could not put her baby to her chest
without the milk Ducks tightening and
hardening inside of chest wall so she
had to physically hold her baby in the
unnatural way that as a mom I've held
all of my infants we simply do not know
all of the outcomes that are going to
occur when we're cutting off breasts of
young women and seeing them mature into
older women who might potentially want
to have children of their own
pregnancies or honestly even
utilize this area area for sexual
function many women who've never had sex
before have no idea that removing this
sexual organ could literally impact them
for the rest of their life for their
ability to have orgasmic pleasure or to
have this part of their body be part of
an intimate relationship that they might
want to have with an adult later on we
just simply don't know what we're doing
to these
kids other questions representative d
thank you Mr chairman um how old were
the uh patients that were being
prescribed uh puberty blockers and
hormones when these surgeries were being
done so one one statement I heard was
that there is a requirement you take
testosterone first that's not in any
guideline there are many people who are
now stating that they are nonbinary and
seeking to just have their breasts cut
off without actually medically
transitioning in any way
um we had patients who were minors who
we were directly referring to
surgeons I
personally
helped uh go around insurance
requirements so insurance will cover
gynecomastia in insurance plans but will
not cover Top surgery often for minors
and so I was teaching parents how to lie
to get this surgery for their minor
children
other
you no one else has signed up to testify
on HB 712
FN uh I'm most afraid to ask does
anybody else wish to
testify seeing no one I'm going to close
the public hearing on this bill on 712
FN that is the last bill we had
scheduled for hearings today uh we will
be meeting again on Wednesday at 9:30
for additional hearings on other bills